FIVE ON OF LIKE SAFETY AND THE
JUDICIARY WILL.
IN.
AN WE ON OUR FIRST ITEM ON THE
AGENDA.
IS OUR OVERVIEW ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND SO WE WILL
RECEIVE THAT FROM OUR ACTING
SECRETARY RAFI IS --
DO WE NEED TO DO ROLL CALL YEAH
COLLEGES I DARE YOU PLEASE NO NO
PLEASE SAID WE'LL DO ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER I AM HERE CENTER
MORLOCK.
CENTER ABOUT.
RIGHT PLEASE FORGET ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WOMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION TO COME IN.
AND GO OVER THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AS ACTING SECRETARY
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU.
SOME OF THE CHANGES THAT I'VE
SEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AS I BEGAN MY CAREER
IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER.
WHEN THE POPULATION WITH ABOUT A --
HUNDRED THOUSAND SIXTEEN YEARS
LATER I WAS A CAPTAIN ON
FACILITY WHEN THAT THE
POPULATION GREW AND IT WAS AT
ITS HEIGHT AT A HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE THOUSAND SO I'VE SEEN.
THE CHANGES IN THIS POPULATION
AND MORE POORLY THE IMPACTS OF
OF THAT TYPE OF GROWTH IN.
OUR INABILITY TO DO CERTAIN
THINGS WITH THAT AMOUNT OF
POPULATION IS A HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AND THIS IS
BEEN MADE POSSIBLE IS A HUNDRED
AND WE JUST SAY THAT NUMBER
AGAIN.
THE DAYS POPULATION IS UNDER A
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
AND THAT'S BEEN THE FIRST TIME
SINCE --
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AND THAT'S
BEEN MADE POSSIBLE BY NUMEROUS
THINGS BUT I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST IMPACTS HAS BEEN
PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SEVEN WHICH IS EMPLOYMENT
WHICH IS VOTED BY THE VOTERS IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN AND
WE'VE.
HAD AND IN IMPLEMENTATION --
AND ONE OF THE FACTORS AND ONE
OF THE KEY THINGS THAT IN THAT
PROPOSITION AND ALLOW THE
SECRETARY. TO AWARD CREDIT
INMATES FOR PARTICIPATION IN
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS WHICH
PREVIOUSLY REQUIRED --
CHANGES IN A LONG.
WHAT PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN DID
FOR US WE HAVE SEEN THAT TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND NONVIOLENT
DETERMINE THE SENTENCE INMATES
BECAME ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE
SUITABILITY UNDER THE NONVIOLENT
PRO PROCESS?
CDC ARE ALSO ALSO IMPLEMENTED
REGULATIONS THAT ALLOWED INMATES
TO EARN CREDITS IN VARIOUS GAMES
WHETHER IT BE THROUGH --
TRADITIONAL IN MADE --
LEISURE TIME ACTIVITY GROUPS THE
REHABILITATIVE ACHIEVEMENT TYPE
GROUPS AND SELF HELP IN OTHER
WORDS JUST IN MORE SIMPLE TERMS
AND THROUGH MORE A IN A MORE
RIGOROUS WAY BUT BASED ON THOSE
CREDIT EARNINGS WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN.
IS THAT INMATES [inaudible]
HAVE BEEN.
THEY HAVE EARNED AND I LIKE TO
SAY THAT EARNED BECAUSE
NOTHING'S GIVEN TO THEM THEY'VE
EARNED FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION
CREDITS AND WHAT THAT TRANSLATES.
TO IS THIRTEEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX PRISON YEARS
HAVE COME OFFICE SENTENCES BASED
ON THAT.
THE INMATES EARNING THAT.
IMAGE PARTICIPATED IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND COLLEGE PROGRAMS THE
DIPLOMAS AND RIGHT NOW --
THEY HAVE EARNED NEARLY NINE
THOUSAND FIVE WORDS AND THAT
TRANSLATES INTO TWO THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED ELEVEN YEARS OFF OF
PRISON SENTENCES.
ALSO THEIR PARTICIPATION AND
RIGOROUS CURRICULUM BASED
PROGRAMS --
A CARD IN BEHAVIOR --
MILESTONE EARNINGS THEY HAVE
ALSO EARNED TWO HUNDRED NINETEEN
THOUSAND AND THAT THAT
TRANSLATES ROUGHLY INTO NINE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE PRISON YEARS OFFICE
SENTENCES.
AND THESE ARE CREDITS THAT
INMATES EARNED AND I THINK FOR
ME THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHANGES IN THE CULTURE CHANGES
INSIDE PRISONS AND HELPED
INMATES PROGRAM.
AND PROGRAMS ARE FACILITATED
INMATES IS THAT THEY EARN THEM --
WE NOW HAVE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED REHABILITATIVE
ACHIEVEMENT CREDIT PROGRAMS AND
WHAT THAT TRANSLATES INTO IS
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
OPPORTUNITIES SO YOU HAVE THE
PROGRAMS AND THEN.
EACH PROGRAM MAY HAVE VARIOUS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMAGE TO
PARTICIPATE AND WE HAVE ABOUT
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND SLOT SO
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND OPPORTUNITY
FOR INMATES TO PARTICIPATE IN A
PROGRAM.
OUR GOAL IS TO OFFER A TOTAL OF
OVER THREE THOUSAND RIGHT
PROGRAMS BY THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR.
ALSO LOOKING FOR TO CREATE
PROGRAMS FOR INMATES WITH MENTAL
AND MEDICAL HEALTH NEEDS TO
INCENTIVIZE PARTICIPATION IN
TREATMENT.
WE'RE LOOKING TO LOOKING AT
IMPLEMENTING A NURSING STAFF
SPONSORED PATIENT.
EDUCATION IN MADE ACTIVITY GROUP.
AND THIS'LL HELP INMATES ASSIST
IN ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS THAT
I'LL BE JUST A SUPPORT GROUP FOR
THE IN MY POPULATION.
WE WANT TO DO THAT AT SEVERAL
INSTITUTIONS.
ALL THESE NUMBERS SAYING SEMEN
PRESS OF THE FULL IMPACT OF PROP
FIFTY SEVEN I BELIEVE WE HAVEN'T
SEEN YET.
BECAUSE I LIKE EARLY PROJECTIONS
PROP -- THAT
WE HAD IN THE PROP.
THIRTY SIX THOSE TWO IDENTIFY TO
ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC NEEDS FOR A
PRETTY DESIGNATED GROUP OF
INMATES.
PROP.
FIFTY SEVEN IMPACTS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE INMATE
POPULATION --
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IMPACT THEIR DATES IN
REHABILITATION BASED ON PROGRAM
AVAILABILITY.
BASED ON SENTENCING COMPLEXITY
AND I BELIEVE MORE IMPORTANT ONE
THE INDIVIDUAL CHOICE THAT IT
AND MAKE CHOOSES TO MAKE TO
PURSUE THESE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS.
I WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT
OFFENDERS RELEASED SINCE
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN ON
AVERAGE HAVE REDUCED OUR
SENTENCES BY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS.
WHAT THAT DOES FOR US INSIDE THE
PRISON POPULATION ITSELF IT
ENCOURAGES HOPE IT ENCOURAGES
INMATES TO SEE THAT THE THESE
THE THEIR EFFORTS WORK?
BUT ALSO THE STAFF SEE THAT IT
WORKS IN STAFF RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY HELP FACILITATE THESE
PROGRAMS WHICH ALSO.
IMPACTS THE THE NEED A CULTURE
CHANGE.
UPDATE ON FIFTY SEVEN WE
SUBMITTED --
REGULATIONS EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS LAST DECEMBER --
TO AMEND THE REGULATIONS WHICH
ARE CURRENTLY IN EFFECT AND THAT
WILL BE GOING OUT FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN THE NEAR FUTURE
THE THESE --
AUGMENTED RAGS.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE AUG EARLY
FOR THE EDUCATION AND THE
REHABILITATIVE ACHIEVEMENT
CREDIT PIECE TO INCREASE THEM.
ALSO IT WILL EXPAND THE
NONVIOLENT PROCONSULS FOR THIRD
STRIKERS DUE TO RECENT
LITIGATION.
ALSO ONE MAY I ASK WHAT WHITE
WHY YOU HAVEN'T AUGMENT THE
CREDIT PIECE BECAUSE WHAT WE
FOUND IS SINCE WE FIRST
IMPLEMENTED AS ANYTHING NEW THAT
YOU.
IMPLEMENT WHAT WERE FOUND IS
THAT -- THE
INMATES WHOSE DATES CHANGE
BECAUSE THEY ARE DETERMINED HE
SENTENCED ABOUT 46% WERE ONLY
ABLE TO EARN THOSE CREDITS
BECAUSE THE REMAINING INMATES IN
THOSE PROGRAMS WERE LIFERS.
AND THOSE DATES REALLY DIDN'T
IMPACT LIFE FOR DATES SO WILL
YOU COULD CALCULATE RELEASE
STATES.
A DECISION WAS MADE EARLY ON AND
I BELIEVE IT'S THE RIGHT
DECISION AND I THINK IT'S A GOOD
DECISION NOW NOT TO REMOVE THESE
LIFERS BECAUSE LIFERS NEED THEM.
LIFERS ARE STABLE POPULATION IN
PRISON --
THEY ALSO --
INCENTIVIZE HOPE TO THE OTHER
INMATES ENCOURAGING TO
PARTICIPATE SO BECAUSE OF THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO INCREASE THE
CREDITS ELIGIBLE --
FOR PARTICIPATION IN THESE
REHABILITATE ACHIEVEMENT CREDITS
AND MILESTONE PROGRAMS.
I DO TAKE CARD IN THE MIDDLE OF
ALL THESE VAST CHANGES AND
CORRECTIONS THAT RECIDIVISM HAS
STAYED STABLE.
EVEN AS THE PRISON POPULATION IS
LARGER AND THE PERCENTAGE OF
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT OFFENDERS IN
PRISON.
AS INCREASED.
OFFENDERS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO EARN
THEIR FREE SIX MONTHS OR EVEN
YEARS --
THAN THE EARLIER WHAT HAPPENED
FOR ME AGAIN I KEEP ON USING
THIS TERM.
THERE IS HOPE THAT THE INMATES
SEE THAT THEIR PARTICIPATION IN
THESE PROGRAMS DO WORK.
HOWEVER WE ARE CONSTANTLY
WORKING TO IMPROVE THIS RATE AND
ALLOW MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OFFENDERS.
OR OFFICER RESEARCH IS CONDUCTED
AN ASSESSMENT ON THE IMPACT OF
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS AND WHAT THEY
DISCOVERED THAT.
THE RECIDIVISM RATE FOR
FRAWLEY'S WITH THE TREATMENT
NEED WHO ARE RECEIVED IMPRISONED
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROGRAM WAS
THIRTY EIGHT POINT 5%.
COMPARED TO THE FORTY ONE POINT
FOUR WHO DID NOT RECEIVE THIS
TREATMENT --
THE ONE YOUR CONVICTION RATE FOR
OFFENDERS WHO EARNED EDUCATION
MERIT CREDITS THESE OF THE
EDUCATION AND COLLEGE --
THERE A THE ONE YOUR CONVICTION
REFER THEM WAS 9%.
IN TWO THOUSAND ON 9% IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ALTHOUGH
THESE AREN'T IT'S NOT APPLE TO
APPLE COMPARISON WE HAVE SEEN
THE DIFFERENCE IN THE CHANGES
BASED ON THESE --
RECIDIVISM NUMBERS BASED ON
PARTICIPATION IN THESE CREDITS --
WE ALSO TOOK A LOOK AT NINE
HUNDRED AND REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE
HAD A ONE YOUR CONVICTION RATE
OF NINE POINT FIVE THE THESE ARE
ENCOURAGING NUMBERS.
WE SEE IN MOST PARTICIPATING WE
SEE THEM CHANGING AND FOR US
THAT'S A GOOD THING. FOR THE
MORE CITIES YOUR POPULATION
PROJECTIONS PREDICT THAT THE
ADULT POPULATION.
IS. TO CONTINUE TO DECREASE BUT
NOT AT THE RATE WE INITIALLY
EXPECTED --
THE FALL OF TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN PROJECTIONS ARE BASED
ON A 1% HIGHER THAN ANTICIPATED
IN SPRING TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
REPORT REPORT MAINLY BECAUSE OF
THE FIFTY OF THE PROFIT THE
SEVEN OF ENHANCEMENT EARNING
CREDITS I DESCRIBED EARLIER WITH
THE RACKS IN THE MILESTONES.
THAT SKEWED THAT'S WOULD BUMP
THE NUMBER UP BY 1% AND 1% WITH
THESE NUMBERS IS AN INCREASE OF
BILLS YOU SOME PROJECTIONS.
DON'T HAVE ACHIEVEMENT CREDITS.
IN POINT IN TIME DATA LIFERS
EARNED ONE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE RACK CREDITS.
AND THE NON LIFERS AREN'T
SIXTEEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE THAT 44% THOSE OF
THE NUMBERS EXPLAINED EARLY ON
WHY IT WAS OFF.
THAT'S WHY WE AMENDED THESE --
REGULATIONS --
BUT I'D BE REMISS IF I DID TAKE
A MOMENT TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT WE ARE STILL SUBJECT TO THE
THREE JUDGE PANEL ONE THIRTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE NUMBER --
THATPOPCAP WE'VE BEEN UNDER
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN BUT
WE MUST --
STILL MONITOR THE POPULATION
TODAY WE ARE AT THREE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY TO BE
LOW THE POP CAP NUMBER BUT I
ALSO NEED TO REMIND THAT WE ARE
STILL WITH ABOUT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED INMATES STILL IN ARIZONA --
WE THE GOAL TO HAVE THOSE
INMATES BACK BY JUNE THIRTIETH
OF THIS YEAR.
WE ARE BRINGING BACK BETWEEN --
I THINK THE LAST TIME I SAW
BETWEEN SEVENTY NINE AND A
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN INMATES A
WEEK.
AND WE ARE ON TRACK TO HAVE THEM
BACK AND THAT'S THE GOAL.
THE REASON WE DO NOT KEEP THE
ORIGINAL TIME FRIENDS BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THE BOB POP PROJECTIONS
THAT I EXPLAINED EARLIER.
AND THAT THE THOUGHT THAT WE
WERE CONTINUE TO BRING THE BACK
SOONER WE WOULD HAVE SEVERELY
IMPACTED THE THREE JUDGE PANEL
NUMBER WE WOULD HAVE BEEN.
VERY CLOSE TO BEING OVER AND
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE WANTED TO BE.
A SEEMS LIKE A LOT --
THAT THE CUSHION THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW --
BUT I DO NEED TO REMIND THAT --
NO THE QUESTION IS IN IS IS
ROBUST AS I WE THAT WE WOULD
LIKE BECAUSE WHAT WE RECOGNIZE
AS ONE LEAKY ROOF ONE BAD COURT
RULING.
CHANGES IN SENTENCING ANYTHING
COULD CHANGE HOW INMATES ARE
RECEIVED IN THE INTO THE SYSTEM
AND WE NEED TO BE COUNSELED
MINDFUL OF THAT --
I RAISE THAT POINT BECAUSE
EXCEEDS THE POPPED UP WE WILL BE
UNDER THE COURT --
THE COURT MONITOR --
BUT I DENIED.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT BUT WE DO
HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS SO THE GOOD
NEWS IS A DECADE AGO ONLY A
QUARTER OF OUR INMATE.
WAS HOUSE ON LEVEL TWO
FACILITIES WHICH ARE LOWER LEVEL
THERE'S MORE PROGRAMMING FOR
THOSE INMATES THERE'S A MORE
ACCESS MORE OPENNESS.
BUT AS OF TODAY WE HAVE A OVER A
THIRD 36% OF OUR POPULATION.
IS IN THESE LOWER LEVEL
FACILITIES THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE IS A
DIFFERENT POPULATION THAN WE HAD.
WE HAVE A MORE SERIOUS MORE
VIOLENT POPULATION THAT COME IN
BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL SHOULDN'T JUST BE
HOUSE BASED ON THE CRIME THEY
COMMITTED.
IT'S A HOLISTIC APPROACH IN OUR
HOUSING INMATES TO GET THEM AT
THE LOWEST LEVEL.
POSSIBLE SO WE CAN REACH THE
REHABILITATIVE NEED.
TOM I KNOW I'VE BEEN IN FRONT OF
THE COMMITTEES LIKE THIS TO TALK
ABOUT A SHOE POPULATIONS THERE
WAS A TIME WHEN WE'RE POPULATION.
WAS ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND NOW THAT
NUMBERS UNDER.
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SO THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN OUR SYSTEM.
THERE ARE ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION UNITS --
THAT WE'RE AT ONE POINT AT ABOUT.
EIGHT ONE THOUSAND UNKNOWN
NUMBERS ARE TRENDING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND I THINK IT'S
JUST THE WAY WE HAVE BEEN
HOUSING AND UNDERSTANDING HOW
INMATES NEEDS NEED TO BE MET.
AND THAT WE NEED AND THE CLEARLY
BEHAVIOR BASIN TAKEN INDIVIDUAL
ON WHAT THEY'RE DOING NOT OUT
WHAT THEY THINK THEY MAY OR MAY
NOT DO [inaudible]
ARM.
A COUPLE OF OTHER HOUSING HAVE A
POINT I WANT TO MAKE THE
POPULATION IS THAT --
MOSER'S INVITES OFFENDER BUT I
DO NEED TO SAY IT ON THE WOMEN'S
PROGRAMS WE HAVE ALTERNATIVE
CUSTODY PLACEMENTS.
WE HAVE SIXTEEN WOMEN HOUSE AND
PRIVATE RESIDENCE IN.
SIXTEEN AND IT'S SIXTEEN HOUSES
AND WE HAVE ANOTHER SIXTEEN
HOUSE IN THE FEMALE OFFENDER
TREATMENT AND EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAMS --
SO IF YOU YOU SAID SIXTEEN WOMEN
IN SIXTEEN HOUSES WELL THE WAY
IT IS.
WITH THE ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY
PLACEMENTS.
THEIR PLACE IN HOUSING THAT --
THAT IS APPROVED BY PAROLE SO
TRADITIONALLY THEY'RE LIVING
WITH LOVED ONES FRIENDS SO
SIXTEEN OF THEM ARE LIVING IN
THOSE HOUSES SO WE HAVE ONLY A
POPULATION OF SIXTEEN OPERATIONS.
IN ALL ALL LOOKS NO OUR WOMEN'S
FACILITY IS OR ANYONE THAT'S
ALMOST OVERCROWDING I I I I
UNDERSTAND I DO WANT TO JUST AND
ALSO -- WE
ALSO HAVE FIVE CUSTODY COMMUNITY
TRANSITIONAL REENTRY PROGRAMS
FOR FEMALES AT FIVE LOCATIONS
WHICH SERVE UP TO THREE HUNDRED
NINETY NINE FEMALE.
PARTICIPANTS ALL OF THE C. C. T.
R. PEAS ARE OPERATED BY A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
UNDER CONTRACT WITH C. C. R..
OF THE FEMALE OFFENDER PROGRAM
SERVICES IS CURRENTLY DISCUSSING
POSSIBLE EXPANSION WITH PROGRAMS
IN LOS ANGELES AND BEAUMONT --
I DO WANT TO SAY THAT --
THAT THAT NUMBER IS GOING NUMBER
OF FEMALES IN ALTERNATIVE
CUSTODY PLACEMENTS.
OF THE REASON THAT IT'S REALLY
SO LOW IS BECAUSE THE READ THE
REALITY IS IS THAT HOUSING PLANS
FOR FEMALE OFFENDERS ARE QUITE
DIFFERENT THAN THEY ARE FOR THE
MALE OFFENDERS WHAT.
SADLY WHAT WE FIND IS THAT --
MEN RETURNED TO SOMEONE STABLE
ENVIRONMENTS IN THE FEMALE
POPULATION OF STRUGGLING TO FIND
THAT STABLE ENVIRONMENT AND WE
ARE WORKING WITH PAROLE TO MAKE
SURE.
WE ARE --
APPROVING THE CORRECT WOMEN TO
BE IN THESE ALTERNATE CUSTODY
PLACE BEEN HOME SO THAT NUMBER
IS ASSIGNED TO ME ALSO BUT IT
ALSO CONSISTENT WITH NATIONAL
DATA AS A PRT OF THE GENDER
RESPONSE OF PRINCIPLES.
THAT ARE PUT UP BY THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF CORRECTIONS SO
WE'RE WE'RE CHECKING NATIONALLY
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING THE
RIGHT THING.
ON WE HAVE --
ALSO FIVE OVER FIVE THOUSAND
INMATES IN FACE TO FACE COLLEGES
AND ARE IN A THIRTY FIVE
INSTITUTIONS.
AND AT A MUCH MORE BASIC LEVEL
WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS THAT WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS THE LITERACY OF
OUR INMATES TO COME IN.
WHAT WE FIND IS ALMOST HALF 47%
OF OUR POPULATION RES BELOW NINE
POINT NO?
AND ALSO WHAT WE FIND IS ABOUT
38% OF OUR POPULATION.
ONLY 30% OF OUR POPULATION HAVE
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR
EQUIVALENT SEE WHEN THEY COME IN.
THAT'S CONCERNING.
WE NEED IN MAY BE ABLE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES THEY
NEED TO IMPROVE THEIR LITERACY --
WHICH MAKES IN ROMAN IN BASIC
EDUCATION ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND OFFENDERS.
IN EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND ADULT
BASIC EDUCATION HIGH SCHOOL
EQUIVALENCY --
THE GOAL IS THAT TO TO REACH THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF EQUIVALENCY FOR
AND LITERACY FOR INMATE
POPULATION.
THE DEPARTMENTS I SUBMITTED A B.
C. P. TO THIS COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERATION TO FUND.
PROGRAMS SPECIFICALLY AIMED AT
IMPROVING LITERACY AND WE'RE
GONNA HIT ON A COUPLE OF POINTS
INCLUDING DIAGNOSTIC REMEDIAL
READING PROGRAMS.
COMPUTER BASED LEARNING.
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
TEACHER MENTOR AND I THINK ONE
OF THE MOST ENCOURAGING I'M I'M
LOOKING FOR THIS.
INMATE LITERACY COACHES
SPECIFICALLY AIMED AT IMPROVING
LITERACY.
I KNOW THAT I'VE TAKEN A LOT OF
THE TIME ALLOTTED --
BUT I DO WANT TO MENTION
SOMETHING CITY STARS IN THE
PROCESS OF OVERHAULING.
IN MANY WAYS.
REINVENTING THE MANAGEMENT AND
HOW WE HOUSE THE TRANSGENDER
POPULATION OTHERS WORK GROUPS
MEETING TODAY ON HOW WE HOUSE
THEM SO WE CAN MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS --
AND I BELIEVE WE'RE HEAD OF THE
NATION IN MANY RESPECTS IN THIS
ASPECT. NINETY NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE IS INSTITUTION SEVEN
pUNDER THE JURISDICTION FROM THE
FEDERAL RECEIVER.
I WHICH PUT US OVER 50% AND I
KNOW --
MISTER KELSO SAID BEHIND ME HE'S
GOING TO GIVE A FOR TO
CONTINUALLY WORK YOU MISTER
KELSO IN THIS EFFORT AND WE DO
WORK VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER TO
IMPROVE I APPRECIATE THE
RELATIONSHIP.
I'M ALSO WORKING ON AN ISSUE
THAT'S THE ACCESS THE FAMILIES
HAVE TO THEIR LOVED ONES IN
STATE PRISON I'VE ASSN DIVISION
ADULT INSTITUTIONS TO CONVENE
STATEWIDE TRAINING ON HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE.
OUR VISIT IN EXPERIENCE FOR THE
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
VISITS WE GET OUR PRISONS EVERY
YEAR.
I'VE ALSO TEST THE A. I. FOR
IMPROVING OUR CUSTOMER SERVICE
AT THE INSTITUTIONS SO WHEN
LOVED ONES OR ANYONE CALL THEY
CAN GET BETTER RESPONSES --
AND I'LL SAY THAT NO THOSE SOME
OF THOSE THINGS ARE SO BASIC BUT
THEY ARE SO CRITICAL THE
POPULATION AND OF THE SYSTEM THE
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
READ IN AND GO OVER.
WHAT WE WHAT WE HAVE AND I
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE?
WELL I IMAGINE SO MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS BUT BEFORE I
CALL ON THEM --
SO WE HAVE OBVIOUSLY A NUMBER OF
THINGS ON THIS AND A INCLUDING
HEARING FROM.
AND SO IT. FOR EXAMPLE ALL THE
QUESTIONS I MIGHT WANT TO ASK WE
COULD BE HERE A LONG LONG TIME
SO I'M GONNA TRY TO RUN THIS AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE SO THAT
THAT IS NOT NECESSARILY THE CASE
BUT THAT WE ARE STILL.
PRECEDING IN A WAY THAT ALLOWS
US.
TO AT GET INTO THE INFORMATION
THAT WE NEED TO TO BE ABLE TO
THAT THESE BUDGET REQUEST.
SO IN THAT SPIRIT I WANT TO SEE
IF.
LA -- HAS
ANYTHING SPECIFIC THAT THEY WANT.
TO RAISE REGARDING ON ACTING
SECRETARY DS'S --
THAT'S MONIQUE OTHERWISE
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE.
LA OWES --
MULTIPLE GOOD REPORTS ON THAT --
KIND OF OVER.
ARCHING AROUND THIS SUCH AS THE
PROP FIFTY SEVEN RAG SO RATHER
THAN REPEATING THEM HERE IF
THERE'S ANYTHING SPECIFIC THAT'S
NOT IN ONE OF THE REPORTS THAT
WE HAVE ACCESS.
TO PLEASE BRING IT TO OUR
ATTENTION.
HE WON O'NEILL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
OUR COMMENTS ARE ALREADY
REFLECTED IN THE REPORT THAT YOU
HAVE SO I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
ELSE RELATED TO THE POPULATION.
OF BUDGET REQUEST OTHER THAN
THAT WHAT IS IN THE REPORT.
APPRECIATE IT AND OBVIOUSLY.
ON GIVEN THAT WAS.
POINTED OUT BY THE SECRETARY DE
IS THAT WE STILL HAVE NOT WE
STILL HAVE INMATES IN ARIZONA.
AND WE WERE EXPECTING THAT WE
WOULD NOT HAVE IN MASON ARIZONA
BY THIS FISCAL YEAR.
ON AND THAT WE ARE STILL
HOVERING RIGHT AROUND OUR AND
COURT MANDATED POPULATION NUMBER.
THE AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THIS
SEPT COMMITTEE PROCESS IF LA --
HAS SPECIFIC ACTIONS THE FUEL.
THAT -- WE
SHOULD BE TAKING. TO TO ADDRESS
THAT POPULATION REDUCTION.
ON WE WOULD APPRECIATE IT I KNOW
THERE IS MUCH IN THE REPORT TO
PRESENTED TO US ALREADY FOR
EXAMPLE AROUND FIFTY SEVEN BUT
IF THERE ARE.
AS WE PROCEED YOU KNOW ANYTHING
YOU EALLY REALLY WANT TO HAVE
US -- YOU
FEELS WORTHWHILE FOR US TO HONE
IN ON THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
ON ALL RIGHT SO.
I I WOULD ASK A FEW QUESTIONS
AND THEN I HAVE TO CALL ON MY
COLLEAGUES.
ON ONE ONE QUESTION I HAVE IS
AROUND ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY.
AND THAT IS ONE MECHANISM FOR US
TO BRING POPULATION DOWN.
AND GIVEN THAT OUR WOMEN'S
FACILITY IS ONE OF THE MOST
SERIOUSLY OVERCROWDED IT'S AT A
HUNDRED AND 40% IT'S POPULATION
TO HEAR THAT WE ARE ONLY IN
SIXTEEN WOMEN AN ALTERNATIVE
CASSIE.
I'M NOT PLEASED.
AND TO HAVE THE CORRELATION BE
WILL THAT.
THIS POPULATIONS HARDER TO
HOUSING THAT'S THAT'S A
REINFORCED BY NATIONAL STUDY.
I HAD DOESN'T HELP ME.
SO -- WE
HAVE PUT.
WE HAVE.
DIRECTED THIS AS A PRIORITY IN
AN EMPHASIS [inaudible]
TO PURSUE --
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY [inaudible]
AND THE ANY OTHER COMMENTS YOU
WANNA MAKE ABOUT THAT I'M I'M
JUST AS CONCERNED AS YOU SENATOR
I AM -- TO
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS COMPARED TO
WHAT WE HAVE IN THE MEN'S MAIL
COMMUNITY REENTRY PROGRAMS.
SIXTEEN IS IS NOT A GOOD NUMBER --
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I I
WANT TO DO IS WORK WITH YOU I
LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH YOU BUT ALSO
HAVING A OUR PROCESS IF IT'S TOO
STRINGENT IF THE THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
pAND FEMALES.
AND WE NEED TO WORK WITH WORK
WITH OUR PAROLE AND OUR AND OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS EVEN IF.
WE CAN DO THAT BUT I KNOW WE CAN
BUT IT'S JUST IS CONCERNED I
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
IT MY TEAM.
AS I WAS DEVELOPING MY TALKING
POINTS THIS WAS ONE AREA THAT
THEY ARE BACK DOING WORK ON
BECAUSE THAT WAS TRULY A NUMBER
THAT I'M NOT.
I'M IN AND I RAISE THE ISSUE OF
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE NOT YET
BEEN ABLE TO MOVE ARE FOLKS WHO
ARE OUT OF STATE.
THAT GIVEN THAT WE HAVE
[inaudible]
EMPHASIZED REHABILITATION EVEN
BEFORE THE PASSAGE OF PROP.
FIFTY SEVEN AND WHILE WE EXPECT
IN OUR CONTRACTS THAT WE HAVE
THAT TYPE OF REQUIREMENT --
EXPECTATION IN ARIZONA WE HAVE
NO ABILITY TO REALLY MONNING WE
HAVE NO REAL ABILITY TO KNOW
THAT THEY ARE MEETING.
THE ARE.
THE OBJECTIVES WE HAVE WHICH IS
I THINK ANOTHER REASON WHY.
ON THERE IS GREAT DESIRE IN
ADDITION MEETING OUR COURT
MANDATED POPULATION CAP TO GET
THOSE FOLKS OUT FROM OUT OF
STATE.
WHERE WE HAVE MORE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE PROPER OVERSIGHT?
I'M SO IN THAT SPIRIT I WANT TO
ALSO ASK THE QUESTION OF OUR
WITHIN.
WITHIN OUR OWN REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AND WORK --
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN TWO WEEKS
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
AN AGENDA VARIES VERY --
FOCUSED ON THAT GIVEN ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE AUDITOR'S REPORT AND
OTHER THINGS --
TO TO REALLY LOOK AT WHETHER ARE
YES WHETHER OUR PROGRAMS ARE.
ARE ADEQUATE WHETHER THEY ARE --
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL THE INMATES
THAT NEED THEM SO I WANT TO GO
INTO GREAT DETAIL ABOUT THAT
TODAY BUT I DO WANT TO ASK.
THAT WHEN YOU DESCRIBE THAT WE
HAVE -- OUR
POPULATION IS GOING TO BE 1%
HIGHER THAN WE WERE HOPING.
THEN I THINK TO MYSELF WELL IF
IT'S HIGHER THAN WE WERE
PROJECTING.
AND WE STILL HAVE YARDS THAT DO
NOT HAVE.
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD ALLOW
INMATES TO BE ABLE.
TO GET REHABILITATIVE CREDITS
AND WHILE I COMPLETELY
APPRECIATE.
THAT WE SHOULD NOT EXCLUDE
LIFERS FROM PROGRAMS WE SHOULD
NOT.
BUT KNOWING THAT WE HAVE THIS
EMPHASIS IN KNOWING THAT WE HAVE
GIVEN INMATES THE PROMISE OF
BEING ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THESE PROGRAMS.
AND AND YET YOU INDICATE THAT
OUR POPULATIONS HIGHER.
AND I THINK PART OF IT IS DUE TO
THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THESE PROGRAMS SUCCESSFUL TO
INMATES IN WITH THEY'RE NOT
AVAILABLE IN ALL YARDS.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING ABOUT IT?
WHILE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
DIVISION OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AND I AT I THINK ON THE
CHEN.
NO NOT TODAY INTO WHAT WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THEM AND ONE OF THE
WHAT WE ARE WORKING ON IS
ENSURING THAT --
V. SPACE THAT WE HAVE IN THE
INSTITUTION IS BEING MAXIMIZE
THAT WE ARE LOOKING BEYOND OUR
TRADITIONAL CUSTODIAL MINDSETS
ON WHAT WE CAN PUT INMATES IN
PROGRAMS --
BECAUSE A BOILS DOWN MEANT
MAJORITY THE TIME SENATOR IS.
TIME AND SPACE THIS LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME IN A DAY TO WHERE
WE CAN HAVE INMATES AND PROGRAM
AND I AM PUSHING.
A CUSTODIAL REQUIREMENTS SO WE
CAN SOME SECURITY CONCERNS
CANNOT PROGRAM IN THE EVENINGS
ARE AT NIGHT --
LOOKING OVER SO --
ESCAPE CONCERNED SOMETIMES THAT
WE THINK AND WHAT AT AND REALLY
PUSHING THEM TO THINK OUTSIDE
THE TRADITIONAL CUSTODIAL
MINDSET.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE REGULATIONS
THAT WE HAVE FOR SECURITY
PURPOSES WERE WRITTEN WHAT WE
FIND A WRITTEN IN THE EIGHTIES
DURING A MORE CONSERVATIVE TIME.
AND IT'S A DIFFERENT DAY IN
CORRECTIONS NOW WE'RE PUSHING
THEM TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE THAT
THE WARDENS MUST BE VERY
CREATIVE ON WHERE WE ARE PUTTING
CLASSES IN.
WHAT WE ARE ALLOWING THESE IN
MAY -- OR
THE REHABILITATIVE ACHIEVEMENT
CREDITS --
TO TO OCCUR.
BUT ALSO --
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITIES TO
BRING THE VOLUNTEERS IN.
AND TO AND TO ALSO SOLICIT --
ON THE INTEGRATED INNOVATIVE
GRANT SIDE INFORMATION THAT --
WHAT PROGRAMS WORK BEST AND TO
GET THEM IN THESE INSTITUTIONS
BUT A LOT OF IT BOILS DOWN TO
SOMETIMES IS TIME AND SPACE --
BUT WE ARE REALLY EMPHASIZING
WITH THE WAR THERE'S A SOCIAL
DIRECTORS TEAMS AND THE DIRECTOR.
TO REPORT.
ON A MONTHLY BASIS THAT THEY'RE
MAXIMIZING THE OPPORTUNITIES.
BUT WHAT DUMB.
THEY KNOW IN THE END WHAT WE
FIND IS OUR RURAL INSTITUTIONS.
THE VOLUNTEER BASE --
EVEN SOMETIMES THE THE
EMPLOYMENT BASE PEOPLE NOW WANT
TO MOVE TO THESE AREAS TO GET
HIRED FOR THESE JOBS BUT WE'VE
ALSO DONE.
IS RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE A
SEGMENT OF THE POPULATION THAT
DO WANT TO COME BACK AND THAT'S
THE FORMALLY INCARCERATED THEY
WANT TO COME BACK AND CONTRIBUTE --
WITHIN THE PRISONS WE RCOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE THE MOST CREDIBLE
MESSENGERS AND IF THEY ARE EAGER
THEY WANT TO COME IN AND HELP.
IN THIS EFFORT TO REHABILITATE
AND PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
POPULATION.
THE THE MOST TROUBLE MESSENGER
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE --
AND BALANCE WE'RE DOING THIS TO
MAKE SURE INMATES OR CV AND
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES AND NOT
SO MUCH JUST FOR THE FOCUS OF WE
NEED TO GET HIM OUT OF PRISON
FASTER.
I NEED TO MEET BOTH OF THEM MEET
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMPONENT AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE.
ONES THAT ACTUALLY PREPARE THEM
FOR THE PROPER REINVENT SO THAT
IT'S A KEEPING ALSO THE
RECIDIVISM RATE FOR A LOWERING.
CHRIS CHRISTIE WELL I THINK ALL
ALL SOMEONE UP THERE THAT IT'S
IT'S REALLY WITH OVERSIGHT THAT.
AND GIVING --
GIVING INSTITUTIONS PERMISSION
SIDE OF WHAT THE TRADITIONAL
MINDSETS ARE BUT THAT IS ALSO
GOING TO BE THE CONSISTENT
OVERSIGHT WITH THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
AND THE DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS THROUGH BOTH
DIRECTORS BECAUSE WHAT I'VE
GIVEN THEM THE DIRECTIVE OF THIS
YOU NEED TO BE CREATIVE.
DON'T BRING ME --
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TRADITIONALLY
NOT USE THIS SPACE BECAUSE IS
DEDICATED FOR X. WELL THAT'S
IT'S DEDICATED FOR EVERYBODY.
AND IT'S FOR EVERYBODY'S USE OF
ITS OPEN YOU USE IT AND IF
YOU'RE HAVING TROUBLE GETTING
VOLUNTEERS PLEASE LET US KNOW WE
HAVE OTHER WAYS OF REACHING
COMMUNITIES.
NOW SOLICIT ANY ASSISTANCE FROM
THIS FOR FROM --
FROM THE COMMITTEE HERE AND HOW
WE CAN REACH THAT VOLUNTEER BASE
AND MAYBE.
THE SPELL THE CONCERN OF WHAT
VOLUNTEERING IN PRISON IS.
IF YOU GO TO SAINT QUITTING
RIGHT UP YOU KNOW JUST UP THE
ROAD HERE IT IS VERY OPEN WE
HAVE THOUSANDS OF VOLUNTEERS
THAT COME IN THE ANNUAL BASIS.
WHEN YOU GO TO OTHERS YOU MAY
HAVE HUNDREDS?
AND MAYBE JUST BECAUSE OF THE
THE LOCATION OF WHERE IT IS IN
THE STATE THE FOUGHT MAYBE WE
NEED TO REACH OUT MORE TO CIVIC
GROUPS CHURCHES.
COLLEGES AND NOT JUST RELYING
THE TRADITIONAL LET'S JUST
REACHED A CONTACT NARCOTICS
ANONYMOUS ALCOHOLICS ANONYMOUS
AND HAVE THEM COME IN.
BECAUSE IT WONDERFUL PROGRAMS
LIKE GOING OUT BY GOING IN --
SHAKESPEARE THE ACTORS GANG FULL
IN BRINGING THOSE GROUPS OF SOME
OF THESE RURAL PLACES --
BUT IT'S REALLY JUST A
COLLECTIVE EFFORT.
SAID TO GET PEOPLE IN TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES.
AND THEN I HAVE A QUESTION ON
THE ISSUE.
WHICH IS ARE SOLITARY HOUSING.
UNITS.
AND WE IN ADDITION --
TO BUDGETARY LEGISLATIVE.
I THINK WAS IN BUDGET ARM ACTION
THAT BASICALLY DIRECTED
REDUCTIONS IN OUR USE OF THE
ISSUE.
I'M WE'VE ALSO HAVE COURT ORDER.
RELATED TO SHOOT.
AND WE JUST RECENTLY SEEN THAT
THE JUDGE INTERVENED AGAIN
INDICATING THAT WE HAVE NOT YET.
THAT WE ARE STILL --
INAPPROPRIATELY.
BY UTILIZING ISSUE IN THIS YOU
FOR LONGER PERIODS OF TIME
POTENTIALLY THAN IS NECESSARY SO
WE'VE WE'VE HAD.
THE ANOTHER INTERVENTION AND I
GUESS WHAT I'D LIKE TO KNOW IS
THAT YES IT'S SEVEN HUNDRED OR
EIGHT HUNDRED IS BETTER IN.
FOUR THOUSAND BUT WHY ARE WE NOT --
DOWN TO NEAR.
ZERO WELL I I I WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SAME THING AND I THINK I'M
FAMILIAR WITH WITH THE THE THE
THE LEGAL DECISION THAT YOU THAT
YOU READ AND THAT'S THE ASKER
CASE [inaudible]
AND I AM.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I'M
UNDERSTANDING THE THE LAST THE
LEGAL BRIEF IN THAT I RECEIVED
AND I AM FAMILIAR WITH THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE OUT THERE IT
IS REALLY BEEN TE DISCUSSION
HAS BEEN.
NOT SO MUCH THE UTILIZATION OF
SHOE PUTTING INMATES IN SHOE.
BUT THE IMAGE THAT ARE RELEASED.
ON TO OUR LEVEL FOR FACILITIES
AND THAT --
THOUGHT IS WE'RE PUTTING THEM ON
THOSE FACILITIES --
AND AT A HIGHER RATE AND WE'RE
NOT AFFORDING THEM --
THE A METHOD SAME AMOUNT OF
PROGRAM IS THE REST OF THE
INSTITUTIONS.
AND THAT --
WE ARE THE INMATES THAT WERE
INVOLVED IN THE LAWSUIT --
THAT GOT US TO WHERE WE ARE --
WE DON'T ALWAYS AGREE WITH THEM --
BUT I DO BELIEVE WE'RE STILL
TRAINING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
IN THE UTILIZATION OF SHOE WE DO
HAVE CHALLENGES.
AND WHAT WE DO WITH THE
POPULATION THAT WERE RELEASED.
THAT THEY WARRANT YOU ONE YEAR
ANOTHER HERE THE BELIEF IS THAT
WE WE NEED TO BE PUSHING HIM TO
THE LOWEST LEVELS OF POSSIBLE
GET ENOUGH MORE REHABILITATION.
AND I AGREE BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
BALANCE THE SECURITY NEEDS OF
PUTTING AN INDIVIDUAL AT LOWER
LEVELS FOR WITH A GROUP OF
INMATES THAT.
HAVE ALREADY MADE GOOD DECISIONS
TO WANT TO FOREGO THAT LIFESTYLE.
AND NOT --
JUST WANTONLY PUTTING SOME OF
THESE RECENT SURE RELEASES ON
THOSE YARDS THE FEAR IS.
THAT IT COULD UPSET THE
CHEMISTRY ON THOSE YOU BEGIN IN
A MORE CUSTODIAL YOU KNOW
BOOGEYMAN TYPE SITUATION WE ARE.
APPROACHING.
A US A PLACE IN CORRECTIONS WERE
ARE CLASSIFICATION STAFFER
PRISONS UNDERSTAND.
THAT BEHAVIOR OVERRIDES A TO
LOWER LEVEL FACILITIES
REGARDLESS OF THE POINTS THAT
THEY THAT THEY HAVE.
THESE WE NEED --
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE INMATE MAY
NOT HAVE RECEIVED.
DISCIPLINARY HEARINGS FOR FIVE
YEARS BUT HE WILL NEVER EARN HIS
WAY DOWN BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
LEVEL OF POINTS BECAUSE HE
EARNED THEM EARLY ON IN HIS
PRISON TERM.
SO WE TAKE THEM AND SAY WE
RECOGNIZE YOU HAVEN'T BEHAVE
THIS WAY FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
YOU EARN THOSE HIGH LEVEL POINTS
EARLY ON IN YOUR CAREER BUT
YOU'VE DEMONSTRATED YOU DO WANT
TO PARTICIPATE.
SO WE HAVE THOUSANDS AND I CAN
GET YOU THAT EXACT NUMBER AT
ANOTHER TIME WE HAVE THOUSANDS
OF INMATES WE HAVE DISCIPLINE
EVERY OVER WRITTEN AND
RECOGNIZING.
THE PAST BEHAVIOR DOESN'T
DICTATE TO THEY ARE NOW --
I WISH WE WERE OUT OF THE OSCAR
LAWSUIT I FELT THAT WE HAVE
SATISFIED THE INITIAL CONCERNS
OF THE LAWSUIT AND ADDRESS ISSUE.
BUT CLEARLY WE WE WE STILL HAVE
MORE CHALLENGES --
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
KEEP IN BROUGHT UP THANK YOU I'M
SURE WILL RETURN TO THAT
DISCUSSION AT SOME POINT. FOR TO
IT --
CALLING.
YES SENATOR STONE WE WERE LIKE
SKIS ME GO AHEAD [inaudible]
I'M SURE.
THANK YOU MISTER DE IS.
THIS IS MY FIRST [inaudible]
MEETING.
FOR SOME FIVE ARE USE NERVOUS AS
I AM.
MAYBE.
SO I I JUST HAVE SOME REALLY
BASIC QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST IS.
YOU REALLY REYES PROP.
FIFTY SEVEN AND WE'RE SORT OF ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF IT AND WE'RE
SEEING.
OTHER ISSUES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WITH PERSONAL RAIMES.
SHOPLIFTING ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS SO.
IF YOU GIVEN SOME [inaudible]
REALLY POSITIVE.
FACTORS AT YOUR BENEFITING FROM
IN SEOUL.
HELP ME OUT A LITTLE MORE --
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S TWO COMPONENTS
TO PROP FIFTY SEVEN AND YOU'RE
SORT OF EDUCATING ME ON YOUR
SIDE.
I IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE YOU
WANT TO ADD TO TO TO YOUR
REMARKS.
SO ALL PUT ON MY TRANSITION HAD
WHEN WE TRANSITION THE INMATE
FROM PRISON BACK TO THE
COMMUNITIES.
AND FOR ME ON ON THAT ASPECT IT
IT'S IT'S CRITICAL.
THAT WE ARE COMMUNICATING WITH
OUR CITY AND COUNTY PARTNERS.
ON HOW WE PROPERLY TRANSITION AN
INDIVIDUAL FROM INCARCERATION TO
THE COMMUNITY AND THE WAYS THAT
WE DO THAT IS WE WORK WITH OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS. TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THEM IF THE INDIVIDUAL IS
GOING OFF TO COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION ON THE PROBATION
SIDE.
AND WHAT I DO AT SECRETARY I
MEET QUITE OFTEN COMMUNICATE
QUITE OFTEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PROBATION OFFICERS CHIEFS A
GROUP SEE PARK --
AND WE WORK TOGETHER ON WHAT WE
MAY BE --
FAILING ON ON OUR END OF WHAT
THEY NEED SO THEY CAN BETTER
TRANSITION ON THE PREVENTION
SIDE.
WE ARM AND ONE OF THOSE THINGS
IS TO ENSURE THAT --
MENTALLY ILL INMATE WE'RE HAVING
A PROPER TRANSITION WITH THEM --
AND EVEN THE MEDICAL INMATES BUT
THEN NOT ONLY THE MENTAL HEALTH
IN THE MEDICAL BUT ALSO ON THE
JOB SIDE. TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
COMMUNICATING WITH OUR CITY AND
COUNTY PARTNERS AND AND A PRO
PARTNERS THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
THAT BEEN RELEASED HAS THESE
CERTIFICATIONS WHETHER IT BE.
WELDING CARPENTRY PLUMBING
THEY'VE BEEN CERTIFIED IN THESE
VARIOUS PROGRAMS IN THESE ARE
NATIONALLY CERTIFIED RECOGNIZED
TO BECAUSE THEY RECEIVE.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THE BEING
UTILIZED IN ONE OF THOSE EFFORTS
IS A PRISON TO EMPLOYMENT
EFFORTS THAT WE ARE DOING RIGHT
NOW.
AND WHAT THAT DOES FOR US IS
WITH -- WITH
WORK WITHIN CDC ARE WITH OUR
LABOR PARTNERS --
WITH THE THE LOCAL UNIONS --
WE ARE MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
MAKING THOSE CONNECTIONS AND
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS WE'VE HAD --
STATE AGENCIES COME IN AND GIVE
STATE EXAMINATIONS FOR INMATES
WILL QUALIFY FOR CERTAIN JOBS.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO GET THEM
EMPLOYED AND WE'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WITH THAT WE'VE HAD --
IN MAKES MORE --
RECEIVED THOSE --
EXAMINATIONS HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN JOB OFFERS.
SO WE RECOGNIZE THAT A
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION IS TO MAKE
SURE THE NEEDS ARE MET.
HOUSING MEDICAL EMPLOYMENT --
SO THAT SERVES ME THAT'S
ENCOURAGING BUT ALSO.
THE PARTNERSHIP WITH CDC OTHER
WE HAVE WITH --
THE CALIFORNIA CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION FEES POLICE
ASSOCIATION WHICH I JUST SPOKE
OUT YESTERDAY IN SANTA CLARA.
I GIVE A PRESENTATION SIMILAR TO
THIS BUT THEN I ALSO FILLED
CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS THAT THEY
MAY BE HAVING AND THEY ARE
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU BY SENATOR.
APOLOGIES BUT I JUST WANTED TO
STAY FOCUSED AND THE QUESTION
WAS ABOUT. FIFTY SEVEN AND THE
CORE LE IN.
AN INCREASE IN SUCH CRIMES.
AND SO I WOULD.
IF I TYPE ALL THOSE OF MY RECORD
I COULD TO I GUESS FOR A VERY
ENTERTAINING STOP BOTHERING THE
WELL I JUST I WOULD JUST SUCH
AND I'M TRYING TO MAKE YEAH
BECAUSE OTHERWISE I'M GONNA ASK
A VERY SIMILAR QUESTION AND TRY
TO GET THE ACTUAL.
BUT ANYWAY YOU PROCEED --
I WAS A SUPERVISOR FOR EIGHT
YEARS FOR THE COUNTY OF ORANGE
AND AND MOST OF THAT TIME I WAS
CHAIR OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
CRIMINAL JUSTICE CORDONING
COMMITTEES I HAD THE JOY OF
WORKING WITH.
THE CHEAPER PROBATION AND THE
SHERIFF AND THE DA AND WE WOULD
MEET ONCE A MONTH AND SO THERE
IS A LOT TO LEARN --
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
PAROLE AND PROBATION AND I'LL BE
SPEAKING TO SEE PARK MYSELF THIS
MONTH AND STEVE SEGMENT IS MIKE
CHIEF AND WORK TOGETHER FOR
YEARS LIKE.
I HAVE BUT I HAVE A A NEW
LEARNING CURVE NOW --
ON THIS SIDE IF YOU LIKE I I I
WOULD WELCOME AN INVITATION I
COULD BRIEF YOU ON A MORE
GRANULAR LEVEL OF THE GRAPHIC
THAT BE GREAT JOB MY STAFF REACH
OUT TO YOUR STAFF WE CAN SET UP
pTHE BRAIN AND SO THE ONLY OTHER
QUESTION I WOULD HAVE.
MEANT I'M SURE IS A AND IT'S
IT'S LATER IN THE REPORT BUT AT
CDC ARE WANTS TO ADD A LOT OF
FIGURE OUT WHY.
A WIN.
HAVING BEEN A DEPARTMENT HEAD.
AS WELL I I DON'T SEE.
WORKLOAD INCREASING ENOUGH TO
WARRANT EVEN A FULL TIME.
EQUIVALENT POSITION SO --
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL WIN WE
WOULD ASK ON ON ISSUE TO IS THIS
THE TIME MORE I'M ISSUE TO WILL
GET THEM.
INTO ADDITION TO BUT I THINK
IT'S PERFECTLY LEGITIMATE GIVEN
THAT THE SECRETARIES GIVEN US
THE OVERVIEW.
I THINK IT'S A PERFECTLY
LEGITIMATE QUESTION JUST JUST
AROUND THIS YEAH WHY ARE WE
INCREASING F. T. E. AT A POINT
WHERE.
WE ARE REDUCING POPULATION
INSIDE AND SEE THE TRAINING
WHEELS.
NO NO NO NO NO THESE ARE THESE
ARE GREAT QUESTIONS.
AND I WANNA MAKE SURE YOU YOU
RECEIVE THE INFORMATION LOOKING
FOR AND SOLD.
WELL I HAVE A IT SAYS FOR SENATE
BILL TWO THREE TWO SEVEN BY
QUIRK YOU NEED YOU'RE REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
WAS I MEAN.
WE'RE REQUESTING FOR AT THE NEXT
ISSUE WE GET TO IT IS A SERIES
OF BILLS THAT PASSED THROUGH --
LEGISLATION THAT DIDN'T HAVE AN
APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL.
TO ADD THE STAFF --
THAT WE NEED --
TO TO ENACT THOSE BILLS I WOULD
STATE TALKING ABOUT POSITIONS
JUST ON A ON A ON A BIGGER SCALE.
OUR POSITIONS THA WE HAVE WE
ARE ACTUALLY GOING DOWN IN THE
GENERAL SECURITY CATEGORY.
THE AS THE POPULATION GOES DOWN
THE POSITION WITHOUT OTHER
FACTORS WELL.
A LOT OF THE POSITION GROWTH
WERE EXPERIENCING.
ARE IN THE CATEGORIES OF PAROLE
WHERE WE'RE SEEING SORT OF THE
OPPOSITE.
OUR POPULATION IS GOING UP ALSO
IN REHABILITATION PROGRAMS WE
RAMP UP THOSE PROGRAMS TO TRY TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL THE
INMATES ARE SEEKINGCREDITS.
AND THEN OF COURSE --
ARE WE DOING A LOT OF WORK TO
TRY TO IMPLEMENT PROP SEVEN
THROUGH OUR FOR BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS HAVING POSITION GROWTH
THERE.
I THINK THE FOURTH CATEGORY
WOULD BE --
ON THE MEDICAL SIDE WE HAVE IS
THE RECEIVE ROLE.
I SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOVE AS
OUR POPULATION GETS MORE FRAIL.
ELDERLY WE HAVE AN AGING
POPULATION ARE MEDICAL NEEDS
HAVE BEEN GROWING.
BUT WE HAVE YOU KNOW OVERALL I
THINK THE THE POSITIVE THING --
LESS OF A NEED.
TRADITIONAL CDC ARE GENERAL
SECURITY POSITION.
FIVE THEN I'LL ASK ONE LAST
QUESTION AND IT'S ON PAGE. NINE
HUNDRED NUMBER FOUR AND IT'S
IT'S JUST A LITTLE PARAGRAPH AT
THE END.
AGE NINE OF OUR AT LEAST THE
REPORT I'VE BEEN IT SAYS UNDER
NUMBER FOR SENATE BILL.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE IT'S AS THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND
OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS WEST.
TWENTY SIX AND FOUR POINT BY
POSITIONS [inaudible]
RESPECTIVELY.
TOTAL OF THIRTY POINT FIVE
POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
DUTIES ASSOCIATED.
WITH A. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
AND I I FOR THE LIFE OF ME I
DON'T SEE ANY ADDITIONAL DUTIES.
FOR KEEPING PERSONNEL FILES SITE.
THERE'S A SO SO I'M I'M JUST WE
WE HAVE.
WE LET'S GET INTO THAT IN IF YOU
DON'T MIND YOU CAN GIVE US AN
OVERVIEW BECAUSE WHEN WE MIGHT.
WHAT MIGHT NOT?
TO A LEGITIMATE QUESTION MIGHT
BE AND WHY AREN'T WE RE
PURPOSING STAFF.
VERSES NEW BUT WE'RE GONNA GET
INTO MUCH DETAIL AROUND THESE
PARTICULAR THINGS IN THAT ITEM
TO BUT CERTAINLY.
I CAN GIVE OVER VERSUS YOU YEAH
FIRST OF ALL I'VE.
I'VE ALREADY RECEIVED SOME SOME
OF THE COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONCERNS ON THAT AND I THINK
Gí
WITH CORRECTIONS WE TRAIN HIT A
HOME RUN WE WANT TO JUST OVER
CHIEF AND WE THEN HAVE CONCERN
WITH THE RETROACTIVITY OF IT SO
I THINK IN A REQUEST THAT.
WE SEE HERE WE JUST WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE FULFILLING.
THE THE INTENT AND NEED AND
SPIRIT OF FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
BUT THE TEAM WE'VE WE'VE BRIEFED
AND YOU KNOW THE YOU CAN GET A
MORE GRANULAR DISCUSSION WITH
THEM.
BUT I THINK IT COMES FROM NOT SO
MUCH WE'RE TRYING TO EMPIRE
BUILD.
IT WAS TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE
IMPLEMENT IT CORRECTLY A BECAUSE
WE DO WANT TO BE THAT
TRANSPARENCY WE DO WHAT WE ARE
SO LARGE.
AND WE HAVE SO MUCH OVERSIGHT
AND RIGHTLY SO THE LARGE BUDGET
WE HAVE A HUGE MISSION.
AND WE DESERVE THAT OVERSIGHT SO
I THINK --
WHEN THE TEAM PRESENTS HERE BUT
I THINK II HOPE THIS THE?
NO THAT THE TASTE OF WHAT YOU
READ WASN'T --
GRAY HERE GOES CORRECTIONS AGAIN
IT WAS CAME FROM A SPIRIT OF
TRYING TO OVER ACHIEVE IN TRYING
TO DO IT RIGHT.
THOUGH MAYBE I SHOULD HAVE SAID
LIMITED TERM POSITION MAKE MAYBE
I MEAN WE TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT'S
EACH BE DEAD WITHIN THAT.
SO WE ARE EXAMINING THAT AND
THEN I'M SURE THE TEAM WILL IT
TAKE YOU AND MORE.
THANK YOU MISTER DAVIS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
EARLY SENATOR MORE LIKE AN NO
WORRIES IT'S PERFECTLY
LEGITIMATE ESPECIALLY IN THE
OVERVIEW TO ASK THINGS LIKE WHY
IS THEIR POSITION GROWTH.
WHY IS THERE NOT RE PURPOSING OF
BECAUSE THINGS WHICH THEN WHEN
WE GET INTO THE PARTICULAR ITEM
WE CAN EVEN GET MORE GRANULAR?
BUT I JUST WANT ONE MAKE ONE NO
BEFORE I TURN TO SENATOR BELT.
AROUND PROP SEVEN SINCE YOU
ASKED A SPECIFIC QUESTION.
AND CERTAINLY VERY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO MONITOR BUT I THINK WHAT
WE WHEN WE LOOK AT THE THE DATA
AND IT'S IT'S NOT --
ACROSS THE BOARD YET IN TERMS OF
THESE PROPERTY CRIMES AND SUCH
BUT THERE ARE DIFFERENT PLACES
IN THE STATE WHERE IT HAS
INCREASED.
WHAT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE?
IS THAT PROP FIFTY SEVEN RAKES
ONLY WENT INTO EFFECT.
LITTLE MORE THAN A YEAR AGO SO
THEY WERE ONLY WRAP IT IN IT IN
THE END OF NOVEMBER SEVENTEENTH
SO IN EFFECT WE'VE HAD A LITTLE
MORE THAN A YEAR OF THEIR AND
WHAT.
THE CREDIT ALLOW THE IN MAY TO
DO IS GIVES THEM A LITTLE --
TIME BEFORE THEY GO TO PROBE IT
DOESN'T GUARANTEE.
THEIR RELEASE IT ISN'T LIKE.
AIDES SAY OUR SENTENCING CHANGES
THAT MIGHT THEN SAY OKAY YOU
WERE SPENT FOR THIS ORIGINALLY.
BUT ACTUALLY UNDER THIS NEW LAW
YOU SHOULD HAVE ONLY BEEN CENTS
FOR THAT SO YOU'RE ELIGIBLE NOW
FOR RELEASE.
THE PROP FIFTY SEVEN ONLY GIVES
YOU SO NOW I HAVE A FOUR MUCH
QUICKER TO GO BEFORE PAROLE AND
I KNOW THAT.
AS OBVIOUSLY IF SINCE IT'S ONLY
BEEN IN EFFECT FOR LITTLE MORE
THAN A YEAR YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
THAT MANY PEOPLE YET.
HAVING GONE BEFORE PAROLE SO YOU
WORTH IT FOR US TO GET THE DATA
ON HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE YOU BEEN.
UNDER FIFTY SEVEN BEEN ADVANCED.
THE OTHER THING TO KNOW IN EARLY
LATER IS THAT WE ONLY HAVE AN
18% RATE.
OF IF YOU GO BEFORE PAROLE
YOU'RE BEING RELEASED.
SO EVERYONE GOES BEFORE A PAROLE
IT'S ONLY 18% THAT SO MY OWN.
SUSPICION WE HAVE TO GET DATA IS
THAT.
WE'VE NOT HAD VERY MANY PEOPLE
RELEASED AS A RESULT OF PROPERTY.
SO IF WE ARE LOOKING AT OF
REPEAT OFFENDERS IT MAY BE MORE
FROM THE COUNTY JAIL LEVEL
THOUGH I DON'T EVEN KNOW YET
WHETHER OR ANY TYPE OF PROPERTY
CRIME.
HAS BEEN REPEAT OFFENDERS OR
WHETHER IT'S NEW OFFENDERS SO I
JUST MAKE THOSE POINTS BECAUSE
IT'S CONVENIENT SOMETIMES A LINK
THESE THINGS.
BUT WE DON'T YET DATA THE GIVES
US ANY REAL ABILITY TO LIKE
THOSE THINGS.
AND M. JUST TO ADD JUST A LITTLE
BIT MORE --
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO HOPE TO MEET SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS WITH THE
AMENDED RAGS. TO EXPAND SOME
SOME ASPECTS OF FOR THE SEVEN
RIGHT SENATOR ABOUT [inaudible]
SO.
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND STEPPING FORWARD TO
BE OUR DIRECTOR AND I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH PERSONAL IN THANK
YOU.
YOU KNOW I KNOW I KNOW THAT --
IT'S SO.
WONDERFUL TO HAVE YOU.
ABLE TO DO THAT AS ONLY WITH SO
MUCH EXPERIENCE.
IN A DEPARTMENT STORE WE SHOULD
DOLLAR JUST TO REALLY DO I WANT
TO SAY THAT FIRST.
I I IN TERMS OF YOUR DEPARTMENT --
THEY'RE JUST OF MANAGED CARE THE
OLD VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION --
THIRTY SIX THEY PROVED --
THAT WAS IN --
TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY FOURTEEN WE
HAD THE COURT ORDER THE OF
NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
OF TOOK PLACE WE HAD THAT.
AGREEMENT THAT WE PROMISED THAT
WE WOULD DO.
CERTAIN THINGS OF THAT WE WERE
DOING THAT WE HAD PROP.
FORTY SEVEN THE VOTERS APPROVE
THAT AND TWENTY FOURTEEN THERE
WAS -- SOME
HOPE THERE TO A FROM FORTY SEVEN
WOULD LEAD TO SAVINGS.
OF SAVINGS THAT WOULD BE USED --
FOR SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY.
OF THAT WAS THE PURPOSE OF PROP.
FORTY SEVEN THEY WERE PROPOSING
THAT [inaudible]
TRANSFERRING --
MONEY TO THE SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS --
AND SCHOOLS.
OKAY SO --
DEALING WITH MAYBE THERE'S SOME
OF THE SUBJECTS THAT YOU HAVE.
CONCERNS ABOUT --
SORT OF THE TRUANCY THERE THEY
WERE TALKING OF PROPERTIES OR
SEVEN TALKED ABOUT.
TRUANCY THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
HELPING THE YOUNG PEOPLE THERE
WITH CRIME THOSE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS.
OF I KNOW THEY'RE VERY
SUCCESSFUL ON SAN JOSE.
OF AS A PROGRAMS OF THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE GOOD.
FROM FORTY SEVEN WAS ALL ABOUT
THAT YOU HAD NOVEMBER --
SIXTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN PROP --
FIFTY SEVEN THE VOTERS APPROVED
OUT SO IT'S BEEN BASICALLY THE
COURT ORDER THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION.
WE HAD THREE PROPOSITIONS.
THE THREE PROPOSITIONS HAD A
DIRECTION --
TOWARDS --
LOWERING INCARCERATION.
OF HAVING BETTER PROGRAMS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND YET.
OF THE POPULATION --
I'M I'M LOOKING AT THE
POPULATION.
AND I AND I WONDER.
I WONDER --
THE QUESTION I HAVE IN THE
GENERAL IS WE NEED.
TO ASSESS WHETHER OR NOT --
TO IMPLEMENTING THOSE
PROPOSITIONS EFFECTIVELY AND
INTO THE BEST MATTER THEY CAN.
OKAY SO THAT'S SO SO THINGS LIKE.
ARE WE CALCULATING --
ELIGIBILITY RELEASE DATES --
PROPERLY IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MANNER.
OF THE DO WE HAVE IN MADE
[inaudible]
CREDIT EARNING.
OF TO MAXIMIZE THEIR CREDIT
EARNING YOU MENTION [inaudible]
THAT --
LIFERS.
WE'RE BE GIVEN SLOTS AND
PROGRAMS --
WELL YOU DO THAT THEN YOU YOU
MAKE A WAITING LIST FOR PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO EARN CREDITS.
ESSENTIALLY RIGHT.
SO I I I BE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
KIND OF STUFF THE RUNNING OF
CREDITS AND WHAT YOUR RULES ARE.
THAT GO AGAINST MAYBE THE
DIRECTION OF THE THREE
PROPOSITIONS AND THE COURT
ORDERED DIRECTION.
AND THEN THE M. MADE THE SIR OF
I'M ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT IN
MADE --
DISCIPLINARY PROCESSES AND
WHETHER OR NOT.
WE'RE RECOGNIZING THE MENTAL
HEALTH ASPECTS OF THOSE.
INMATES AS OPPOSED TO JUST BEING
A DESPAIRING --
THE SECURE HOUSING UNITS OF
SHOES OR OR USED TO HOUSE.
OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE PROBLEMS AND
WHETHER OR NOT.
THAT IS ADEQUATE --
THE ALBUM IS A QUESTION --
YOUR JUST WARY OF PROCESSING
CREDIT FORFEITURES PROCESS.
AND ANY OPPORTUNITIES REMINISCES
EARNED A CREDITS HOW HOW IS IT
INHIBITED BY YOUR REGULATIONS.
AND THEN YOUR RELEASE PROCESSES
WE HAVE --
PROPOSITION TALKED ABOUT.
THE YOU MISSION AGING PRISON
POPULATION WORLD WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH --
RELEASING AGING PRISONERS I
REMEMBER WHEN I WAS IN STOCKTON --
THERE IS A GUY WE'LL BY ME I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WERE WITH ME
AT THE TIME BUT I WILL BUY ME IN
A WHEELCHAIR AND ASKS YOU LOOK A
VERY OLD MAN.
HE WAS IN IN YOUR FACILITY AND I
I WAS WONDERING HOW OLD WAS.
AND YOUR PRISONERS IN THEIR
NINETIES AND NOT SURE WHAT A
CENTURION.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE THE
CENTURION ANYMORE I THINK THOSE
ON WHO WERE IN THE NINETIES I
WANT TO SAY WE HAVE.
I COULD BE WRONG BY OFF ONE OR
TWO BUT WE HAVE FIVE OR SIX
INMATES IN THE NINETY FIVE OR
SIX THEIR INNER NINETIES OKAY SO.
NOW AS WELL AS I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY DID OR WHY POINT THE POINT
I'M MAKING IS THE YOU KNOW OF
THEY'VE.
THE VOTERS APPROVE SOMETHING AND
SO MAYBE WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT HOW
THAT'S BEEN IMPLEMENTED IS THAT
EFFECTIVE.
I KNOW I KNOW THE COMPASSIONATE
RELEASE I'M GOING THROUGH THAT
WITH THE PERSON IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE.
THEY TOOK ALL THE STEPS
NECESSARY FOR COMPASSIONATE
RELEASE AND WAS SO COMPLICATED
TOOK MONTHS AND MONTHS AND
MONTHS.
AND TWO WEEKS BEFORE THE PERSON
WAS SCHEDULED TO BE RELEASED A
ROOF THE PERSON DIED IN THE
PRESENT.
SO IT WAS A TRAGEDY FOR THE
FAMILY.
PERSON WAS L. ON HER DEATHBED
LITERALLY THEY WERE GOING TO
RELEASE --
AND WILL BE WITH THE FAMILY AND
HE WAS GOING TO PASS AWAY.
PASS ON BUT BUT HE A THE
COMPLICATED PROCESS WAS.
SO COMPLICATED THAT OF HE WASN'T
ABLE. TO TO MAKE IT OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL IN THE SOLANO HOSPITAL
OVER THERE SO SO I THINK I CHECK
GO.
I THINK WHAT I'M LOOKING ON IS --
THESE POLICIES THAT YOU HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROPOSITIONS.
AND WHETHER OR NOT WERE
MAXIMIZING THEIR POTENTIAL.
TO RELEASE PRISONERS IN AN
EFFECTIVE WAY.
AND SUPPORT THESE.
BY RELEASING THEM --
NEARLY PROGRAMS.
THAT OR FUNDED WITH PROP FORTY
SEVEN ANOTHER FUNDS THAT WE HAVE --
IN -- PUBLIC
SAFETY ARENA YOU KNOW FUNDING
PROGRAMS IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO I'M INTERESTED IN --
LOOKING AT THAT PARTICULAR --
WITH YOU AND EXPLORING HOW TO BE
MORE EFFICIENT AND MEASURE.
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND YOUR
REGULATIONS WITHOUT YOUR
REGULATION.
IMPACT.
ON THESE THINGS LIKE RELEASING
PRISONERS NOW THE PRIVATE
PRISONS -- I
A I I JUST SAY THIS --
I DON'T LIKE PRIVATE PRISONS I
DON'T THINK THEY HAVE THE
STANDARDS OF CARE --
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR FACILITIES
AFTER ALL THE DECADE THAT I'VE
BEEN HERE WORKING WITH THE COURT
ORDER AND ALL THE THINGS WE'VE
DONE.
TO IMPROVE OUR FACILITIES.
THE CAPITAL INVESTMENTS THE THE
STAFF INVESTMENTS ALL OF MONEY
THAT WE SPENT.
AND THEN WE HAVE THESE PRIVATE
PRISONS THAT HAVE LIKE.
THE JUST NOT EVEN COMPARABLE
STANDARDS TO THE STANDARDS THAT
WE HAVE.
IN OUR FACILITY SO I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT WE WANT --
TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF THOSE
PRIVATE.
FACILITIES BECAUSE QUITE
PERSONALLY I THINK THERE ARE.
THERE REALLY --
NOT TREATED THE SAME AS SOMEBODY
AND A STATE OWNED OPERATED
BILLION WHICH YOU AGREE WITH THE
GENERAL CONCEPT.
I THINK IN GENERAL I WOULD LIKE
TO WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE PRIVATE
FACILITIES IS STILL UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND WE
THE THE STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE
IN THE PROGRAMS.
THE OVERSIGHT COMES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THERE'S AN THAT WE
ADDRESS IT.
BUT AS IN HOW TO BEST USE THE
THE DOLLARS OF THE CITIZENS THE
CALIFORNIA --
I I BELIEVE IN WHAT WE DO
INSTEAD OF OUR PRISONS --
BUT I KNOW THIS IS A DELICATE
BALANCE ON WE BRING THEM BACK
BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT ONE
THIRTY SEVEN FIVE NUMBER.
AND EVERYTHING THAT YOU BROUGHT
UP AND I WROTE DOWN SEVEN POINTS
AND IF YOU LIKE I COULD DO I
COULD ADDRESS ALL THE SEVEN
POINT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ARE
YOU ADDRESS OF OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS BUT YEAH OF OF THE PEOPLE
OUT.
NO NO I APPRECIATE.
IN OPPOSITION I'M GIVING YOU MY
BASIC [inaudible]
I'M GONNA.
YEAH BUT I I I I THINK I THINK
THE I THINK THAT THE PRIVATE
PRISONS.
THE STAFF TRAINING THE HIRING
POLICIES THAT TYPE OF PEOPLE --
BECAUSE THE PRISONERS OF YOU
KNOW AS I I VISITED YOU KNOW
QUITE A FEW WITH YOU AND OTHER
PEOPLE --
THEY GROW UP TO ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE OR SO --
I THINK I'M GOING TO DONOVAN TO
THOSE --
DOWN IN YOUR YOU WANT TO GO
SINCE SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
SO SO -- I
THINK I THINK YOU'RE ALL --
YOU KNOW I SEE THE STAFF IS
BEING.
HIRE TRAIN LEVEL OF TRAINING AND
QUALITY THAN.
WHAT YOU SEE AND --
PRIVATE LOANS RIGHT I THINK IT'S
NOT FAIR TO SAY.
AND AND I'D LIKE TO VERIFICATION
WE IT'S YOU'RE REFERRING TO
ARIZONA IS BECAUSE IT IS OUR
ONLY ONE ONLY THAT'S RIGHT.
AS WE HAVE SOME IN --
WE HAVE SOME FACILITIES THAT WE
HAVE PEOPLE IN THE IT ALL FOR
NOW YEAH WE HAVE.
YEAH UNDER CONTRACT.
BUT IT IS OUR GOAL IT IS OUR
GOAL AND I'M CONFIDENT.
AND WITH THIS GOAL IN REACHING
HAVING ABOUT BY JUNE.
YES OKAY SO THOSE ARE MY
QUESTIONS I THINK I WANT TO
EXPLORE TO OKAY OF THE WORKING
WITH YOU AND THE CHAIR.
OUR COMMITTEE --
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS I HAD --
ON THE BUDGET.
DOCUMENT --
WANT TO READ IT --
THERE'S A HIT WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT MAINTENANCE AND ALL THAT
I'M EXCITED ABOUT TALKING ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE I THINK.
I'VE BEEN LONG WAITING FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE MAY I SUPPORT THAT
BUT I WANNA I WANNA.
I WANT TO KNOW ABOUT --
THE TATTOO REMOVAL.
PROGRAM I THINK THAT'S AYE AYE
IF IT'S NOT REALLY A KEY FOR THE
PRISON IT'S WHAT I HEAR FROM
PEOPLE IN THE PRISONS ARE IT'S
NOT REALLY SOMETHING THEY WANT.
TO DO.
BUT THERE'S PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
THE COUNTY JAILS AND ALL OVER
THEY WANT TO DO IT SO.
IT'S IS A BIGGER ISSUE THAN WE
MIGHT REALIZE THAT PEOPLE WANT
TO REMOVE THEIR TATTOOS ON
ESPECIALLY THE FACIAL ONE RIGHT
I I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THAT --
I THINK WHAT ONCE AN INDIVIDUAL
MAKES THAT CHOICE TO REMOVE.
THE TATTOO THEY'RE MAKING THAT
CHOICE THEY THEY DO WANT.
TO HAVE A BETTER CHANCE AT ROCK
I HEARD I HEARD FROM A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT IT'S A SCARY PROCESS
THIS FOR A I I HAVE HAD FRIENDS
WHO HAVE DONE IT AND I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S SCARY YOU KNOW I
THINK.
THIS IS THE INFO ANYWAY.
AND SO -- SO
THERE WE WHAT WE WANT TO GET --
BUT I HEAR THERE'S A NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT THE LESS PAINFUL
AFTER REMOVAL MACHINE.
SO WE WANT TO GET THE ONE THAT
I'M NOT SURE I DON'T --
I DON'T HAVE ONE SO I DON'T KNOW.
WE MIGHT TELL SOMEBODY MAYBE
ONLY AND OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
YEP THE GOT YEAH I KNOW.
BUT I HEARD I HEARD THAT THERE'S
LESS PAINFUL ONE SO I'M
INTERESTED IN WHAT WERE.
I LOOK FOR A PROPOSING ON THAT --
SOME PEOPLE SUGGEST A MOBILE
OUTSIDE TO REMOVAL SYSTEM.
WE CAN MOVE AROUND TO ALL THE
PRISONS.
I GUESS --
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT AT THE
TIME AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEASURE.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA DO
PUBLIC.
MY MY GOD WE'RE GONNA GET YOUR
FROM PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM
ON THIS OVERVIEW I'M NOT GONNA
CALL IN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
BECAUSE THIS WAS THE OVERVIEW
BUT IN OUR NEXT ITEMS PART IN
FINANCE WILL COMMENT.
SO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
OVERVIEW NOT ON THE INDIVIDUAL
ITEMS THAT ARE STILL BEFORE US
ANYONE OVERVIEW.
ALL RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SEC THREE DS OKAY
WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO THE FUN BC
PEAS.
THE END.
I'M ISSUE TO THE OUR
CONSOLIDATED LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL WHICH ARE --
WE BEGAN TO VISIT A BIT THE ASK
FOR ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR
IMPLEMENTING AB 212-327-2840
FIVE SB NINE SIXTY SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE AND SB.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN AND WE HAVE
OUR WE HAVE HOWARD MOSTLY THE
ACTING OFFICE OF LEGAL AFFAIRS
IN JOE GALVIN THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
FOR I SEE THIS YEAR'S POLICY
RESEARCH IN INTERNAL OVERSIGHT
MEANING INTERNAL AFFAIRS --
SO I'M ASSUMING THAT --
ACTING SECRETARY MOSTLY YOU WANT
TO START.
I SAW MR GOV AND HAS AN OPEN
MISTER GOLDMAN'S GONNA START
OKAY.
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JOANNE AND I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE.
INTERNAL AFFAIRS THE ENTITY
WITHIN A GARLIC FORMAL INTERNAL
AFFAIRS INVESTIGATOR.
YEAH I SAID IF YOU ALLEGATIONS
OF EMPLOYEE CRIMINAL AND IT IS
ON C. C. R. ANY ADMINISTRATION A
MINUTE COOLEY IMPLEMENTING SP
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE TO INCLUDE
APPLYING IT RETROACTIVELY.
THE FACT WE RECEIVED OUR FIRST
REQUESTED A FEW MINUTES AFTER
MIDNIGHT.
I JUST WANNA MAKE A CORRECTION
BECAUSE RETROACTIVE CONTINUES TO
BE USED SO COMMONLY.
THAT IS NOT IT YOU ARE NOT GOING
TO BE IMPLEMENTING IT
RETROACTIVELY NOR IS ANY OTHER
AGENCY IN THE ENTIRE STATE TO
IMPLEMENT THAT BILL
RETROACTIVELY WOULD MEAN THAT
YOU WOULD BEGIN TO FULFILL
REQUESTS THAT YOU RECEIVED.
PRIOR TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN NO ONE IS EXPECTING YOU
TO FULFILL REQUESTS RECEIVED
PRIOR.
TO TWENTY NINETEEN I'M WHAT YOU
WILL BE DOING IS.
UPON RQUESTS MADE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN AND AFTER YOU
WILL BE LOOKING AT ALL RECORDS
IN YOUR POSSESSION.
AS THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUIRES SO IT IS NOT AN ISSUE
OF RETROACTIVITY AND I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR ON THE RECORD THANK YOU.
FOR THE RECORD THAT
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT ADOPTS
EXACTLY.
THE STANCE THAT WAS JUST
ARTICULATED BY THE CHAIR.
YES MA'AM TRIPOLITAN.
REALLY THAT INCORRECTLY.
WE RECEIVE UP TO UP TO THIS
POINT TWENTY ONE OR TWO WILL
WORKING HARD TO FILL THOSE.
PROVIDE THE RECORDS.
OKAY WEST WERE ALL RECEIVED
AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN HONOR AFTER THANK YOU.
FOR WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING FRIDAY.
AS THE GATE OF THE DISPLAY
PROCESSES.
CURRENT LAW UNDER THE GOVERNMENT
CODE REQUIRES.
A COMPLETE INVESTIGATIONS AND
DISCIPLINE AND ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST EMPLOYMENT UNDER.
WITHIN ONE YEAR OF THE DAY TO
DISCOVERY.
AND THE NEW LAW REQUIRES WE
PROVIDE INFORMATION RELATED TO
YOUR REQUESTS AND CERTAIN
CATEGORIES --
WITHIN THE SIX MONTHS AFTER THE
INCIDENT OCCURS.
THE LAWS SOUND POLICY AND WE
TOOK IT VERY SERIOUSLY TRY TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT WE THOUGHT
WE CAN BEST IMPLEMENT THE LAW.
AND ROBUST FASHION. FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE DOES NOT REQUIRE US
TO EXPEDITE THE TO COMPLETE
DESTINATIONS IN SIX MONTHS.
WE WERE LOOKING FOR A WAY TO
BALANCE THE NEED FOR
TRANSPARENCY WHILE MAINTAINING
THE INTEGRITY OF THE
INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS.
AND WE THOUGHT --
THAT COMPLETING INVESTIGATIONS --
DISCIPLINE WITHIN A SIX MONTH
TIME PERIOD WOULD BE A GOOD
APPROACH --
WE REALIZE OUR PLAN REQUEST IS
ONLY ONE WAY TO ADDRESS THIS
PROCESS AND THAT OTHER AGENCIES
MAY HAVE DIFFERENT INNOVATIVE
IDEAS.
ON HOW TO BEST THE FROZEN PRO
TEMPORE MENTORSHIP.
WE WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW THE REVIEW THOSE OTHER
IDEAS TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO
REFINE HOW WE CAN BEST IMPLEMENT
THE LAW.
THE WAY THAT YOU ENVISION.
HOPEFULLY MISTER MILLS IN I CAN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE NOW YOUR YOUR PCP REQUEST
IS NOT ONLY POSITIONS FOR
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE BUT SOME OF
THE OTHER BILL SO PERHAPS YOU
COULD.
GET INTO THAT A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE YEAH HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT AT ALL YEAH AND IF I
FORGOT TO INTRODUCE MYSELF
BEFORE I MERRICK'S ONCE OF THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF CDC OURS
OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES.
WE DO HAVE THERE ARE FIVE BILLS
THAT ARE PART OF THIS LEDGE BCP
PROCESS SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
WHICH WE JUST TALKED ABOUT.
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FIVE SB.
NINE SIXTY AND SB. FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE IT IS ARE
PROBABLY OUR MOST SIGNIFICANT
REQUEST THE MAJORITY OF THE
POSITIONS.
THAT WE HAVE REQUESTED ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL BUT WE
DO HAVE EXPERTS ON IMPLEMENTING
THE OTHER BILLS AS WELL.
THERE ARE A TOTAL OF IT'S A
TOTAL OF NINE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR THE B. C. P.
FORTY TWO POINT FIVE POSITIONS.
IN A BATH OFFICE OF LEGAL
AFFAIRS THAT DID JOIN THIS B. C.
P. I CAN I REASSURED THE CHAIR
WE HAVE RECEIVED TWENTY THREE P.
R. A.'S AFTER JOE A JANUARY
FIRST ST.
I WE DID ACTUALLY RECEIVE SOME
P. R. A.'S PRIOR TO THE JANUARY
FOR STATE BUT WE MADE IT CLEAR
TO THE I REQUEST HERS.
THAT THE LIGHT NOT GONE INTO
EFFECT YET AND SO THEY OBVIOUSLY
A WAITED AND AS MR GALVIN
INDICATED WE RESEARCH RECEIVED
OUR FIRST REQUEST THE FIRST
MINUTE AFTER MIDNIGHT ON JANUARY
FIRST.
THAT REQUEST --
ASKED FOR ALL FOUR CATEGORY
INCIDENTS AND ASK FOR IT FOR THE
ENTIRE FIVE YEAR PERIOD I PRIOR
TO THAT DATE.
AND SO IT WAS A COMPREHENSIVE
REQUEST BY MEDIA ORGANIZATION
WHICH IS PERMITTED UNDER THE LAW.
AND AS MR GALVIN WAS DESCRIBING
OUR GOAL IS TO PROVIDE MAXIMUM
TRANSPARENCY UP AS THE LAW
INTENDED.
THERE ARE TO ADD THOSE TWO
COMPETING PROVISIONS THE
TRANSPARENCY UNDER.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AS WELL AS
THE OBLIGATION THAT THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS AS A WHOLE. TO
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS WITHIN A
ONE YEAR TIME PERIOD LOOKING AT
THOSE TWO COMPETING INTERESTS.
IT WAS DETERMINED AS A POLICY
MATTER THAT AN IDEAL.
CHOICE WOULD BE TO ACCOMPLISH
ALL OF THE INVESTIGATIONS WITHIN
A SIX MONTH PERIOD. TO THE BOTH
THE ONE YOU'RE STASHED
IMITATIONS AS WELL AS THE SIX
MONTH.
REQUIREMENT UNDER FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE COULD BE MET.
BUT AS MR GALVIN INDICATED THIS
IS ONE POLICY CHOICE FOR SOLVING
THE PROBLEM WE'RE AWARE NOW THAT
THE H. P. AS I SUGGESTED A
LIMITED TERM.
APPROACH TO THE STAFF SO THAT
THEY CAN THEN STUDY THE MATTER
AFTER A YEAR TO PERHAPS COME
BACK.
WITH A MORE --
THE EVIDENCE BASED REQUEST FOR
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND THAT
CERTAINLY ANOTHER OPTION THAT WE
ARE.
OPEN TO SO WE PUT WHAT I WOULD
DESCRIBE AS OUR BEST FOOT
FORWARD --
DESCRIBING THE PERSONNEL THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED IN ORDER TO
MEET THE ONE YEAR TIME FRAME.
I WITHIN THE SIX MONTH TIME
FRAME AND THAT'S HOW THIS.
PROPOSAL WAS BUILT AB AGAIN WE
ARE CERTAINLY OPEN TO OTHER
SUGGESTIONS [inaudible]
I'M.
ANY COMMENT ANY OF YOU WANT TO
MAKE BEFORE WE START ASKING.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REALLY --
IN THE REST OF US TO START
ASKING OR MULTIPLE QUESTIONS ANY
COMMENT YOU WANT TO MAKE ABOUT
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY SEVEN AB.
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY FIVE SB NINE
SIXTY YOUR SB FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN ALL OF WHICH YOU ALSO HAVE
POSITION.
REQUESTING.
WE HAVE OTHER PANELS I BELIEVE
PREPARE TO DISCUSS THE OTHERS IF
THAT WAS IF YOU WANT I DID NOT
REALIZE THAT I DON'T.
I DO NOT HAVE OTHER PEOPLE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE SPEAKING TO
THOSE.
WE HAVE THEM AVAILABLE IF YOU
WANT TO GET INTO SPECIFICS ON
SOME OF THE OTHER BILLS I CAN
JUST TALK IN GENERAL ABOUT.
ALL THIS THE COMPONENTS OF THE
OF THE SPECIES P..
I WILL WE WILL CAN SEE IF
THERE'S QUESTIONS.
RATHER THAN BRINGING UP MORE
PEOPLE TO THE TABLE YET
[inaudible]
THE LA --
DID YOU HAVE ANY COMMENT.
IN RAISE ANY CONCERNS ON THIS
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
BERMAN FINANCE.
NOT ON THE CLEAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
FURTHER CON ACCEPTED JUST POINT
OUT THAT --
WHEN WE DID THE ORIGINAL B. C.
P. REQUEST IT WAS TO ENSURE PER
LEGISLATION THAT INVESTIGATIVE
FINDINGS COULD BE RELEASED
WITHIN A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT THAT REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT?
AGAIN TO BACK INTO A DATE WHERE
THE INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETED
AND OTHER RESOURCES ARE PROVIDED.
OF THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN THE
BCP WERE TO MEET THOSE TIME
FRAMES.
ALL RIGHT I'M --
IF MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD
INDULGE ME AS THE AUTHOR.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE TO GET A
LITTLE BIT INTO THIS.
SO [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
WHILE.
IT MIGHT BE.
THERE COULD BE A STRONG ARGUMENT
FOR BRIAN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
COMPLETE INVESTIGATIONS AND
SIXTY DAYS IS NOT REQUIRED UNDER
THE LAW.
IS RECOUP THE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS AND LET ME BACK UP FIRST.
THERE ARE ONLY FOUR CATEGORIES
OF RECORDS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
UNDER.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AND WHEN I
EIGHT ASKED IN ADVANCE OF THE
HEARING TO TRY TO GET SOME DATA.
ON SOME SENSE OF PAST INCIDENTS
THAT MIGHT --
YOU KNOW FALL UNDER IT IS YOURS
PER VIEW THAT ARE RELEVANT SO IF
WE FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THE
CATEGORIES OF DATA.
UNDER FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE IS
TAMPERING WITH A WITNESS --
INTERFERING WITH THE WITNESS OR
TAMPERING WITH EVIDENCE.
WHILE THAT COULD PERTAIN TO SOME
OF OUR STAFF WITHIN CDC ARE IT'S
A LESS LIKELY CATEGORY THAN THAN
UNDER.
OBVIOUSLY OUR OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES I'M ANOTHER
CATEGORY IS SEXUAL ASSAULT.
OF PROVEN SEXUAL ASSAULT.
I'M.
NOT HARASSMENT NOT BUT PROVEN SO
NOW THAT CAN HAPPEN IN A
CUSTODIAL CASES OBVIOUSLY
[inaudible]
BUT ON SO THAT COULD BE A
CATEGORY OF RECORDS THAT.
THE DCR MAY HAVE.
ON THE OTHER.
CATEGORY IS.
USE OF A WEAPON. FOUR DEADLY
FORCE [inaudible]
SO.
IT AND THAT IS A VERY CAREFULLY
DEFINED SO CERTAINLY.
ANY TYPE OF ALL IN EVERY TYPE OF
FORCE THAT A CUSTODIAL OFFICER
MIGHT USE WOULD NOT FALL UNDER
THAT CATEGORY [inaudible]
I'M.
AND AS A RESULT WHEN I LOOKED AT
THE DATA THAT WAS PROVIDED WHILE
IT'S NOT GRANULAR [inaudible]
IT.
IT WOULD APPEAR FROM QUICK FOR
LANCE THAT THERE WOULD BE FAR
FEWER RECORDS.
THAT CDC ARE EVEN AS LARGEST
POPULATION IS IN AS MANY --
BECAUSE DUTY OFFICERS THAT YOU
HAVE.
THAT IT WOULD BE FAR FEWER
RECORDS THAT WOULD BE EITHER IN
YOUR POSSESSION OR EVEN FALL
UNDER THE LAW THEN MANY MANY
OTHER OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
THAT WAS ONE ISSUE [inaudible]
SECONDARILY.
THE EXPERIENCE THAT AGENCIES ARE
NOW HAVING.
OF GETTING THE BROAD REQUESTS
GIVE US EVERYTHING YOUR IN YOUR
POSSESSION.
THAT MIGHT FALL UNDER FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE IS OF COURSE
HAPPENING BECAUSE FOR FORTY
YEARS.
THE PUBLIC AND OTHER HAVE HAD NO
ACCESS SO WE YOU KNOW WE KIND OF
OPENED UP FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SO THAT.
AND OF COURSE ONCE THOSE RECORDS
ARE RELEASED [inaudible]
THEN.
THE NEXT REQUEST CAN ONLY BE
PERTAIN TO ANYTHING NEW.
RIGHT ANY NEW INCIDENT.
SO IT IS.
BOTH FOR CDC ARE AND FOR
AGENCIES HAPPEN ON STATE RIGHT
NOW IS GOING TO BE A YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA GET THIS IT'S AN
INTENSIVE.
ALLOCATION OF RESOURCES TO MEET
THE REQUEST NOW BUT WILL JUST BY
THE VERY NATURE OF THAT YOU'RE
ONLY HANDING.
OUT.
MATERIALS BASED ON COMPLETED
INVESTIGATIONS.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE FAR LESS STAFF
REQUIREMENT.
AND ADDITIONALLY FIRST THE LAW
ONLY COVERS COMPLETION OF
INVESTIGATIONS ON A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS ON THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE.
NOT ON THE OTHER [inaudible]
THE ONGOING REQUIREMENT TO
INCREASE.
STAFF FOR INVESTIGATION.
IS AGAIN. ONE COULD ARGUE. FOR
MORE LIMITED THAN WHAT APPEARS
TO BE BEING RECOMMENDED.
AND SO WHEN I LOOK AT THE BEAST
HE AND I SEE THAT.
ONLY SEVEN POSITIONS ARE BEING
ASKED [inaudible] FOR TO PROVIDE
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE
ANTICIPATED INCREASES OF PARDON
CONNOTATION REVIEWS.
WHICH WE ARE POTENTIALLY
EXPECTING TO COVER FAR MORE
INMATES AND THE NUMBER OF RECORD
YOU MAY HAVE IN YOUR POSSESSION
UNDER FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AND I
LOOK AT FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AS
THIRTY POSITIONS I'M LIKE.
THIS KIND AT AND THEN WHEN I
LOOK AT THE BUT ASK FOR ONLY ONE
POSITION FOR SENATE BILL.
NINE SIXTY WHICH IS TO COMPLY
WITH NEWLY ENACTED SUICIDE WATCH
AND I WOULD IMAGINE YOU HAVE
QUITE A NUMBER OF INMATES.
ATTENTION WE UNDERSTOOD WERE
SIDE WATCH AND SO WE'RE ASKING
FOR A LOT OF DETAILED REPORTING
THAT'S GOING TO BE FOR EVER AND
CONSTANT.
AND YOURS ONLY NEEDING ONE
POSITION VERSES AGAIN THIRTY FTP.
FOR FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE I FIND
IT VERY HARD TO JUST.
BUT I DITION EARLY.
IN THIS IS A GENERAL THING IT
YOU'LL HEAR FROM ME AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND ALL BCP'S WITH NEW FTP
IN THIS DEPARTMENT.
GIVEN THAT WE ARE.
CLEAR THAT WE ARE REDUCING
POPULATION.
AND WE ARE CLEAR THAT WE MUST
BECAUSE WE ARE A COURT ORDER
[inaudible]
AND WHILE WE NEED.
TO DO THINGS EFFECTIVELY IMPROVE
AND INCREASE OUR REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS.
DO OTHER THINGS.
WE STILL.
LOOK AT THE F. T. E. THAT WE
HAVE.
AND HOW WE MOST EFFECTIVELY USE
THEM [inaudible]
VERSES.
INCREASING F. T..
IN GENERAL BECAUSE THIS IS ONE
OF THE FEW AREAS OUR WHAT WE
OVER PROVIDE OVERSIGHT ON IS ONE
OF THE FEW AREAS OF
DISCRETIONARY GENERAL.
SO EVERY BIT OF GENERAL FUND
THAT WE INCREASE HERE.
AND MANY TIMES IT'S VERY
LEGITIMATE BUT EVERY BIT OF
GENERAL FUND THAT WE INCREASE IN
THIS DEPARTMENT.
BASICALLY IMPEDES US FROM
PROVIDING GENERAL FUND.
FOR ANY OTHER PRIORITY TO ME.
WHATEVER OTHER PRIORITY THE
STATE MAY HAVE ISN'T ALREADY.
MANDATED BY NO IT'S NON
DISCRETIONARY.
SO OF COURSE WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY.
YES OPERATE SE WE ARE AT THE
HIGHEST QUALITY LEVEL POSSIBLE
INTO ABSOLUTELY USE OUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE ARE PROPERLY HOLDING PEOPLE
THAT ARE VERY DANGEROUS.
AND THAT ANY PEOPLE THAT WE
EXPECT TO BE GOING BACK TO A
COMMUNITY WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
THERE THERE RELEASED A ARE
[inaudible]
HI.
GOING TO GO BACK TO THAT
COMMITTEE SAFELY.
AND NOT --
RESERVE IT SO YES WE MUST DO
THAT BUT WHETHER THAT MEANS AN
INCREASE IN F. T. P..
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE A REDUCTION
IN POPULATION I THINK.
NEED TO BE ALWAYS VERY CAREFULLY
LOOKED AT AND WHAT I SEE IS
EVERY TIME.
A BILL PASSES.
WELL YES THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE APPROPRIATIONS.
YOU COME BACK WITH GIVE US MORE
PEOPLE GIVE US MORE PEOPLE
[inaudible]
NOT.
NOT LEGITIMATE IF YOU LOOK AT
HOW DO WE UTILIZE.
YES WE HAVE NEW PRIORITIES.
SO HOW DO WE UTILIZE THE STAFF
WE HAVE. TO ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS.
SO YOU CAN COMMENT BUT OTHERWISE --
WE CAN --
HERE FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THEN I CAN CALL MY
COLLEAGUES.
ALL THE CHAIRS POINTS ARE WELL
TAKEN AND BASED ON A STAFFER
QUESTIONS LEADING UP TO THE
COMMITTEE MEETING AND AND OTHER
ENQUIRIES.
IT'S BECOME APPARENT TO US THAT
WE NEED TO WORK WITH THE STAFF
AND BASICALLY RE ENGINEER THE
MODEL.
I I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
WHAT CAME FORWARD WAS MEANT IN
THE BEST OF INTENTIONS IT WASN'T.
SIMPLY TO AUGMENT A FOR A
PARTICULAR PERIOD.
THAT IS THE BUBBLE THAT I THINK
AT THE CHERRY IT WAS ACTUALLY A
RECONSIDERATION OF THE MODEL.
AND WHERE THE CURRENT STAFFING
AND THE CURRENT MODEL WITH IT'S
TIME LINES WAS BUILT ON THE
PREVIOUS WHEN YOU'RE STASHED
IMITATIONS.
IT WAS AN EFFORT TO ACCOMPLISH
THAT WORK IN A SIX MONTH PERIOD
OF TIME SO THAT THERE WOULD BE
COMPLETED INVESTIGATIONS
AVAILABLE FOR RELEASE.
UNDER FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE SO IT
WAS A REIMAGINE OF THE MODEL OF
THE TIMELINE THAT.
CREATED THE INCREASE BUT I THINK
YOU KNOW WITH THE CLEAR
DIRECTION IS BEING PROVIDED IN
THE INPUT.
I WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT
WE NEED TO RETURN AND LOOK AT
THE ACTUAL NUMBERS AND PERHAPS
THAT A GRAND SLAM WE WERE
SWINGING.
FOR NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED TO SOME
OF THE REALITIES THAT --
THE TEARS DESCRIBING WE'RE
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO ANSWER AS
MANY QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THIS
PROPOSAL WAS PUT TOGETHER AND
WHAT THE AIRLINES SECTIONS ABOUT
IT WERE --
BUT I I SAY THIS KNOWING THAT IN
THE END THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE
DONE IN THIS AREA.
FRANCE AND YOU WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT.
RICH MY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
CAN SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE TO
METHODOLOGY OF SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE HOW WE CAME TO THAT
REQUEST --
JEEZ I DID NOT ALSO POINT OUT
THAT IN THE DOCUMENT.
THAT WE RECEIVED IT DOES SHOW AS
YOU STATED THAT WAS BASED ON A
SIXTY DAY INVESTIGATIVE PERIOD
AND I HAVE TO WONDER.
WHY APPRECIATE EXPLANATION THAT
WAS GIVEN HERE?
THE ORIGINAL THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL BEFORE IT WAS AMENDED SO
BEFORE IT WAS SIGNED BEFORE IT
FINALIZED IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BEFORE WE SIGN.
DID HAVE A SIXTY DAY
INVESTIGATORY PERIOD AROUND THE
USE OF FORCE BUT THAT WAS
CHANGED TO ONE EIGHTY SO I I
HAVE TO WONDER WHETHER.
THE THIS IS SESSION WAS BASED ON
IN INACCURATE READING OF THE
FINAL BILL.
I FELT THEIR THEM FOR THE PART
OF FINANCE COMMENTS I THINK IT'S
THAT COMES DOWN TO THE TIMELINE
THAT WE CONSIDER THE ACTUAL
INVESTIGATION GENERALLY KERN
THERE'S A PERIOD OF TIME.
WHEN THE GRIEVANCE TO THE
ALLEGATION IS IS BROUGHT FORWARD --
WHERE IT'S --
BROUGHT TO I WAS REFERRED TO AS
THE TION OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
AND THEN IT GOES TO
INVESTIGATION THERE NEEDS TO BE
TIME LEFT ON THAT END OF THE
INVESTIGATION FOR BOTH --
THE HIGHER THREE TO REACH
DECISIONS AND FOR ANY NOTICE OF
ADVERSE ACTION TO BE ISSUED TO
EMPLOYEES SO.
IN REFERENCE IN THE SIXTY DAYS I
DON'T BELIEVE IT WAS A MIS READ
OF THE LEGISLATIVE CHANGE.
IT WAS TRYING TO CAPTURE THE
PERIOD OF TIME THAT EXIST BEFORE
ALL OF THE IN TAKES STEPS GET TO
AN AGENT FOR INVESTIGATION.
AND WHEN THE AGENT IS OBLIGATED
TO COMPLETE THAT INVESTIGATION
SO THAT ALL THE FINALIZATION
STEPS CAN PROPERLY OCCUR BEFORE
THE TIMELINE IS MATT SO IT'S A
COLLAPSED WINDOW.
THAT IS CORRECT THERE'S ALSO AN
ADDITIONAL TIME AFTER.
WHERE IT'S AT THE INSTITUTIONAL
LEVEL WHERE IT'S BEING REVIEWED?
MAY GO THROUGH THE INSTITUTIONAL
USE OF FORCE COMMITTEE BY
JENNIFER BEFORE EVEN COMES TO
THE INTERNAL AFFAIRS.
CONSIDER FOR INVESTIGATION.
AND SO BACK YET THAT AND HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS ENCOMPASS THE
INTEGRITY OF INCIDENT OCCURRING
WHAT HAPPENS IF HE'S.
LEVEL COMING TO INTERNAL AFFAIRS
INTAKE MOVING TO INVESTIGATION
MOVING TO DISCIPLINE AND TAKING
DISCIPLINARY ACTION.
SO WHAT CLASS.
BERMAN FINANCE GO AHEAD.
I WOULD LIKE IN THE DEPARTMENT
THAT YES WE DO CONSIDER THE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO DAY TIME
FRAME AND THAT IS ONLY APPLY TO
THE USE OF FORCE AND WEAPONS
CASES.
AND A FURTHER MORE ONLY THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE CASES WHICH CAN'T
BE DELAYED IF THEY'RE SUBJECT TO
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION THE
DEPARTMENT HAS THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO DEFER A RELEASE OF THOSE
RECORDS UNTIL THE INVESTIGATION
IS COMPLETE SO THIS.
UP REQUEST WAS JUST TARGETED ON
THE USE OF FORCE WEAPONS HE SAYS.
THAT WERE ADMINISTRATIVE THAT
NEEDED TO BE LIMITED TO UNDER
THE SPELL [inaudible]
I'M.
CENTER MORE LIKE SINCE YOU WERE
ASKING SOME YOU WERE.
LEGITIMATELY HAD SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THESE BE THESE INCREASE OF
PETITIONS PLEASE YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH US THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
AT TWELVE A ONE YOU RECEIVE HER
REQUEST.
FOR ALL FOUR CATEGORIES FOR FIVE
YEARS IN IN IN COULD YOU REPEAT.
THE A NUMBER MOST PURE REYES YOU
HAVE TO RESPOND WITHIN TEN
BUSINESS DAYS BUT FOR THIS
REQUEST WHAT IS YOUR DEADLINE.
WITHIN TEN DAYS YOU PROVIDE A
RESPONSE WHICH OFTENTIMES
INDICATES HOW MUCH TIME IT WILL
RECENTLY TAKE. TO ASSEMBLE THE
DOCUMENTS I IN SOME INSTANCES
YOU CAN EXTEND THAT TEN DAY
RESPONSE TO ANOTHER FOURTEEN DAY
RESPONSE A TWENTY FOUR WHERE
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED PERHAPS SOME
COST FACTORS OR GIVEN THE VERY
SIZE OF IT --
YOU'RE ASKING FOR SOME
CLARIFICATION AND OTHER STEPS SO
IN THIS INSTANCE THAT COMMITMENT
IS BEEN MADE.
TO COMPLY WITH THE FULL REQUEST
BY JUNE THIRTIETH SO A SIX MONTH
PERIOD YOU CAN FLUCTUATE THE
AMOUNT OF TIME TO ACTUALLY
PRODUCE DOCUMENTS.
BASED ON THE VOLUME BUT YOU MUST
RESPOND WITHIN TEN DAYS TO
INFORM THEM THAT YOU'VE RECEIVED
IT AND WHAT YOUR INTENSE ARE
GOING FORWARD.
THOUGH THE REQUEST YOUR OF THE
SIX MONTH.
TIME FRAME ARE YOU YOU'VE JUST
BE MY SAID THIS IS WHAT IT TAKES.
AND NOT NOT USUALLY THERE'S A
COMMUNICATION AND THE OTHER SIDE
THE REQUESTED --
MAY INDICATE THAT THEY THEY
DON'T WISH TO WAIT THAT LONG SO
THEY'LL TRIM DOWN THE REQUEST.
I'M OR YOU HOPEFULLY REACH SOME
COMPROMISE AND PERHAPS STAGING
THE REQUESTED SOME MATERIALS ARE
PROVIDED AT ONE POINT IN TIME.
AND THEN A DEEPER DIVE FOR
DOCUMENTS IS DONE IN AT A LATER
TIME IT'S PRODUCED THERE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT WAYS --
TO STRUCTURE THAT.
GIVEN THAT HAVE.
MAXIMUM AT REQUEST.
AT SIX MONTHS I WAS OFFERED AS
AS A COMPLETION DATE FOR THE
ENTIRE PROJECT.
ONCE YOU COMPLETE THIS PROJECT
IN SIX MONTHS YOU HAVE
[inaudible]
ADDRESSED EVERY.
EVERYONE IN YOUR IN YOUR ENTIRE
DEPARTMENT RIGHT YOU'VE YOU'VE
COVERED AT ALL.
I THINK THE POINT IN IT WAS MADE
EARLIER IS CORRECT EXCEPT FOR
SOME NEW WANTS AND THAT IS THAT.
UPON IDENTIFIED ALL THE
DOCUMENTS THERE'S A REDUCTION
PROCESS AND SO BASED ON THE
REQUEST --
YOU MAY BE REDACTING PORTIONS OF
THE RECORD THAT PERTAINED OTHER
INDIVIDUALS --
AND THEN A SUBSEQUENT REQUEST
MAY COME IN FOR THE SAME
INCIDENT BUT THEY'RE ASKING
ABOUT A DIFFERENT --
INDIVIDUAL AND SO YOUR READ DR
THE OPPOSITE NOW IN THIS CASE
WHERE THE REQUEST IS --
FOR EVERY CONCEIVABLE RELEASABLE
THE GOAL WOULD BE.
TO CONDUCT THE REDUCTIONS
ARCHIVE THOSE MATERIALS SO THAT
IF A SIMILAR REQUEST COMES IN
THE FUTURE.
THEN IT'S EASILY AVAILABLE AND
RELEASED IN A MUCH SHORTER
PERIOD TIME YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
WELL THEN.
I GUESS WHERE I'M GOING IS AFTER
SIX MONTHS OF AN ANSWER.
WORK [inaudible]
YOU'RE DONE.
SO I THINK WE WOULD HAVE TO BUY
FOR KATE THAT THE P. R. A
REQUEST OF THIS B. C. P. AND
INVESTIGATORY.
SO I THINK YOU'RE CORRECT WHEN
YOU'RE DESCRIBING THAT THE P. R.
A. PROCESSING.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THIS --
ONE LARGE PR REYES COMPLETED
WILL BE A MATTER OF REPRODUCING
THOSE OR REDACTING FUTURE
INCIDENTS.
BUT THE THE LARGE REQUEST FOR
INVESTIGATORY STAFF DON'T RELATE
TO THE FIVE PASSED YEARS BECAUSE
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS OF BY LARGE
BEEN COMPLETED.
THEY RELATED TO A GOAL OF
MODIFYING THE ENTIRE PROGRAM
GOING FORWARD.
SO THAT ALL INVESTIGATIONS OF
INCIDENTS THAT WOULD FALL UNDER.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WOULD BE
COMPLETED IN THAT SIX MONTH
WINDOW SO THEY WERE REALLY TO
REQUEST IMBEDDED ONE WAS --
THE SMALLER IF YOU WILL WHICH
WAS TO PROCESS THE R. A.'S THE
PAPERWORK AND THAT DOES HAVE THE
BUBBLE AFFECT THAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING.
BUT THE LARGER REQUEST FOR FOR
AGENTS AND FOR SOME ATTORNEYS
WHO ARE PART OF THAT INVEST
TOWARD PROCESS UNDER THE MADRID
CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT.
WHICH I MEAN IF YOU WANT THAT
WAS ABOUT CREATE A MODEL
DESTINATIONS THAT USED TO BE
COMPLETED WITHIN A YEAR WOULD BE
COMPLETE IN SIX MONTHS
ANTICIPATING FUTURE FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE REQUESTS.
SO THAT'S WHY I DESCRIBED DAM
THE THE THE INITIAL IMPRESSION
ABOUT A BUBBLE.
PERTAINS TO THE REQUESTED HAVE
COME IN AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
YEAR. FOR INFORMATION GOING BACK
IN TIME --
UP TO THIS FIVE YEARS.
BUT DID THE LARGE DRIVER OF THE
B. C. P. )
ADDITIONAL INVESTIGATIVE STAFF
SO THAT.
FROM THIS POINT FORWARD.
OUR INVESTIGATIONS OF THAT
NATURE WOULD BE COMPLETED IN SIX
MONTHS THAT'S MEDIAN THE SAME
TIME FRAME AS THE FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE IT WOULD BE THE
INVESTIGATION AND THE
DISCIPLINARY.
PROCESS SO THAT IT WILL HAVE A
COMPLETE RECORD.
OF WHAT OCCURRED.
SO IN THE MEANTIME.
IT'S ALL HANDS ON DECK A. B.
RIGHT NOW YEAH.
THAT'S CORRECT CENTER AND ARE
YOU RETAINING ANY --
TEMPORARY.
SERVICES THAT BACKYARD BURGER
FOR THE CURRENT RATHER
DEPARTMENTS OR A GESTURE OPTING
FOR THAT FOR THE CURRENT --
WAVE IF YOU WILL --
THERE'VE BEEN A LOT OF RE
DIRECTED STAFF.
AND SO -- WE
ARE COVERING THE WORKLOAD
OBVIOUSLY AT SOME POINT I
WHATEVER THE C. P. ARGUMENTATION
IS IS AGREED.
TO I WOULD PERSONALLY COME
ONLINE JULY FIRST AND THEN THAT
WORK WOULD BE HANDED OVER TO THE
PERMANENT THAT TEAM.
I WHATEVER SIZE --
THAT CONSISTS OF BUT AT THE
CURRENT TIME MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
REDIRECTED IN PARTICULAR FOR THE
THE LARGE GLOBAL.
I REQUEST THAT WAS RECEIVED I
SHOULD SAY THERE ARE YOU KNOW
OTHER REQUESTS IN THE TWENTY
THREE SOME OF THEM ARE SINGULAR
SOME OF THEM ARE --
A REQUEST FROM A PUBLIC DEFENDER
ABOUT A PARTICULAR OFFICER IN
PARTICULAR INCIDENT.
I SOME ARE PERHAPS --
ENTIRE INCIDENT FROM A MEDIA
OUTLETS --
BUT IN AS MUCH AS A FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE IS OPEN TO THE ENTIRE
PUBLIC BE THEY MEDIA.
INMATES OBVIOUSLY ARE FREE TO
USE THAT PUBLIC DEFENDERS
PROSECUTORS YOU KNOW EXPECT OVER
TIME TO SEE --
FOLKS GET FAMILIAR WITH THE BILL
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ITS
TRANSPARENCY BUT IT THIS TIME.
WE ARE SITTING ON THE TWENTY
THREE WITH THE ONE LARGE REQUEST
AND PROCESSING THAT AS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS WE CAN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AFTER.
CERTAINLY CENTER WERE LIKE IN I
AM.
THINK WHAT A IN ALSO IMPORTANT
TO NOTE AS IN.
YOU -- IN
YOUR QUESTION.
WE WILL WAS REPORTED TO US THAT
YOU ARE REDIRECTING STAFF.
AND THAT THIS EVEN IF WE WERE TO
APPROVE THESE THE WOMEN TAKE
AFFECT UNTIL JULY ONE AND THEN
OF COURSE YOU'D HAVE TO HIRE SO
MAYBE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
OCTOBER NOVEMBER.
SO A GIVEN THAT THE THE AS YOU
RIGHTFULLY POINTED OUT IN AND
YOUR QUESTION AROUND IF YOU HAVE
A DATA DUMP.
OR A REQUEST LIKE YOU HAVE
RECEIVED WHICH IS GIVE US
EVERYTHING.
EVEN IN SUBSEQUENT REQUESTS THAT
MIGHT BE ABOUT INCIDENT.
X. OR Y. ONLY YOU WOULD OF
ALREADY PROCESSED AT LEAST SOME
OF LARGE PORTION OF THAT.
SO THAT'S THE TIME.
FOR RESPONDING THAT REQUEST IS
GREATLY CONDENSED.
SO GOING FORWARD WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE.
MUCH LESS OF A AGAINST ON
ONGOING WORK BUT NARROWER NATURE.
SO JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE HAD.
THAT POINTED OUT THANK YOU.
YES YOU MAY RESPOND GO AHEAD YES
WITH REGARDS --
TO PULLING THOSE RECORDS FROM
CASCADE [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible] SEVEN YEAH.
WAS THE MOVIE FOR WITH
RESPECTIVE CASES THAT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
OKAY.
SO IN THE TERMS OF YOUR RESPONSE
AROUND TO DESIRE.
TO HANDLE YOUR INVESTIGATIONS
DIFFERENTLY I THINK YOU SHOULD
HAVE SEPARATED THE PCP BECAUSE
THERE'S NOTHING IN.
OUR WHAT FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
THAT REQUIRES YOU TO OTHER THAN
THE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS.
SO IF THERE'S A DESIRE TO HANDLE
INVESTIGATIONS DIFFERENTLY I
THINK IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED SEPARATELY.
SO THAT WE COULD DISCUSS THAT IN
DETAIL AND WHY WE MIGHT AND WHAT
OTHER CASES MEANING THE MADRID
IN OTHER CASES.
MIGHT --
JUSTIFIER BEARD. THREE READ
RATIONALE FOR THAT UNDERSTOOD IN
A FAIR POINT.
UNDER BILL DID YOU HAVE ANY
[inaudible]
SOME.
BUDGET PROPOSAL INCLUDE --
OUR STATE [inaudible]
PRIVATE FACILITIES.
IN AS MUCH AS WE MAINTAIN THE
RECORDS AND WE DO HAVE MANY
RECORDS ABOUT INCIDENTS THAT
OCCURRED.
AT THE ODYSSEY FACILITIES THEN
THE P. R. A. WOULD APPLY THAT
INCLUDE --
RECORDS OF THE PRIVATE OPERATIVE.
NONE OF THOSE RECORDS ARE KEPT
SEPARATE THEIR REQUEST WOULD
HAVE TO MADE OF THEM.
BUT AT ANY RECORDS THAT ARE
WITHIN THE CONTROL OR THE
CUSTODY OF THE APARTMENT.
ADD WOULD FALL UNDER THE P. R. A
LOT WHEN WE PASS LAWS DO YOU
MODIFY THEIR CONTRACTS TO
INCLUDE.
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR LAWS THAT
WE PASS --
BUT WE CERTAINLY APPLY ALL OF
OUR AT OUR RULES AND OUR
POLICIES THROUGH OUR CONTRACTS
TO THE IS.
A PRIVATE INSTITUTION SO YOU'RE
GOING TO CHANGE --
CONTRACTS TO IMPLEMENT.
SOME OF THESE LAWCENTER AT THE
CURRENT CONTRACTS --
THAT ARE EXPIRING.
WE WON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TO MODIFY THEM A LONGER THEY'RE
GOING TO BE IN THOSE FACILITIES.
AT THE GOAL AS THE SECRETARY
MENTIONED WAS.
NO FURTHER INMATES IN THE
ARIZONA FACILITIES AFTER JUNE
THIRTIETH.
THIS YEAR CORRECT THIS YEAR --
IF SOMEBODY CALLS UP AND ONCE
RECORDS.
NOW FROM SOMETHING IS HAPPENING
DOWN THERE.
FEEL AS RIVAL OPERATOR THEY
CAN'T GET THE RECORDS UNLESS.
IF THOSE RECORDS IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S CUSSING CONTROL
THEY CAN GET THOSE RECORDS IF
THOSE ARE SEPARATE --
RECORDS THAT ARE THE PURVIEW OF
THE CONTRACTOR I THAN THEY WOULD
HAVE TO MAKE THE RECALL THANK
YOU OKAY I THINK I THINK WE WE
YOU WANT TO EXPLORE.
MAKING SURE THAT IF THERE'S ANY.
I DON'T WANT TO HAVE A TWO
TIERED.
I THANK OF SOMEBODY ELSE FOR SO
IS SOMETHING HAPPENS IN ARIZONA.
AND THEY ASKED FOR THE RECORD.
THEY CAN'T GET IN BECAUSE OF
SOME REASON THE PRIVATE OFFICER
DOESN'T WANT TO DISCLOSE THEM
AND I WOULD BE --
THAT WOULD BE NOT IMPLEMENTING
THESE BILLS OKAY THAT THE LAWS
OF THE HOUSE THAT'S OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER ROLE
IN -- I USED.
OUR USE THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS
AND THINGS LIKE AB. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY SEVEN AND AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY FIVE AND OTHERS.
IN MY COMPARISON BUT REALLY WE
COULD HAVE LOOKED AT MORE
CLOSELY AT SB.
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN WHICH
COMPLIES WITH ASKS THE
DEPARTMENT A COMPLY WITH NEW
PRESCRIPTION AUTHORIZATION
REQUIREMENTS.
AND IT AFFECTS THIRTY FIVE
LOCATIONS THIRTY FIVE DIFFERENT
PHARMACIES.
AND IT REQUIRES.
MORE --
DEALING WITH AFTER OUR
PRESCRIPTIONS AND YET IT ONLY
ASKS US FOR TWO PEOPLE SO IT'S A
ONGOING THING FOR THIRTY FIVE
LOCATIONS.
POTENTIALLY TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SO
I JUST IS ANOTHER COMPARES
[inaudible]
IN SCALE.
WE APPRECIATE THE CHEST BY A
THANK YOU I'M.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS SIDE.
OKAY SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ISSUE THREE ALLOCATION
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
THANK YOU.
FOR THE OUR NEXT ITEM IS A
REQUEST FOR A ONE TIME INCREASE
OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
SPECIAL CARE TO FOR MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS AROUND THE STATE AT OUR
FACILITIES.
OUR SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT FOR
THIS ISSUE END OF THE NEXT TWO
ISSUES IS DEAN BORG.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FACILITY
PLANNING CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT.
RIGHT GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS --
AS MENTIONED --
THIS -- BCP
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDING
IS TWENTY FIVE MILLION AS A ONE
TIME B. C. P. --
SIMILAR TO WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
LAST SEVERAL BUDGET CYCLES --
IN A SECTION SIX POINT --
ONE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OF
PROGRAM.
LET ME EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW WE PRIORITIZE OUR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
PROJECTS --
OUR INSTITUTIONS WILL SUBMIT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS --
TO HEADQUARTERS ON A FLOW BASIS
WE DO DO WHAT'S CALLED A CALL
LETTER ONCE A YEAR TO SAY PLEASE
ENSURE YOU SUBMITTED EVERYTHING
BUT IF --
NEEDS ARE IDENTIFIED BETWEEN
THAT CALL LATER ON THE NEXT CALL
LETTER --
THEY WILL SUBMIT THOSE --
PROJECT REQUESTS ON A FLOW BASIS.
ANNUALLY AT THE START OF EACH
FISCAL YEAR WE WILL GO THROUGH
ALL THE REQUEST THAT WE RECEIVED
AND DO A PRIORITIZATION BASED ON
A VARIETY OF FACTORS --
IS THE PROJECT REQUEST NECESSARY
TO MAINTAIN EXISTING OPERATIONS
AND HOUSING INMATE PROGRAMMING
HEALTHCARE --
IS IT NECESSARY TO COMPLY WITH
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS --
ARE THEY REQUIRE IS A PROJECT
THE CONDITIONS FOR A INMATES OR
STAFF.
OR IS IT NECESSARY TO ADDRESS --
COURT MANDATES.
SO WITH THAT PRIORITIZATION WILL
END UP WITH EACH YAR ABOUT
THIRTY PROJECTS THAT WE ARE
PRIORITIZING TO START MOVING
FORWARD ON AND OFF IN CASES THAT
MEANS STARTING A DESIGN PROCESS
FOR THESE PROJECTS --
THAT DESIGN PROCESS DEPENDING ON
THE SCOPE OF THE PROJECT COULD
TAKE ANYWHERE FROM TWELVE TO
EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
SO OUR PRIORITIZATION PROCESS
ESSENTIALLY AND IN ONE FISCAL
YEAR WILL IDENTIFY PROJECTS TO
START THE DESIGN WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR OR THE FISCAL YEAR
FOLLOWING THAT.
ONE THAT PROJECT WILL BE FULLY
DESIGNED AND READY TO MOVE INTO
CONSTRUCTION SO IT'S A MULTI
YEAR PROCESS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS VERY
SIMILAR TO OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS.
SO -- IT THE
AND NOW SAYS DID IDENTIFY THAT --
WE HAD NOT PREVIOUSLY REACHED
PROVIDED A LIST OF WHAT THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION PROJECTS ARE --
WE HAVE NOW --
EARLIER THIS WEEK --
PROVIDED THAT TO THE COMMITTEE
AND TO THE LA --
SO WE CAN ANSWER ANY ONGOING
QUESTIONS --
YOU KNOW BE ON OF THE ON THIS
HEARING X. AND IF ANYBODY DID
WANT TO COPY I HAVE ADDITIONAL
THAT THE SERGEANT COULD PASS OUT
SO -- PLEASE
LET ME KNOW.
THE PROJECTS ARE ON HERE VERY
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROJECTS THE
DEPARTMENT HAS UTILIZED THE
PREVIOUS YEAR'S FUNDINGS FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
ON SO IT'S A FAIRLY CONSISTENT
WITH THE PRIOR --
THE PRAYER REQUESTS --
AM VEILED AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND AND AS I SAID IF
ANYONE WANTS TO SEE A COPY OF IT --
AGAIN OF THE SORT
.
WE HAD REYES AGAINST THE
DEPARTMENT HAD PROVIDED A
PROVIDED A LIST OF SPECIFIC
PROJECTS OR INSPIRATION
EXPLANATION OF HOW IT HAD
PRIORITIZE THIS PROJECT FROM ITS
BACKLOG.
THE BERMAN HAS SENSE --
PROVIDED BOTH OF THOSE THINGS SO --
WE WILL CERTAINLY BE REVIEWING
THE LIST AND COMMUNICATE ANY
CONCERNS WE IDENTIFY --
WE JUST RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAKE SURE THAT THAT
PRIORITIZATION METHOD IN THE
LIST OF SPECIFIC PROJECTS MATCH.
FOR SOME REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE THINK WOULD ENABLE
BETTER LGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OVER.
ONGOING MAINTENANCE ISSUES.
I'M AND THE FIRST WOULD BE --
SOME SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE REQUIRING CDC ARE TO
IDENTIFIED BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE HOW THEIR
BACK A DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACK
BETWEEN TWENTY NINETEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND TO THE
EXTENT IT GROWS OVER THAT TIME
PERIOD.
TO IDENTIFY REASONS FOR THE
GROWTH AND OF WHAT WHAT STEPS IS
TAKING.
TO MITIGATE THAT GROWTH.
I'M AND THEN WE ALSO RECOMMENDS.
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO REPORT ON WHAT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
ARE ULTIMATELY FUNDED WITH
WHATEVER RESOURCES ARE PROVIDED
IN THAT TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ERIN EDWARDS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
I THINK I WOULD JUST LIKE TO TO
NOTE THAT WE THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT --
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT --
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE SAFE
SECURE FACILITIES --
THAT ARE CONDUCIVE TO PROVIDING
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING AND
TO PROVIDING ADEQUATE HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND IN THESE SORTS OF
INVESTMENTS ARE THAT THE TYPE OF
INVESTMENTS WE NEED TO MAKE.
IT TO ENSURE THAT OUR PRISONS DO
WE ALL AGREE ON IN TERMS OF VIA.
THE ALLEY --
RECOMMENDATIONS ON PROVIDING
REPORTING LANGUAGE ALL AT THE
DEPARTMENT IS TO SPEAK TO THAT
BUT I I THINK IN GENERAL --
WE TRY TO BE AS FORTHCOMING AS
WE CAN BE WITH INFORMATION ABOUT --
WHAT PROJECTS WERE FUNDING AND I
I DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
GENERALLY PROVIDING THAT SORT OF
INFORMATION TO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE?
THEN YOUR BELT --
HOW WE APPROACH THE MADE US I I
I THINK IT HAS AS TO BE --
PART OF OUR BUDGET AND I'M GLAD
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT --
I THINK THEY'RE A GOOD WAY OF
DOING MAINTENANCE PROJECTS ON A
ONE TO HEAR YOUR OPINION.
IS TO TO LOOK AT SERVE THE
ONGOING MAINTENANCE COSTS.
AND THEN LOOK AT ANOTHER
CATEGORY WOULD BE --
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
THINGS THAT WERE DONE THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE A WHILE
AGO.
BUT YOU HAVE A LIST OF THOSE
THAT.
IF YOU TAKE CARE OF OF THEN --
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE CARE MANY
MORNING HAVE ONGOING MAINTENANCE
A REGULAR MAINTENANCE.
UP I SEE THESE LIST AS KIND OF A
MORE WITH THE FOR MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG WITH.
PRIVATE THAT WAY.
YES THE LIST HAS TO DO WITH THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
THAT THE INSTITUTION IF MORE
ADEQUATELY FUNDED IN THIS LEADS
INTO THE NEXT ITEM --
ON ON THE AGENDA --
IF IF WE HAD ADEQUATE FUNDING AT
THE LEVEL THESE ARE PROJECTS AND
IN SOME CASES THE INSTITUTION
COULD HAVE BEEN DOING --
THROUGH MULTI YEAR PLANNING --
KNOWING WHAT THEIR BUDGET IS-GOING TO BE BUT BECAUSE OF WHERE
THE BUDGET HAS BEEN OVER THE
LAST FIVE TO TEN YEARS.
IT GETS REALLY FOR SO SO.
SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING TO ME YOUR
IS.
IF YOU HAD THE TOP TO YOUR
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG.
PROJECTS.
THESE ARE THE THESE THIS IS
STILL THE TOP TIER BUT WAS THERE
AN ARTIFICIAL.
LIMIT YOU SAID TWENTY FIVE
MILLION THIRTY MILLION WHAT WAS
THE REASON.
FOR THE DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT YOU --
SELECTED OR WAS SELECTED TERMS
OF THIS BUDGET REQUEST AND AND
WHAT IS THE OVERALL SIZE OF THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG.
AS REPORTED BY OUR INSTITUTIONS
THE SIZE OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG IS IS
APPROXIMATELY BILLION DOLLARS AT
THIS TIME OKAY SO THIS IS A CHIP
AWAY KIND OF A BUDGET REQUEST.
AND AND AND AND I MEAN IT IT'S
SO IT'S A IS IT A COUPLE OF THEM
FACTORS ONE HAS TO DO WITH WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE THE THE BAND WITH THE
ABILITY TO MOVE THESE FOR
PROJECTS FORWARD SO SOMETHING
THAT WAS.
NOT TWENTY FIVE MILLION BUT
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION EIGHTY
MILLION --
MAY NOT ALL MOVE FORWARD --
IN AN EXPEDITIOUS MANNER MANNER
AS WE CAN WITH TWENTY FIVE
MILLION AND THESE ARE PROJECTS
THAT WE PRIORITIZE.
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO MOVING
THROUGH THE DESIGN --
AT AT AT THIS.
RATE OF YOU --
YOU SEE THE MADE A BACKLOG.
GROWING.
GIVEN THE FACT THEY'RE ALWAYS
SPENDING TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS YOUR OUR ON DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG HERE.
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG
WILL CONTINUE TO GROW UNTIL WE
CAN ADDRESS THE ABILITY FOR THE
INSTITUTIONS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS A LOT OF
THESE PROJECTS --
WITH -- WITH
THEIR OWN FUNDING WHICH AGAIN
TIES INTO THE NET RESULT
ROUSEY'S QUESTION IS.
A LOOK AT THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AS A NUMBER
[inaudible]
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GROW YOU WANNA
SHRINK THE NUMBER.
BUT IF YOU DON'T SPEND ENOUGH
MONEY ON SHIPPING AWAY OUT AT
THE MAIN AS BACKLOG WILL GROW.
AND WE HAVE TO FIND THAT SWEET
SPOT WE'RE IT ACTUALLY STARTS TO
SHRINK.
THE MAINTENANCE BACKLOG.
OF WHERE WOULD YOU SAY THAT
NUMBER WOULD BE.
IT'S I'D I'D I DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC DOLLAR NUMBER BUT I
THINK IT IS A COMBINATION OF
LIFE OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
ALL THAT.
STUFF TO YOU BY.
IT'S IT'S A COMBINATION OF THESE
ONE TIME DEFERRED MAINTENANCE UP
OPERATIONS ADMIN COMING
PREVIOUSLY IN SECTION SIX POINT --
ONE AND NOW IN THIS PCP BUT ALSO
THE ABILITY FOR OUR PLANT STAFF
TO HAVE A AN ANNUAL MAINTENANCE
BUDGET TAT ALLOWS THEM TO IF
THEY'VE GOT TWENTY FIVE THEY'RE
HANDLING UNITS THAT THEY KNOW
ARE TWENTY YEARS OLD.
AND THEY'RE ALL GOING TO FAIL
SOMETIME IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO
REPLACE THEM.
IT BECOMES A DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECT AND WE HOPE
WE GET TO THEM BEFORE THEY
COMPLETELY FAIL.
IF WE'RE ABLE TO FUND THEM ON
AND AND AND SAY IN THE NEXT FOUR
FIVE YEARS I WILL REPLACE ALL OF
THOSE ARE HANDING UNITS WITHIN
MY OWN BUDGET AND THEN IT DOES
NOT BECOME A DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECT IT BECOMES
SOMETHING THEY HANDLE YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M SAYING.
YEAH I THINK I THINK --
FOR ME.
I WOULD LIKE TO LOOK AT IT IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY.
SO WE ANALYZE HOW HOW MUCH MONEY
WE NEED TO SPEND ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS.
OF RATHER THAN ARBITRARILY SET A
NUMBER.
I DON'T KNOW IF OTHER PEOPLE
AGREE WITH THIS BUT I'M I'M A
BIG.
MAINTENANCE IS A PLANNING
EXERCISE.
A BUDGET PLANNING AS A MULTI
YEAR BUDGET PLANNING OUR FIRST
YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT.
WHERE THE RIGHT SPOT IS? TO
START.
TO BECAUSE SAY WHAT WE'RE GONNA
LIMóN THEY JUST TO FOR THIS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AND
FIFTEEN YEARS OR TEN YEARS OR
AND THEN YOU FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT LINE'S GOING TO BE AND THEN.
FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH MONEY YOU'RE
YOU HAVE TO SPEND YOU KNOW.
OTHERWISE IT'LL JUST KEEP
GROWING [inaudible]
AND OR KELSO WILL BE AT OUR
MEETINGS FOR THE REST OF OUR
LIVES RIGHT AND HILL.
HE'LL BE HERE FOREVER
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO BE SO IN A
WELL AT LEAST THROUGH THE RULES
ORLEAKING.
YEAH LIKE THAT LET YOU KNOW YOUR
I'M SAYING SO I I I THINK --
MY GOAL IS TO UPGRADE ALL THE
FACILITIES.
BUT I NEED TO SEE WHAT THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROPER
LIBERAL FUNDING AS I I HAD AT A
OF THAT COULD BE DONE.
IN WORKING WITH THESE COMMITTEES
I THINK.
WE WOULD TRY TO ACHIEVE THAT.
I DON'T KNOW AND WILL RIGHT.
THAT'S WHERE WORST THAT'S WHAT I
FEEL.
RESPONSIBLE THAT I HAVE TO DO.
I AM IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT YOUR
MAIN ISSUES I HAVE FOR YOUR OUT.
WHAT THE PLAN IS TO ELIMINATE
THE BACKLOG IN?
THIS ONCE YOU ELIMINATE IT ISN'T
TRUE THE OPERATING COSTS IN THE
ROMANUS POSSIBLY MUCH LESS.
IT WOULD BE LESS YOU AVOID
EMERGENCY THE TAX EMERGES MONEY
RICHES BECAUSE OF THINGS --
FAIL -- I I
APPRECIATE AND WILL GO BACK FROM
THIS WORKING WITH FINANCE LA
WHEN THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND TRY
TO COME UP WITH --
SOME INFORMATION REGARDING A
SWEET SPOT --
AS WE PUT IT REGARDING TO
ONGOING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING THE THE OTHER THE OTHER --
IDEA THAT SOME PEOPLE USE WITH
MAINTENANCE FIVE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS --
A FINANCING IDEAS.
HAVE YOU.
LOOKED AT FINANCING.
N. XCELERATED AND IN USING THE
FINANCING TO ACCELERATE.
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
PROJECTS SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU'RE
DOING WITH THE CAPITAL BUDGET
YOU'RE USING REVENUE BONDS. TO
EXCEL THE PIXEL RATE SOME OF THE
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT BONDS.
PROJECTS --
I WONDER IF --
THE REVENUE BONDS COULD ALSO BE
USED TO ACCELERATE SOME OF THE
MAINTENANCE --
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
THAT YOU HAVE THERE.
ARE YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON
THAT [inaudible]
FINANCING OF I'M SORRY NO NO I I
NO IMMEDIATE THOUGHTS --
I DON'T KNOW AT SOME POINT WHERE
I HAVE A FEW MORE CONVERSATION
ABOUT CAPITAL OUTLAY IN US MY
CAPITAL OUTLAY COLLEAGUES HERE
THAT WORK MORE ON THE LEASE
REVENUE SIDE OF THINGS MIGHT
HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT BUT
NO IMMEDIATE THOUGHTS ON THAT
PARTICULAR.
THE YOU KNOW BARTON THIS IT WHAT
YEAH GO AHEAD BUDGET JUST IS
THAT HAVE --
COMMON AND SPOKEN TO US ABOUT A
MODEL SUCH AS THAT AND I THINK
THAT --
THOSE ARE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE I IT
COMES DOWN TO WHAT THE FUNDING
STREAM TO REPAY THOSE BONDS
WOULD WOULD BE AND BEING ABLE.
TO ACTUALIZE A SAVINGS PER SE
FROM GETTING THE MAINTENANCE
DONE QUICKER THROUGH FINANCING --
WE WE WE HAVE NOT FOUND THE THE
ANSWERS TO THAT YET --
BUT IT'S A I THINK T'S
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE ONGOING.
THE THE BASIC GOAL OF FINANCING
IS TO PROVE THINGS EARLY.
SO CLARK CAM LEVER MEETINGS AND
THEN -- HAVE
THE FACILITIES UPGRADED --
THE PROPER LEVEL AND THEN --
BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THE THE
NEEDS OF OUR CALIFORNIA IN TERMS
OF INCARCERATION.
BUT MEET THE QUALITY STANDARDS
THAT WE WANT TO HAVE --
IN AND FALL THE LEGAL RULES. TO
DO THAT AND I THINK --
DEFERRED MADE IT SHOULD BE
LOOKED AT AS POSSIBILITY --
TO USE THE REVENUE BROUGHT
APPROACH --
DOES AND YOU ALSO WOULD SAVE
MONEY ON IF YOU LOOK AT IT FROM
A TENURE PERSPECTIVE OR WHATEVER
YOU MIGHT.
FIND IT YOU WOULD SAVE OPERATING
COST.
AT THE SAME TIME BY NOT HAVING --
CONSTANT REPAIRING AND BROUGHT
YOU KNOW CRISIS --
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS THAT YOU
HAVE TO DO.
ALL THAT ARE THE LAST QUESTION
HAMMER I'M SURE WAS.
DO YOU ANTICIPATE USING THESE
PROGRAMS.
TO TRAIN THE WORK FORCE --
PRE APPRENTICESHIP --
TYPE PROGRAM SO WE HAVE. FOR OUR
INMATES IN --
FACILITIES IS THIS.
HEART OF THESE PROJECTS IS IT
INCLUDED IN THE PLANNING OF THE
PROJECT.
YES ABSOLUTELY CENTER --
THE VAST MAJORITY THESE PER IN
THIS PROJECT OVERALL ARE
DELIVERED THROUGH OUR INMATE
WERE LABOR PROGRAM AND THE CLOSE
COORDINATION THAT THEY HAVE WITH
THE THE TRADE UNIONS AS FAR AS
PRO BRITISH PROGRAMS ARE
CONCERNED --
SO THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO LEARN
SKILLS FREE PRINTER SHIP SKILLS
AND ACTUALLY.
HAVE ON THE JOB TRAINING.
FOR THE TIME THAT THEY WOULD
LEAVE THEY WOULD HAVE A
CONSTRUCTION JOB TRAINING.
THAT'S THE GOAL OF OUR PROGRAMS
IT'S EASIER ACCOMPLISHED ON SOME
PRO ON SOME PROJECTS AND OTHER
PROJECTS BUT IT'S AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION THAT ARE IN MAY OR
LABOR PROGRAM IS IS HAVING --
TO RAISES MANY OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AS POSSIBLE.
OKAY I'M I'M THAT'S THAT'S I I
KIND OF FOLLOWED WITH MY POINTS
THAT I MAKING ABOUT.
PLANNING MAINTENANCE --
A I WAS THINKING ABOUT LAST
NIGHT IT'S NOT THAT MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN --
ROAD REPAIR MAINTENANCE WHO'S
BEEN WORKING ON FOR FIVE YEARS.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE YOU EITHER
EITHER SPEND MORE LATER OR YOU
SPEND LESS MORE EARLIER AND THEN
YOU SAVE MONEY LATER.
SO I THINK I THINK THERE'S
THINGS WE CAN DO WITH THIS --
TO HAVE AN EFFECTIVE PROGRAM AND
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTS ON OVER
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS [inaudible]
YES.
A CENTER WELL --
JUST INTEREST TO COUPLE A
GENERAL COMMENT ON A FEW
SPECIFIC POINTS IN IN RESPONSE
TO YOUR TO YOUR COMMENTS I THINK
FIRST OF ALL WE CERTAINLY SHARE
YOUR INTEREST IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE INVESTING ON THE
FRONT AND THEN IT DOES
ABSOLUTELY.
REDUCE OUR COSTS IN THE LONG RUN
IF WE ACTUALLY MAINTAIN OUR
FACILITIES BEFORE THAT THE POINT
WHERE THINGS START BREAKING --
IN SO --
THAT'S ONE POINT I THINK I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
IN THAT THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN ADDITION TO THIS --
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A ONE TIME BASIS DEPARTMENT HAS
A BASE BUDGET FOR DEFERRED
MASONS THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
AND WE CONTINUE --
TO THE BILL THAT INTO THEIR BASE
SO THIS SPECIFICALLY FOR REGULAR
MAINTENANCE OB AND THAT IS SORT
OF DOING THE ARE GOING TO GET
INTO IN A MOMENT YES WHICH WILL
GET INTO AND SECOND.
TO JUST WANTED TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT I THINK THAT IS THE
IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION --
AND AND THEN ONE OTHER POINT IS
THAT IN ADDITION TO THOSE POTS
OF MONEY WE'VE INVESTED ATTENDS
ACTUALLY OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
FISCAL YEARS IN A RELEASE AND
THEN REPLACING RESEARCH
FACILITIES.
YEAH AND I THINK I THINK I AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU'RE DOING BUT I
THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT IT.
THIS.
AGAIN ALL THE STRESSES WE HAVE
TO HAVE A STRATEGIC MULTI YEAR
APPROACH.
WE CAN'T JUST HAVE EVERY YEAR
THROWING MORE MONEY AT THINGS WE
HAVE TO KNOW.
WHAT THE SPOT IS THAT WE NEED TO
FIND THE TARGET SO WE CAN?
REDUCE THE BACKLOG.
SO THAT'S ACTUALLY A PERFECT
SEGUE INTO THE M..
I WILL CALL ON YOU CENTER MORE
LIKE BUT I JUST WANT TO RAISE
THAT.
MY PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE HAD YOU
PRESENT ON BOTH ITEMS BECAUSE
THE CAPITAL OUTLAYS.
GOT AS A AN ITEM WHICH IS THE A
METHODOLOGY FOR THIS PRISON
FUNDING SO WHAT I'M GONNA CALL
IN CENTER MORE LIKE FIRST.
BUT I ALSO LIKE AYE BERMAN
FINANCE SO THROUGH THE CHAIR
NEXT TIME WHEN YOU WANT TO
RESPOND --
TO SO CENTER MORE LIKE.
I'M SURE I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON
YOUR BILL'S COMMENTS --
YOU LEARN AS A YOUNG PERSON.
THAT WHAT YOU OWN.
OWNS YOU.
YOU KNOW I TOLD THE STORY OF
BUYING THE SWING SET FOR THE
KIDS AND THEN YOUR READ THE
INSTRUCTIONS AND IT SAYS EVERY
SIX MONTHS YOU HAVE TO OIL THIS
GREW THIS BALL.
AND YOU JUST YOU KNOW JUST
WHATEVER YOU.
BY A POOL YOU HAD A BAKER THE
POOL IS JUST IN YOU LEARN THESE
THINGS.
AND THEN THE OLDER YOU BY A YOU
BUY A HOME IN A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND YOU START PAYING
MONTHLY DUES.
AND YOU REALIZE THAT A GOOD
CHUNK OF THAT MONEY IS GOING
INTO RESERVES TO REPLACE
SOMETHING IN THE FUTURE OF THAT
IT'S OF ON A CASH BASIS YOU HAVE
ACCUMULATED THE FUNDS TO RE ROOF
TO REPAINT. TO RESURFACE THE
ROTORS --
BUT WE DON'T DO THAT IN
GOVERNMENT.
WE FORCED BEFORE CITIZENS TO DO
THAT.
IT BY A HOMEOWNERS --
INTO A HOMER SO SHE BUT WE DON'T
DO THAT.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING.
AS IT AS CENTER VALUES THE TERM
MULTI EUROPE ROACH WHEN DO WE
GET TO A POINT WHERE YOU SAY
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO BUILD A
FACILITY IT'S GOING TO COST US.
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AS A
FOR YOUR LIFE THEN OVER THE
FORTY YEARS WHERE DO WE THEN
ACCUMULATE THE HUNDRED MILLION
TO REPLACE IT OR OR RESTORE.
AND SO WITH THAT I I'M SEEING.
A FAILURE IN BUDGETING.
IF WE HAVE TO ISSUE BONDS WE
FAILED IF WE'VE GOT TO RAISE A
TAX WE FAILED.
IT WOULD FILL THE TAXPAYERS BY
NOT PREPARING AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN COME TO THEM AND SHAME
THEM AND SAYING OUR PRISONS ARE
BAD BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN CHIP
IN AND THEY'RE GOING WAIT A
SECOND.
AS MAKES SENSE WE'VE BEEN OPEN
IN.
OUR ENTIRE LIVES HOW DID YOU
COME DOES --
WITH A A BOND REQUEST OR A TAX
REQUEST SO I'M A LITTLE.
DIFFERENT IN MY FINANCIAL
APPROACH TO HANDLING THESE
THINGS BUT I KIND OF LIKE TO SEE
WHEN WE WORRY ABOUT TE BACKLOG
WOULD START.
BEING PROVED WHATEVER WE BUILD
NEW IF YOU BUILD A NEW PRISON I
KNOW YOU'RE NOT BUT WHEN YOU DO
IN THAT WHICH ARE PUTTING
RESERVES ASIDE.
AMEDEO IT'S OUR BUILDING A
DISCIPLINE SO THAT WE DON'T SIT
HERE LOOKING AT A BILLION DOLLAR.
BACKLOG.
YEAH AND IF SOME OF YOUR ANSWER
IS A GERMANE TO YOUR
PRESENTATION ON THE MAINTENANCE
FUNDING METHODOLOGY.
YOU COULD IN [inaudible]
YOU MIGHT.
ANSWER WHATEVER ISN'T.
AND THEN IN YOUR OPENING ADDRESS.
WHAT SENATOR MORE LIKE WAS
ASKING OKAY?
I THINK THAT ARE FUNDING FOR
MAINTENANCE IS A IS A
COMBINATION OF DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES IN A COMBINATIONAL
LEVERS AT ALL HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER --
AND AND I THINK THE CHURCH POINT
IS VERY WELL TAKEN A LOT OF THE
ISSUE OF PUTTING MONEY ASIDE IN
ORDER TO KEEP FIXING THINGS.
KNOWING THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO
BE FIXED IS --
WHAT ARE?
MAINTENANCE --
METHODOLOGY --
PCP IS IS ADDRESSING.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO AVOID.
WHAT I SEE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
OVER SOMEONE WAKES UP THE DAY
AFTER THANKSGIVING IS HIS --
CHRISTMASES IN A MONTH.
WHERE DO I GET MONEY?
AS I JUST I JUST DON'T WANT TO
BE THERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MANAGER
[inaudible]
I'M.
LET'S MOVE TO ISSUE FOR PRISON
MAINTENANCE FUNDING METHODOLOGY
AND AGAIN THERE MAY BE SOME
PORTIONS OF THE METHODOLOGY THAT
ARE GERMANE. TO THE QUESTION
SENATOR MORE LACK HAS ASKED SO.
THEY ARE PLEASE PERCENT.
ABSOLUTELY MANAGER. FOR
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY YEARS --
MAINTENANCE --
FUNDING WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN INCLUDED IN THE ANNUAL
BUDGET ACT BASED ON A PER INMATE
FORMULA --
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
DOLLARS PER INMATE --
IN ITS VENN FUND ENOUGH IN THE
THE METHODOLOGY USED TO FIND
FOOD AND CLOTHING.
OR FOR INMATES --
WELL THE COST OF FEEDING AND
CLOTHING INMATES IS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE NUMBER OF INMATES
WHO HAVE.
THE MAINTENANCE THAT THE SYSTEM
NEEDS IS NOT DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THE NUMBER OF A INMATES THE
SYSTEM HAS AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING TO CHANGE WITH
THIS --
METHODOLOGY.
RISEN MAINTENANCE NEEDS ARE
FIXED COSTS THAT ARE TIED
PRIMARILY TO THE NUMBER
BUILDINGS YOU HAVE THE SIZE AND
AGE OF THOSE BUILDINGS THE
MECHANICAL ELECTRICAL PLUMBING
SYSTEM SERVING THOSE BUILDINGS.
AND THEN THE ELECTRICAL AND
WATER WASTEWATER SYSTEMS AND AND
ROADWAY CYSTS.
PARDON THE ROADWAY SYSTEMS
SERVING THE ENTIRE --
PRISON CAMPUS --
THE COST OF MAINTAINING THAT
HOUSING UNIT OR MEDICAL BUILDING
DOES NOT FLUCTUATE IF YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED PEOPLE LIVING THAT
HOUSING UNIT OR A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE OR A HUNDRED FIFTY
THE MARGINAL CHANGES THERE BUT
THE OVERALL MAINTENANCE IT NEEDS
TO BE PERFORMED. TO KEEP IT
OPERATING STAYS THE SAME.
BECAUSE OF THE CHANGES IN THE
INMATE POPULATION OVER THE LAST
TEN PLUS YEARS THROUGH
REALIGNMENT AND THE VARIOUS
PROPOSITIONS THAT WERE DISCUSSED
IN THE EARLIER A CONVERSATION --
HAVING THIS FUNDED ON A PER
INMATE BASIS MEANS THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO PERFORM
THESE ONGOING MAINTENANCE
FUNCTIONS HAS BEEN REDUCED BY
ABOUT 33% --
WENT FROM ABOUT FORTY EIGHT
MILLION SEVEN TWO WORDS IT'S
ABOUT THIRTY THREE MILLION RIGHT
NOW.
AND THAT'S FOR A PORTFOLIO ABOUT
FORTY TWO MILLION.
SQUARE FEET --
SYSTEM WIDE.
SO WE HAVE FOR SEVERAL YEARS
BEEN WORKING WITH OUR PRISON
STAFF AND SERVING THEM TO
IDENTIFY WHAT ARE THE COSTS AT
YOUR LEVEL --
THAT WE SHOULD BE EXPANDING IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE FACILITIES
THAT THAT YOU'RE OPERATING --
PART OF THAT WAS LOOKING AT
MAKING SURE CONTRACTING
MECHANISMS WERE IN PLACE FOR
FIRE ALARM FIRE SPRINKLER
MAINTENANCE HIGH VOLTAGE
EQUIPMENT MAINTENANCE --
NOT ASKING THEM HOW MUCH ARE YOU
SPENDING THIS YEAR BECAUSE WE
KNOW THEY'RE NOT SPENDING AS
MUCH AS SHOULD BE BUT WITH THIS
CONTRACTING MECHANISMS IN PLACE
WHAT SHOULD WE BE SPENDING --
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE SYSTEMS
WHAT DO WE NEED N ORDER TO PAY
OUR REGULATORY FEES TO LOCAL
AUTHORITIES HAVING JURISDICTION
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
AND TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE PARTS
AND EQUIPMENT FOR ONGOING
REPLACEMENT OF ITEMS WHEN THEY
NEED REPAIR OR WHEN THEY'VE
REACHED THE END OF THEIR USEFUL
LIFE -- ONE
WE'VE GATHERED INFORMATION BY A
TO PRISON --
REVIEWED IT BASED ON THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE OF EACH PRISON AND
LOOKED AT IT ON AN AVERAGE
ACROSS --
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM IT CAME OUT TO
ABOUT TWO DOLLARS AND TWENTY
CENTS PER SQUARE FOOT --
THAT WAS ALSO COMPARED TO SOME
EARLY FOR PRISONS BUT FOR THINGS
LIKE OFFICE BUILDINGS --
AND TO TWENTY WAS --
CONSISTENT IN THOSE IN THOSE
OTHER --
PUBLICATIONS ALSO SO THIS A B.
C. P. WAS CALCULATED BASED ON
THAT TWO DOLLAR AND TWENTY CENTS
PER SQUARE FOOT AGAINST THE
FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLAR AYE
FORTY TWO MILLION SQUARE FEET --
AREA OF THE OF THE PRISON SYSTEM
CURRENTLY.
SO EIGHT WITHIN OVER PHASED
BASIS OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS
IT WOULD TAKE OUR FUNDING FROM
THE THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AT THE CURRENT FORMULA PROVIDES.
AN INCREASE AT APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
TO EIGHTY NINE MILLION IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND THEN I'M
GOING AT THAT LEVEL --
PLUS THIS PROPOSAL PLACES AT
FUNDING IN A SEPARATE BUDGET
ITEM IN ORDER TO ASSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY --
REGARDING HOW THE FUNDING IS IS
SPENT EACH YEAR --
A TIME BACK TO WE WERE
DISCUSSING THE KEY HERE IS THAT
THIS IS GOING TO ALLOW PRESENCE
COME UP WITH A MULTI YEAR PLANS
IN ORDER TO BE REPLACING ITEMS.
AS THEIR FACING THE AT THE END
OF THEIR USEFUL LIFE RATHER THAN
LEAVING LARGER SCALE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE TO BE SENT TO
HEADQUARTERS ON A DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BASIS --
THE EXAMPLE I USED REGARDING
YOUR HANDLING UNITS IS IS THE
EXAMPLE THAT I I KEEP USING IN
HERE THIS WILL ALLOW US TO WORK
WITH THE INSTITUTIONS WHICH
RIGHT NOW REALLY LOOK AT THEIR
MAINTENANCE NEEDS ON A YEAR TO
YEAR BASIS WHAT I HAVE TO DO
THIS YEAR.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THEY GET IS SO LIMITED
THEY'RE NOT THAT THEY'VE
UNFORTUNATELY UNTRAINED FROM
VIEWING IT AS OF THE YEAR A
MULTI YEAR PROCESS.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE ASPECTS OF
THE THREE YEAR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS IT WILL ALLOW US TO WORK
WITH OUR INSTITUTIONS.
AND ENSURE THAT WE FUND THESE
RIGHT OFF THE BAT --
WITH THE FIRST YEAR AND BEGIN
HELPING THEM SET PLANS FOR YOUR
TWO THREE AND FULL
IMPLEMENTATION TO BEGIN --
READ REPAIRING THEIR ITEMS AND
REPLACING THINGS BEFORE THEY
BECOME A LARGE SCALE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECT --
YOU SEE THERE'S ANYTHING I
pTHE CORRELATION IS.
THIS IS TWO ITEMS TO KEEP
JUMPING BACK AND FORTH --
PART OF LOOKING FOR THAT SWEET
SPOT UNDER FOR MAINTENANCE IS
ALSO HELPING TO RAMP THIS UP AND
GETTING THIS IN PLACE THIS OVER
TIME ONCE IT'S FULLY IMPLEMENTED
AND AND WE SEE IT GOING FORWARD
FIVE YEARS FROM THERE.
WE BELIEVE WILL CERTAINLY REDUCE
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE LIST
AND SO IF WE IT'S A COMBINATION
OF FIGURING OUT WHAT.
REDUCTIONS WILL WE SEE FROM THAT
AND THEN IF WE ARE GOING TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WE
SPEND EACH YEAR ON DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IN ORDER.
TO FULLY ADDRESS THE BACKLOG --
WE WOULD WANNA MAKE THAT
DECISION BASED ON THE BILLION
DOLLARS BECAUSE WE BELIEVE GOING
FORWARD AFTER FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS.
THAT BILLION DOLLARS WILL FALL
ON THE NATURAL SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S GONNA REQUIRE ONGOING
STUDY AND AND CONSULTATION TO
FIND THAT FIND THAT SWEET SPOT
BUT WE REALLY.
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL
HAVE POSITIVE --
EFFECTS GOING FORWARD THAT WILL --
PROVIDE THE PRISONS --
AS THE TYPES OF SPACES THEY NEED
TO BE IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THE
REHABILITATIVE.
PROGRAMS AND ALL THE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN ALREADY
DISCUSSED HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
THIS IS GOOD.
IT BE NICE TO SEE IF YOU WANTED
TO LOOK AT MAYBE YOU WANT TO SEE
THE FULL PICTURE.
HI WHERE YOU'RE GONE MAYBE A
LITTLE LONGER TIMELINE. THREE
YEARS I GOOD THOUGH I THINK YOU
SHOULD LOOK AT MAYBE --
LONGER TIMELINE TO SEE --
HOW YOUR I DON'T I DON'T LIKE
WHEN SOMEBODY SAYS ON THE
NATURAL OR WANT TO SEE THE
ACTUAL?
NOT THE NATURAL.
SO -- TIME
AT THE PLANT YOU KNOW A LIKE A
MORE.
FIND OUT THINGS TO YOU CAN SEE
HOW THE THE BACKLOG GETS REDUCE
AND IN YOUR I KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE.
SPENDING A LITTLE MORE EVERY
YEAR AND FINALLY YOU REACH
THAT'S BOB WEIR.
WHERE YOU'RE A?
BOB GOES AWAY.
AND TALK ABOUT CAPITAL LA NEXT.
COUPLE LA SHOULD.
GIVEN THE FACT WE HAVE A BILLION
DOLLAR AND IT'S BACK I THINK THE
CAPITAL L. IS.
I'LL BE A STRONGLY.
REHABILITATION OR THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROGRAM HAS TO BE VERY
INTO SB.
WE DON'T WANT A LOT OF NEW. ONE
FOCUS ON THE CAPITAL AT THE
COUNTER I WAS ON THE THE REHAB
PART OF OUR OUR BUDGET.
SO I I I I APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK YOU DID NUTS.
I AM INTERESTED IN REFINING IT A
LITTLE BIT LIKE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE ONE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CAPITAL.
INVESTMENTS ARE CAPITAL
EXPENDITURES ARE ORIENTED
TOWARDS THE PRIORITIES --
FOCUS THAT WE HAVE SO --
BEFORE IF I'M IN A LET.
I WANT TO GO TO THE VARIOUS
CAPITAL OUTLAY DISCUSSION AND
THEN SEE WHETHER --
FINANCE OR LA --
HAS ANYTHING MORE TO ADD --
BUT IN THE IN RECEIVING THE
BREAK DOWN THAT --
SENATOR BILL DESCRIBED.
YOU BYE SO IT MUST BE.
RIGHT FACILITY ALSO IS CLEARLY
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE.
SOME FACILITIES THAT ARE IN FAR
GREATER.
NEED IN HEART BIGGER DISREPAIR
THAN OTHERS AND WE MAY WANT TO
LOOK AGAIN AT THE ISSUE OF THE
COST EFFECTIVENESS OF
INVESTMENTS IN FACILITY THE OKAY
IF YOU MADE THE BOTTOM.
EXACTLY.
I'M YOU MAY PROCEED ON ISSUE.
FIVE OKAY CERTAINLY AND OUT OF
HIM TO GIVE A OVERVIEW RATHER
GOING INTO ANY DEPTH ON ANY ONE
OF THE PROPOSALS OF COURSE WITH
OUR QUESTIONS --
WE CAN GO MORE IN DEPTH --
ON ANY OF THE PROPOSALS --
SO THE CAPITAL OUTLAY OF ITEM
FOR ITEM --
FIVE CONTAINS OF APPROXIMATELY --
THIRTEEN NEW --
APPROPRIATIONS APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS --
AND THREE RE APPROPRIATIONS FROM
PRIOR YEARS THAT TOTALS
APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
OF THAT SEVENTY MILLION A LARGE
PART OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH --
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES --
AT FOR PRISONS SO --
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET CYCLE FOR
ADDITIONAL LEASE REVENUE FUNDING
FOR THE HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WE LOOK BACK
AT THE EXISTING HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS.
AND TO IDENTIFY WHICH ONES --
WE WERE LOOKING TO MANAGE OUR
RISK AS FAR AS INCREASED COST
INCREASE SCHEDULES ON THOSE
PROJECTS.
AD THROUGH THAT ANALYSIS WERE
IDENTIFIED OF FOUR SEPARATE
PRISONS --
PROJECTS OF FOUR SEPARATE
PRISONS THAT EITHER HAD POOR
PERFORMING CONTRACTORS --
AND THERE ANY CONSULTANTS --
EQUALLY MIGHT BE POOR --
IN AND HAD PROJECTS THAT HADN'T
STARTED YET THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
RENOVATIONS AND BUILDINGS THAT
WERE ABOUT FIFTY FIVE TO SIXTY
FIVE YEARS OLD --
OUR EXPERIENCE --
TO THIS POINT TIME HAS --
AND LET US TO RECOGNIZE THAT
WE'RE GOING INTO THESE BUILDINGS
THAT ARE THAT OLD WE FIND A LOT
OF ON ANTICIPATED SITE
CONDITIONS THAT DRIVE ADDITIONAL
COSTS --
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE GENERAL
CONTRACTORS DO CONSTRUCTION
BULLETINS AND AND NEW DESIGN
FEATURES FROM THE ANY FIRMS --
SO -- WE
MADE THE DECISION TO IN ORDER TO
GET THE LEAST REVENUE FUNDING TO
GO FARTHER WITH THE OTHER
REMAINDER OF THE HEALTH CARE
PROJECTS WE PULL FOR PROJECTS
OUT AT THESE FOR PRISONS AND
PROPOSE THEM THROUGH THE BUDGET
ACT AT TO BE DONE AS A
COMPLETELY SEPARATE PROJECT
WOULD.
NO LONGER BE --
DRAIN ON ANYWAY ON THE LEASE
REVENUE FUNDING FOR THE
REMAINDER OF IT AND WE PLAN TO
HAVE THE WORK DONE BY THE INMATE
WARD LABOR PROGRAM --
BEYOND THE ASPECTS OF THE THAT
PRINTER SHIP IN THE JOB TRAINING
TO THAT WE HAVE A BETTER ABILITY
UNDER THE HECK A PROGRAM TO
CONTROL OUR COSTS WHEN WE'RE
USING THE IN MAY OR LABOR
PROGRAM RATHER THAN A GENERAL
CONTRACTOR.
IF WE DO RUN INTO DELAYS WE
DON'T FACE EXTENDED JOB COST
THAT WE DO WITH GENERAL
CONTRACTORS AND OUR INMATE WERE
LABOR PROGRAM HAS A MUCH BETTER
RELATIONSHIP LOCAL PRISON STAFF.
AND CAN MANAGE THE DISRUPTIONS
THAT COME FROM THESE PROJECTS --
BECAUSE MANY OF THESE ARE IN THE
CENTRAL HEALTH SERVICES BUILDING
AT THESE AT THESE PRESENCE.
BEYOND THE FOR HEALTH CARE
PROJECTS IN HERE --
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL A
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS AT A
NUMBER OF LOCATIONS --
PELICANS A PELICAN BAY STATE
PRISON --
FACILITY D. WAS --
PART OF THE FOR THERE THAT WAS --
CHANGED INTO A GENERAL
POPULATION UNIT AND THIS IS IN
ORDER -- TO
CONSTRUCT A STANDARD --
YARD FOR THEM --
TO RECREATION --
ANOTHER PROJECT IS AT THE
CORRECTION TRAINING FACILITY AND
SOLD AND MINISTRY OF SEGREGATION
CELL DOOR RETROFIT TO IMPROVE --
SAFETY --
FOR THE INMATES AND TAFF THIS
IS SIMILAR TO A PROJECT THAT WE
JUST --
WE'RE WE'RE JUST COMPLETING
RIGHT NOW AT DUAL VOCATIONAL
INSTITUTION THAT WAS A SUCTION
TYPE [inaudible]
OF ROGER CAN THEREFORE
ADDITIONAL WATER STORAGE TANKS
AT FOLSOM THAT WOULD SERVE BOTH
FOLSOM STATE PRISON AND
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SACRAMENTO --
THIS IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS A FIRE
LIFE SAFETY REQUIREMENTS THAT --
WERE IDENTIFIED IN THESE PRISONS --
THROUGH THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
AND THE HEALTH CARE CONSTRUCTION
WE DON'T NEED TO GO THROUGH EACH
ONE OF THESE SINCE WE HAVE IT
BEFORE US I MEAN WE OBVIOUSLY
MAY HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THEM.
BUT RATHER THAN YOU'RE LITERALLY
READING TO US I MEAN AND I DON'T
MEAN IT THIS IS NOT --
BUT RATHER THE OVERVIEW IS WHAT
WOULD I THINK RIGHT NOW BE MORE
HOPEFUL AND THEN WE MAY HAVE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS BUT ANY ONE
PARTICULAR.
PROPOSAL OUR FACILITY.
OKAY LET ME I WILL TRY TO TRY TO
SUMMIT AND IS BRIEF BE AS BRIEF
AS POSSIBLE --
THE BUDGET DOES INCLUDE FOR
PROJECTS THAT ARE REQUESTING THE
SECOND PHASE OF FUNDING SO THESE
ARE PROJECTS THAT WERE IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR THE
PRELIMINARY PLAN PAYS AND WE'RE
NOT REQUESTING TO MOVE ON TO THE
WORKING DRAWING PHASE --
THE BUDGET REQUEST DOES INCLUDE
ONE BRAND NEW PROJECT --
THIS IS --
IT ALLEN ADAM VALLEY STATE
PRISON NEAR MADERA --
WE HAVE A WATER SYSTEM THEY'RE
SERVING BOTH VALLEY STATE PRISON
AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FACILITY ACROSS THE STREET --
ARSENIC IN THE GROUNDWATER IS
ENDEMIC IN MANY OTHER AREAS OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE HAVE
FIVE WELLS SERVING THESE TWO PER
ENDING.
THE WELL WATER --
BECAUSE SOME WELLS ARE BETTER
THAN OTHERS IN ORDER TO MEET
ARSENIC STANDARDS BUT THE
ARSENIC LEVELS ARE RISING SO THE
LONG TERM SOLUTION TO MAINTAIN
STANDARDS THERE IS GOING TO BE --
TO BUILD AN ARSENIC TREATMENT
PLANT TO SERVE BOTH PRISONS --
AND THEN --
JUST VERY BRIEFLY THERE ARE --
TWO REVERBERATIONS --
ONE HAS TO DO WITH THE A. B.
NINE HUNDRED I'M SORRY THERE
THREE REVERBERATIONS ONE IS --
TO GO TO CONSTRUCTION ON A NEW
BOILER FACILITY AT DAHLE
LOCATIONAL INSTITUTION --
FIRE MARSHAL APPROVAL OF THE
DRAWINGS CAME AFTER THE END OF
THE FISCAL YEAR THIS WEEK WE
COULD NOT USE THE FUNDING FROM
THE PREVIOUS BUDGET.
ARE THE EVEN A HUNDRED GENERAL
FUND OF CORPORATION IS A FUNDING
SOURCE FOR US SEVEN ON GOING
PROJECTS ARE IN CONSTRUCTION NOW
AND SO --
PROJECTED COMPLETION DATES FOR
THOSE PROJECTS IS AN TWENTY
TWENTIES OR ASKING TO HAVE THAT
FUNDING REPROGRAMMED IT SO WE
CAN COMPLETE THOSE PROJECTS --
AND THEN FINALLY THERE'S THE
STUDY OF THE ORIGINAL TWELVE
PRISONS --
AND REALIZES THAT THIS PRESENT
PROJECT HAS BEEN MUCH DELAYED IN
AS A SOURCE OF MUCH FRUSTRATION --
WITH OUR RELATIONSHIP --
WITH WITH THE LEGISLATURE --
WE DO BELIEVE THAT WE ARE ARE ON
THE RIGHT TRACK TO GETTING
COMPLETED NOW WE SPEND
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO FINALIZE A FORMAT --
WITH THE CONSOLE UTILIZED AND TO
CORRECT --
DEFICIENCIES AND HOW THE OR
NATIONAL REPORTS WERE COMING IN --
WE NOW BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE --
FOR DRAFT REPORTS --
SO THERE'S EIGHT MORE TO GO YOU
HAVE REPORT LEASE --
LATER THIS CALENDAR YEAR --
SO WE'RE REQUESTING EXTENSION OF
THE LIQUIDATION PERIOD TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN --
FINALIZE THE INVOICES AND AND
PAY ALL THE BILLS OVER THE
CONSOLE --
BY THE END OF NEXT FISCAL YEAR --
BILLABLE ANSWERING QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
CURRENTLY I'M.
THIS EITHER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE REALLY --
HAVE A COMMENT ON THIS BEFORE A
GIVE ME COMMENTS FROM MY
QUESTIONS FOR MY COLLEAGUES.
GO AHEAD SENATOR MORE LIKE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
LEASE REVENUE BONDS --
WHERE ARE WE?
ARE WE GONNA DO THAT JUST HELP
ME OUT ARE WE ARE WE PAYING RENT.
THE STATE PAYING RENTS RIGHT NOW
FOR EVERY.
PRISON AND YOU'RE USING THAT
INCOME AS THE THE CASH FLOW
OUGHT WELL ARE ARE PROJECTS IN
FRONT OF HERE IN THIS BUDGET
REQUEST NONE OF THEM ARE RELYING
UPON LEASE REVENUE BONDS.
OKAY SO.
WHAT HAVE I GOT HERE WHAT WHY
DID THEY LEASE REVENUE BONDS?
FOR IS THE FIRST.
THREE I'M IN A GUEST BONE.
WHAT A WHAT AM I MISSING I'M?
SO THAT RELATES TO THE PROJECTS
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY REVIEWS
OTHER HEALTH CARE --
HEALTH CARE.
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROJECT
TAKE THE PROJECT THE CARVED OUT
OF THE SCOPE OF THE PREVIOUS
PROJECT WE'RE PUTTING FORWARD AS
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS SO THOSE
PREVIOUS PROJECTS WERE --
WERE WERE WERE FUNDED THROUGH
LEASE REVENUE BONDS.
AND AND WE'RE HERE FOR ME IS
PREVIOUS TO THANK YOU.
FOR POINTING THAT OUT.
BECAUSE I WOULD OR MAYBE JUST
FOR MY BENEFIT --
WHAT WHAT WAS THE LINK TO THE
BOND SOMEBODY? TO MATURITY THERE
THERE ARE VARYING L<c.cyan>G SAID</c>
GENERALLY IT THIRTY YEARS --
IF OR TO TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY YEARS AT IT VARIES DUE TO
MARKET CONDITIONS AT THE TIME
THAT THE IN THE YOU KNOW
TREASURES --
OFFICE DECISIONS WHEN THAT GOES
TO MARKET.
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE TIME I
PAYING DOUBLED IN THE INTEREST
COSTS RATE OVER THE LIFE OF THE
THIRTY YEARS.
THAT THERE BEEN VER STUDIES ON
A BUTTON WITHIN WE SHOULDN'T
QUIBBLE ON WHETHER IT'S FULL
DOUBLE OR NOT YES.
ROUGHLY IT'S THE A TOTAL
INTEREST COSTS ON EACH OF THESE.
YOU KNOW YOU WON'T HAVE THAT
WITH THE DAY BUT AGAIN JUST
TRYING.
TO PRUDENT WITHOUT WE SPEND
MONEY.
THAT ARE MORE LIKE OLD ALLOW
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO ADD ON
AND OF COURSE YOU MAY TWO BY THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CRANE ONE
ROBIN HARSH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AT CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW
IT'S ABOUT ONE POINT SIX TIMES
OF THE SOUL THE BOND FOR HUNDRED
DOLLARS WOULD BE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY DOLLARS THAT WOULD PAY
BACK OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
YEAH ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
YOU DID IT OKAY --
GREAT OKAY.
CENTER BILL --
WE DID --
THIS CAN YOU EXPLAIN MORE
DETAILS ABOUT THE THE PRISON
WATER STORAGE TANKS.
WHAT IS THE PROJECT?
SO THE FIRE CODE AS I LIKE WATER
OR THE WATER TANKS IS.
SIXTY TWO WELL THEY I THINK THE
SIXTY SIX MILLION WAS THE PRICE
OF THE OVERALL HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT --
PROJECT THERE THE AND FOR THE
WATER TANKS IS NINE POINT SIX
MILLION.
THE THE TOTAL COST OF THE WAR.
NINE NINE ONE SIX NINETY NINE
POINT ACT.
THE WHAT WHAT THE GORE WIRING.
OKAY -- THE
THE IF IT'S THE FOR THE FIRE
CODE REQUIREMENTS --
FOR THE FIRE FLOW NECESSARY
BASED UPON THE SIZE OF THE
BUILDINGS AND WHETHER THE
BUILDINGS ARE SPRINKLED OR NOT.
THIS IS ONE OF THE DIFFICULTIES
WE RAN INTO IN IMPLEMENTING
HEALTH CARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM IS THAT WE ARE GOING
INTO MANY PRISONS THAT HAD BUILT
IN PREVIOUS YEARS AND THE CODES
MAY HAVE CHANGED SINCE THEN SO
AS WE WERE IN.
THE BUILDING --
VARIETY OF NEW BUILDINGS AND
RENOVATIONS AND COLLEGES BUT CAN
WE BE SPECIFIC TO THE FOR SOME
WATER TANKS.
SO WHEN WE ARE BUILDING THE GUM
THE BUILDINGS IN THE RENOVATIONS
AT C. S. P. SACRAMENTO IN FOLSOM
STATE PRISON --
THE FIRE MARSHAL IN REVIEWING
THE PLANS IDENTIFIED THAT THE
FIRE FLOW REQUIREMENTS NEEDED TO
BE MET AND THE WAY THE FIRE FLOW
REQUIREMENTS ARE MEASURED IS
BASED UPON THE LARGEST SPRINKLER
BUILDING.
EVEN THOUGH OUR PROJECT WAS NOT
BUILDING THAT SMALLER BUILDINGS
BUT THEY WATER STORAGE
REQUIREMENT FOR SPRINKLERS WAS
BASED ON THE LARGEST BUILDING
WHICH IS --
WAREHOUSE OF A QUITE SOME SIZE
AT ALL AT THIS IS THE SACRAMENTO.
SO THAT'S THE REASON WHY THE
TANK SEVENTY BUILDERS BECAUSE
THE FIRE MARSHAL IDENTIFIED A
DEFICIENCY IN THE EXISTING
FACILITY AS FAR AS THE STORAGE
REQUIREMENT FOR FIRE WATER.
SO HE WANTS A STORAGE FACILITY
AS OPPOSED --
TO OUR FARM WATER --
FLIGHTS WERE FROM --
WATERS [inaudible]
SUPPORT SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO BUILD IT.
IT IS A REASON WHY IS REQUIRING.
IT IT HAS.
TO IT THAT'S A QUESTION IT HAD
IT HAS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A A
A SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF FLOW FOR A
SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF TIME AT A
SPECIFIC --
GALLONS PER MINUTE AND THE
EXISTING WATER SERVICE IN FROM
THE MUNICIPALITY BUT NOT BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THAT EVEN IF IT WAS
SOLELY DEDICATED JUST --
TO JUST TO FIGHTING THAT FIRE.
OUR WATER CHANGE.
AND A CERTAIN NUMBER.
THE WATER PRESSURE THE YES I
THINK I AM DOING WITHOUT PULLING
OUT THE DOCUMENT I THINK SOME
LIKE FOUR THOUSAND GALLONS PER
MINUTE --
OVER THE COURSE OF OF TWO HOURS
OR THREE HOURS.
AND TIMES A SQUARE FOOT YEAH.
DON'T HAVE A WELDER.
NO WE'RE ON MUNICIPAL WATER
THERE AND IN THERE THEY ALSO
REQUIRE --
THE PROJECT TO SHOW HOW THAT
WATER IS MAINTAINED AT ALL TIMES
SO IF YOU HAVE A TANK AND YOU
HAVE A DAILY FLUCTUATION OF YOUR
WATER USAGE YOU NEED TO BE ABLE
TO SHOW HOW THAT DAILY
FLUCTUATION STILL.
ALWAYS LEAVES THEIR FIRE REQUIRE
THE CODE REQUIRED AMOUNT IN.
WHAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED?
WAS NOT TANKS.
THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR DAILY
WATER USAGE YOU JUST DESCRIBED
TANKS THAT HAD TO BE NECESSARY
FOR THE SHOW YES BUT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE ANY NOT YELLOW.
THERE ARE NOW THAT COVERS OUR
DAILY WATER USAGE BUT RIGHT
NOBODY HAS OCCURRED.
YOU ARE BUILDING NEW TANK. FOR
THIS PURPOSE WHAT THE NINE
MILLION IS YES SO WHY WOULD THEY
NEED NEED TO BE.
I THANKS THAT WOULD ALSO SUPPLY
FOR THE DAILY WATER USED.
I APOLOGIZE I MISSTATED A
MANAGER A WHERE WAS SAYING IS A
REASON WE'RE BUILDING NEW TAXES
BECAUSE OUR EXISTING TANK DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR THE CAPACITY THE
NECESSARY WITH THE DAILY HAS OF
THE DAILY WITH RIGHT BECAUSE OF
THE DAILY USAGE THESE NEW TANKS
OR JUST TO COVER THE FIRE.
FLOW REQUIREMENTS.
IN WAS THERE ANY DISCUSSION WITH
THE FIRE MARSHALL AS TO HOW
THERE MIGHT BE.
ACCOMMODATION FOR THE WAREHOUSE.
SEPARATELY FROM THE CUSTODIAL
FACILITY.
OF WE ARE PRESENT HAVE NOT BEEN
BUILT WITH SEPARATE FIRE FLOW --
A FIVE FIGHT ESSENTIALLY ONE
SINGLE WATER SYSTEM THAT'S OUR
THAT THAT THAT'S THE OBVIOUSLY
AND THAT'S WHY YOU'RE BUILDING
NEW BUT STILL YOU ARE CLEARLY
CONNECTING THESE WATER TAKES SO.
DID YOU CONSIDER AND ENTERTAIN
[inaudible]
A A SEPARATE SOURCE.
FOR THE WAREHOUSE VISIT YOU'VE
DESCRIBED THAT YOU MUST HAVE
THIS LARGER ARE LARGER ASK
BECAUSE OF THE SQUARE FOOTAGE
WAREHOUSE FACILITY.
WHICH YES WILL HAVE PEOPLE BUT
NOT LIKE.
THE LADY TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SO
WAS THERE.
ANY NEGOTIATIONS WITH FIRE
MARSHAL AROUND.
SOME DIFFERENTIATION HERE THAT
MIGHT THEN REDUCE OUR COSTS.
I I UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION AND
I DON'T HAVE THE DETAILS IN
FRONT OF ME AT THIS TIME SO I'LL
GO BACK AND AND RESEARCH THAT
WITH THE PROJECT TEAM AND QUE.
RESPOND BACK THROUGH THE CONCERT.
IS I MEAN CLEARLY WHAT YOU
DESCRIBED AS A THE WATER TANKS --
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING AT NINE
MILLION FOR SOME WATER TANKS AND
I'M THINKING.
THOSE ARE PRETTY CADILLAC BUT
DEPENDING ON THE CAPACITY MAYBE
NOT BUT THEN AGAIN MAYBE THE
CAPACITY DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
QUITE.
CERTAINLY WE NEED TO ACHIEVE THE
OBJECTIVE OF THE FIRE MARSHAL
BUT MAYBE THERE'S OTHER WAYS TO
ACHIEVE IT.
I'M UNDERSTOOD WHEN WE GO BACK
AND RESEARCH THAT AND WE WILL UP
RIGHT INFORMATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR BELT BACK TO YOU OF SODA
[inaudible]
YES.
IS -- FOR
FOR AND YES [inaudible]
SO WHAT [inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
SO.
ONE ONE IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A A
THREE TIER HOUSING UNIT USED
AGAIN FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION AND IT HAS OPENED
BARRED CELL FRONTS SO THE
ABILITY.
AND YOU KNOW TO THE YOU THE
ABILITY --
TO EITHER PUT --
STAFF OR IN IN MAY THAT MAY BE
ESCORTING PASS ANOTHER INMATE
CELL AND RISK IS VERY VERY MUCH
A IN AT RISK --
FOR ANY SORT OF ATTACKS WHILE
YOU'RE WALKING PAST --
THE THE LONG TEAR SO IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM HERE AND IT
AT OTHER PRISONS --
WE REPLACE THE BARD CELL FRONT
WITH SALAS ALL FRONTS --
IT INCLUDES --
ADDITIONAL VISION PANELS --
AND THE VENTILATION SYSTEM THE
SERVICE OF THE THIS THE CELLS
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S BASED
UPON AIR FLOW THROUGH THE BARS
AND FORCE WHEN YOU PUT THE SOLID
OR THERE YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE GETTING THE PROPER
AIR FLOW THROUGH.
US ALSO AGREED THE BUILDING --
TO INCLUDE --
FIRE ALARM A FIRE SPRINKLERS
WHICH MAY NOT WE'RE NOT CODE
REQUIRED AT THE TIME THE
BUILDING WAS.
ORIGINALLY CONSTRUCTED BUT IS
REQUIRED TO THE LEVEL OF
RENOVATION WILL BE DOING IN THIS
ROOM.
IN THE WORLD.
NOT A CONDITION BUT BUT BUT
EVAPORATIVE COOLING --
YES VILLAGE.
OUR FIRE ALARM FIRE SPRINKLER
UPGRADES [inaudible]
I INDEED.
ONE I AM I FEAR THAT ANY
COMPARISON WOULD BE APPLES AND
ORANGES BECAUSE THAT NEW CELL
WOULD BE BUILDING BUILDING THAT
GOES ALONG WITH IT --
SO I HAVEN'T DONE THE MATH ON
THIS ONE WE NEVER LOOKED AT IT
ON A ON A PER CELL.
PURCELL COST.
I'M NOT MORE MONEY BUT INCLUDING
IN SCOPE I BELIEVE THE LIGHTING
FIXTURES ARE BEING ARE ARE BEING
REPLACED AT THE SAME TIME ALSO --
YEAH.
BUT NO WE'RE NOT REPLACING THE
BUNKER NOT REPLACING THE YES
WELL IT'S IT'S TO READ IT'S TO
CREATE A S. A SAFER WORKING
ENVIRONMENT YET [inaudible]
GOOD WORK [inaudible]
CERTAINLY I I I OF THE STATE.
OF YOU'RE NOT THE ONLY.
ONE CENTER MORE LIKELY TO ONE
OKAY.
I'M.
AND I WOULD ONLY REYES.
IT -- TO
COMPLY COLLEAGUES SENATOR BILLS
CONCERNS OR COMMENTS BUT ON THE
ON THE ISSUE OF AND IF THIS
DOESN'T NECESSARILY NEED TO
COMMENT BUT WE DID APPROVED LAST
YEAR -- RE
PURPOSING SOME YARDS AT PELICAN
BAY [inaudible]
GIVEN -- OUR
INTENT -- TO
BRING POPULATION OUT OF STATE
INTO STATE AND KEEPING OUR
POPULATION NUMBERS DOWN IN THE
OTHER THE LADIES THAT ARE PASSED
OR CLOSE TO THEIR CAP
[inaudible]
I'M.
BUT IN CONTEXT OF OUR DISCUSSION
EARLIER.
AROUND OUR REQUIREMENT TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING.
THE APPROPRIATE.
AND CONSISTENT OR COMPARABLE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS IN ALL
OF OUR YARDS IN ALL OF OUR
FACILITIES.
AND HOW SOME LEVEL OF THOSE ARE
DEPENDENT ON COMMUNITY MOMENT
VOLUNTEERS AND SUCH.
WHEN WE LOOK AT FACILITIES LIKE
PELICAN BAY?
THAT ARE VERY REMOTE AND NOT
NEAR POPULATION CENTERS WE ALSO
KNOW THAT OUR ABILITY. TO
SUCCEED IN THOSE ASPECTS.
OF IS DIFFICULT IS HARDER.
AND SO I HAVE TO LOOK AT AS WE
THINK ABOUT IT COMMITTING
EXPENDITURES OF FUNDS.
WHETHER WE AND AGAIN AS WE LOOK
AT WHERE WE'RE GOING TO PUT
POPULATION IN WE WE PUTTING
POPULATION.
AT FACILITIES WHERE WE KNOW WE
CAN.
PROVIDE THE ADEQUATE REHAB
BECAUSE WE HAVE ACCESS TO EITHER
THE EDUCATIONAL.
INSTITUTIONS OR OTHER AND I'M
NOT TALKING JUST VOLUNTEERED WE
HAVE THAT PRO PROPER --
ACCESS WHICH WE MAY NOT IN SOME
OF THE REMOTE FACILITIES SO
AGAIN DOESN'T REQUIRE COMMENT
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY A LENS THAT
I'M GONNA BE LOOKING AT IN OUR
EXPENDITURES.
THROUGHOUT OUR BETTING OF CDC
OURS BUDGET.
JUST SO GO AHEAD CENTERVILLE.
KIND OF CURIOUS OF WHICH THE
SAUDIS HAVE BEEN WORSE
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG.
IN TERMS OF ANALYZING
[inaudible]
THESE REQUEST.
YEAH YOU CAN GET.
THAT DATA --
I DON'T KNOW GIVE IT TO US.
RIGHT RATHER THAN.
FIND WORSE YEAH JUST GIVE US.
MAYBE OUTLINED WITH THE PROBLEMS
OR ERRORS.
THE SOUL IS THAT HAVE --
WORST.
OKAY BUT YES OR NO GREAT.
OKAY SO NOW PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON THESE ITEMS THIS IS ISSUE
THREE FOUR FIVE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
OKAY WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM
[inaudible]
THESE -- ALL
RIGHT SO --
APOLOGIES I DID NOT ACTUALLY.
MR CLOSER WE ARE YOU PREPARED
NOW YOU HAVE THE OTHER STAFF OR
DO YOU WANT ME --
TO JEEZ I'M FINE OKAY GREAT
BECAUSE WE WERE HAD WE I SUPPOSE
GOTTEN TO YOUR ITEM EARLIER WE
MIGHT NOT HAVE HAD YOUR STAFF
PRESENT I'M HAPPY TO DO IS.
FIRST IF THAT'S IF THAT NO I
THINK.
I THINK I CAN ADEQUATE OF MY
STAFF.
YES WE'RE GOOD.
ALL RIGHT THEN WE WILL --
PROCEED WITHISSUE SIX WHICH IS
AN OVERVIEW OF OUR IN MADE
HEALTH CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BY A RECEIVER.
ON PARK ALSO.
RECEIVED THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS CLARK
KELSO I AM THE RECEIVER
APPOINTED BY THE FEDERAL COURT
IN THE PLOTS OF LITGATION.
A WITH RESPONSIBILITY FOR CDC
OURS MEDICAL PROGRAM I HAD JUST
NOTICED --
IN REVIEWING OF THE THE AGENDA.
OF THAT I'M LISTED AS TALKING
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND THAT ACTUALLY IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF SOMEONE ELSE.
MY RESPONSIBILITY IN THE PLOT
LITIGATION IS LIMITED TO MEDICAL --
I WON'T BE SPEAKING TO MENTAL
HEALTH IF YOU WANT TO REPORT
FROM THAT YOU SHOULD.
DISCUSS THAT WITH --
DIANA TOSH.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT
CLARIFICATION.
I'M OVERALL --
WELL FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO AMBER
A AND JUST A FEW ADDITIONAL
DETAILS TO THE BACKGROUND THAT'S
ALREADY PROVIDED TO SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS IN YOUR AGENDA.
I WHICH DOES --
DESCRIBE THE HISTORY AND
BACKGROUND OF OF THE BOTTLE
LITIGATION.
OVERALL.
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE STEADY
PROGRESS IN FILLINGOUR MISSION.
BY IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF
MEDICAL CARE THAT IS BEING
DELIVERED TO OUR PATIENTS AND ON
AN INSTITUTION BY INSTITUTION
BASIS.
TRANSFERRING AUTHORITY OVER THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM BACK TO THE
STATE.
AS OF TODAY.
UP TWENTY FOUR OF CDC OURS
THIRTY FIVE INSTITUTIONS ABOUT
69%.
HAVE EITHER BEEN DELEGATED BACK
TO CDC ARE FOR ITS MANAGEMENT.
FOR RECEIVED A FINDING OF
ACCEPTABLE CARE FROM THE OFFICE
OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
OF SPECIFICALLY NINETEEN
INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN DELEGATED
THERE ARE FIVE ADDITIONAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
RATED BY --
Y. G. AS ADEQUATE.
BUT I HAVE NOT YET DELEGATED.
I'M THAT LEAVES US WITH ELEVEN
REMAINING INSTITUTIONS --
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN DELEGATED
BACK TO THE STATE AND DO NOT
HAVE A FINDING OF ADEQUATE CARE.
IN THOSE INSTITUTIONS ARE NOW --
ONE OF MY MOST THE PRIMARY
FOCUSES.
I BELIEVE THAT A FEW OF THESE
ELEVEN WILL FAIRLY EASILY BE
FOUND ADEQUATE IN THE NEXT ROUND
OF REVIEWS BY THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
AND WILL BE SUITABLE FOR
DELEGATION BACK TO THE STATE.
THAT WILL LEAVE US WITH A SMALL
BUT STILL SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE FRANKLY.
SOME OF THE MOST DIFFICULT TO
MANAGE INSTITUTIONS.
IN THE STATE.
WELL THAT WOULD PROBABLY BE MORE
LIKE.
EIGHT I CAN ASSURE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF CARE IN
THOSE MOST DIFFICULT
INSTITUTIONS.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO PAINT TOO
ROSY A PICTURE.
GETTING TO THE FINISH LINE WITH
THESE LAST INSTITUTIONS IS GOING
TO BE VERY HARD WORK.
AND IT WILL REQUIRE VERY CLOSE
COOPERATION WITH AND SUPPORT
FROM SECRETARY DIAZ IN HIS
CUSTODY RESOURCE.
THE ACTING SECRETARY AND I WORK
VERY WELL TOGETHER VERY CLOSELY.
AND WE ARE JOINTLY COMMITTED TO
GETTING THIS JOB DONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE JUST TWO OF OUR
MOST IMPORTANT RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS.
OUR FIRST I AM PLEASED TO REPORT
THAT THE ELECTRONIC HEALTH
RECORDS SYSTEM.
WHICH WAS A MASSIVE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PROJECT BEGUN A SHORT
FIVE OR SIX YEARS AGO.
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED AT ALL INSTITUTION.
OUR PATIENTS BENEFIT FROM THIS
SYSTEM EVERY SINGLE DAY.
OUR MEDICAL RECORDS ARE NOW
FINALLY IN SUCH GOOD ORDER.
THAT OUR PROVIDERS NURSES
ADMINISTRATORS CAN EASILY TRACK
EVERY PATIENT'S MEDICAL HISTORY
SEE IN MONTREAL TEST RESULTS
EASILY SCHEDULE PROVIDER IN
SPECIALIST INITIAL AND FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS.
PRESCRIBE MEDICATIONS AND
MONITOR THEIR ADMINISTRATION.
NURSE NOTES DOCUMENTING THE CARE
THAT IS BEING DELIVERED.
EQUALLY IMPORTANTMEDICAL
LEADERSHIP OF THE INSTITUTION AT
THE REGIONAL LEVEL AT
HEADQUARTERS ALL THE WAY UP TO
ME PERSONALLY.
WE ARE ABLE TO MONITOR THE
DELIVERY OF CARE.
IN REAL TIME.
I'M WHEN I BEGAN BACK IN
WHATEVER THAT WAS.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE HAD ONLY
PAPER RECORDS.
AND WHEN I STARTED WE HAD FIFTY
THOUSAND INCHES OF ON FILED
MEDICAL RECORDS WHICH IS ABOUT
WE USED TO SAY TO EMPIRE STORIES --
TO EMPIRE BUILDINGS WORTH OF
MEDICAL RECORDS.
THAT IS ALL GONE.
ON AND WE ARE NOW INTO A TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY --
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD.
SECOND I'M THE SECOND MAJOR --
DEVELOPMENT.
AFTER SUBSTANTIAL --
INTERNAL DELIBERATION LAST YEAR.
I JOIN WITH UNDERSECRETARY DIANA
TASCHEN DIRECTING OUR STAFF TO
DEVELOP A MEDICATION ASSISTED
THE TREATMENT PROGRAM. TO
ADDRESS THE SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER
OF PATIENTS WITH LCD C. R. WHO
HAVE SUBSTANCE INDOOR OPIOID USE
DISORDERS.
A WITH A DIRECTION INITIALLY TO
FOCUS ON THOSE PATIENTS WHO ARE
AT HIGHEST RISK FOR OVERDOSE.
AS THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE NO.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER S. YOU DO
USE A COMPLEX CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITION [inaudible]
INVOLVING DOPAMINE DYSREGULATION
IN THE BRAIN THAT CONTROS
REWARDED MOTIVATION.
AND CAN LEAD TO UNCONTROLLABLE
CRAVINGS CONTINUED SUBSTANCE USE
ANOTHER ABHORRENT BEHAVIORS.
WHICH CONTRIBUTES TO PERMANENT
DISABILITY PREMATURE DEATH.
ANOTHER ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES FOR
AFFLICTED INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES.
IN RECENT YEARS ARE OPIOID USE
DISORDER --
IS THE PRIMARY --
S. U. D. E. ASSOCIATED WITH THE
INCREASE AND NON FATAL OVERDOSES
NATIONALLY.
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IN CDC ARE.
WE ESTIMATE OF THE PREVALENCE OF
S. U. D. AMONG THE CDC OUR
POPULATION IS APPROXIMATELY 80%.
AND THAT AT LEAST 26% THAT'S
ABOUT TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
PATIENTS.
HAVE --
OPIOID USE DISORDER.
CURRENTLY THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATION OFFERS BEHAVIOR
THERAPIES TO ALL CDC OUR
INSTITUTIONS THROUGH VARIOUS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS.
ALL MOST OF THE BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY SERVICES DELIVERED BY
THE CONTRACTORS ARE BASED ON
MODELS THAT HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
BE EFFECTIVE IN SPECIFIC GROUPS
OF PATIENTS IF IMPLEMENTED AS
INTENDED.
OF FRANKLY THE RELIABILITY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE
TREATMENTS WITHIN THE CDC ARE IS
LARGELY KNOWN.
ADDITIONALLY THE CURRENT S. UT
TREATMENT MODEL USED BY DR P. IS
NOT BASED ON A MEDICAL CHRONIC
CARE MODEL.
WHICH IS HOW WE HAVE ON THE
MEDICAL PROGRAM A REDUCED ARE
AVOIDABLE DEATHS --
DURING THE COURSE OF THE
RECEIVERSHIP.
INSTEAD THE TREATMENT DURATION
IS ONLY FIVE MONTHS AND CURRENT
AVAILABLE TREATMENT CAPACITY IS
LESS THAN TWELVE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS PER YEAR.
SO WE WILL BE PROPOSING AN M. A.
N. M. A. T. PROGRAM INVOLVING
LONG TERM COMBINATION THERAPY
WITH MEDICATIONS AND BEHAVIORAL
INTERVENTIONS.
THAT WAS WILL BE BEST DELIVERED
IN AN INTEGRATED HEALTH CARE
SETTING.
USING INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAMS
WHO TAKE CARE OF THEIR PATIENTS
THROUGHOUT THE CONTINUUM OF CARE.
THIS APPROACH WILL PROVIDE
GREATER OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE
RELIABILITY.
EFFECTIVENESS AND EFFICIENCY IN
THE DELIVERY OF CLINICAL
TREATMENTS.
WHICH IN TURN SHOULD ALLOW
BETTER COST CONTROL.
AND PROMOTE BETTER.
POSITIVE OUTCOMES.
INCLUDING DECREASES IN RELAPSE
FATAL AND NONFATAL OVERDOSES
ABNORMAL BEHAVIORS WITHIN THE
PRISON SETTING.
AND HOPEFULLY ULTIMATELY A
REDUCTION OF RECIDIVISM.
IN OUR MODEL S. UT TREATMENT
WOULD CONTINUE OUR AFTER RELEASE
FROM CDC ARE CUSTOM.
IN COORDINATION WITH EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS HAS BEGUN.
ON NOVEMBER TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE CONVENED A TREATING
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS SUMMIT.
ATTENDEES INCLUDED
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
LEGISLATURE OF THIS COMMITTEE.
A PRISON LAW OFFICE UNIVERSITIES
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH SERVICES JAILS.
OF THE OREGON DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS JERRY AND EXPERIENCE.
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS --
CDC OUR ARMS BIRDS MOM OFFICE.
PRISON INDUSTRY AUTHORITY
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
BERMAN FINANCE.
THE FORMER REPRESENTATIVES AND
FORMER GOVERNOR BROWN'S OFFICE
AND THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL AMONG OTHERS.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS STAKEHOLDER
MEETING WAS --
TO BRIEF THEM ON OUR INTENDED
PROGRAM.
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO OUR
PLAN.
UP TO ENSURE ACCESS TO CARE FOR
PATIENTS WITH S. UT DURING A
HIGH RISK OF TRANSITIONS TO THE
FREE WORLD AT TIME OF RELEASE.
ADDITIONALLY THE SUN WAS OLD
IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES
OPPORTUNITIES AND LEVERAGE
POINTS TO IMPROVE CARE DURING
TRANSITIONS.
I ESTABLISH ONGOING
COLLABORATION AND COMMUNICATION
WITH OUR PARTNERS.
I DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
THIS SPRING AND SUMMER --
WITH MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ON THE MANY ISSUES THAT WILL BE
INVOLVED IN THE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT NEW
TREATMENT PROGRAM --
CAM WITH THAT MADAM CHAIR I'M BE
DELIGHTED TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE OVERVIEW --
OR WE CAN TURN TO ISSUE
[inaudible]
SEVEN THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
MORE LIKE.
MR KELSO NICE TO MEET YOU NICE
TO MEET YOU SENATOR I KNOW YOU
BY REPUTATION [inaudible]
I'M.
SO IT SAID GOOD TO BECOME
ACQUAINTED I I JUST HAVE ONE
QUESTION AND AND IN I WOULD
ASSUME.
IN YOUR ROLE THAT IT'S YOUR JOB
TO WORK YOURSELF OUT OF THAT JOB.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING HOW
THAT'S WORKING.
FOR WELL --
AS I'VE INDICATED WE MADE
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS IN THE
DELEGATIONS ARE WE'RE DOWN TO OF
THE LAST REMAINING MOST
DIFFICULT INSTITUTIONS.
NOW I HAVE A LASER FOCUS ON
COMPLETING THAT TASK I THINK
THINGS ARE GOING [inaudible]
REASONABLY WELL.
I WOULD HAVE PREFERRED.
FRANKLY THAT THESE LAST
INSTITUTIONS WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO IMPROVE THEMSELVES --
USING ALL THE TOOLS AND POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES WE PUT IN PLACE
JUST AS OF THE OTHERS.
THEY HAVE PROVEN TO BE MORE
RESISTANT TO IMPROVEMENTS.
AND FRANKLY WHAT WE ARE DOING
RIGHT NOW IS TRYING TO DIAGNOSE.
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE TOOLS THAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE WORK.
IT'S JUST ARE NOT WORKING OF
THOSE INSTITUTIONS.
AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE IT'S A
REALLY COMPLEX CHALLENGE.
OF THE FIGURE OUT WELL WHY
HASN'T WORKED AND THEN ONCE THE
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION TO THAT
PROBLEM.
SO I'M THAT'S WHY I REMAIN
OPTIMISTIC THAT I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE.
IN THE DIRECTION OF WORKING
MYSELF OUT OF A JOB.
GREAT SO.
I CAN INFER THAN THAT IS MAYBE A
SQUARE PEG IN A ROUND HOLE
VERSES INSUBORDINATION.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S
INSUBORDINATION [inaudible]
THANK.
THANK YOU MANAGER [inaudible]
SENATOR BREAUX --
JUST.
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE --
PROGRAM IS. ONE OF THE OTHER WAY --
AFTER FOUR YEARS OF RAISING THIS
ISSUE IN THIS.
AND GETTING THE PROGRAM GOING ON
A COMPREHENSIVE BASIS.
WHAT KIND OF --
STEPS YOU YOU THINK WILL BE
TAKEN.
TO TOTALLY EMPLOYMENT --
DRUG TREATMENT FOR ALL THE
INMATES THAT HAVE DRUG ABUSE
PROBLEMS AND HOW HOW DOES THE
THE ELECTRONIC RECORDS.
TRANSITION WHEN THEY LEAVE
PRISON.
IT WAS SO NICE.
THEY GO INTO A LOCAL HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS --
THOSE RECORDS ARE KEY TO PROVIDE
GOOD.
HEALTHCARE TREATMENT ONCE THEY
LEAVE.
RESIDENT AND I I KNOW YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS WHAT DO YOU
ARE YOU --
EXPLAINED TO THE MERRY.
WELL THANK YOU SENATOR OFTEN
QUESTION AND AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LONG ISSUE BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE ADVOCACY IS IN
PART OF THE REASON THAT.
WE MADE THE DECISION LAST YEAR --
TO TO GO MUCH BROADER
[inaudible]
I'M.
V. R. WERE IN THE PROCESS OF
PUTTING TOGETHER AN ESSENTIALLY
AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN FOR HOW
WE WOULD ROLL THIS OUT BECAUSE
IT'S A VERY BIG PROGRAM.
I'M AND WE DON'T WANT TO TRY TO
IMPLEMENT TOO MUCH.
ALL AT ONCE M. STUMP.
THE FOCUS OF OUR FIRST AVERAGE
IS GOING TO BE ON MAKING SURE
THAT INMATES AS THE INITIALLY
COME INTO THE SYSTEM WHO ARE
ALREADY ON SOME FORM OF
TREATMENT.
THERE WE MAINTAIN CONTINUITY OF
THAT TREE.
WHICH WE HAVE NOT REALLY
PREVIOUSLY DOT.
SECOND WE'RE MOST INTERESTED IN
CATCHING PEOPLE WHO ARE ABOUT TO
BE RELEASED.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE GET TO
THEM EARLY ENOUGH SO THAT THEY
CAN GET INTO AN OF THE
CONDITIONS OF THE PROGRAM.
SO AT THE TIME OF RELEASE OF
WHAT WE'VE DONE AS MUCH AS WE
CAN.
I'M WILL SO WE'LL START OF THOSE
ENDS AND THEN OF A GRADUALLY
MOVE TOWARDS OF BUILDING THE
PROGRAM OUT TO ALL INMATES THE
GROUP IN THE MIDDLE.
IN TERMS OF THE U. COORDINATION --
AT THE TIME OF RELEASE THAT
OBVIOUSLY IS CRITICAL.
IN OTHER OF THIS YOU KNOW THERE
ARE A LOT OF ISSUES YOU HAVE TO
WORK WITH TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN THOSE FIRST TWO WEEKS
AFTER RELEASED.
SOMEBODY ACTUALLY GETS IN FRONT
OF A PROVIDER IN THE COUNTY.
AND THAT THE TRANSITION IS VERY
LOS.
ILLEGAL PROVIDERS WITH ONE WE
WANT TO GET IN FRONT OF THE
PROVIDERS THAT WE ARE
COORDINATING.
NOW.
THE GOOD NEWS ON THAT FRONT WITH
THE ELECTRONIC MEDICAL RECORD --
WE NOW ARE AT A POINT --
WE RECEIVED ALIVE BELIEVE IT'S
CORRECT TO SAY IT'S A
CERTIFICATION BUT WE ARE AT A
POINT WHERE WE ARE ABLE NOW TO
SHARE --
INFORMATION DIGITALLY FROM OUR
MEDICAL RECORD. TO QUALIFYING --
LOCAL.
MEDICAL RECORD SYSTEMS AND I'M
FAIRLY CONFIDENT I'M GOING TO
SAY THIS IN THE CITY OF MY STAFF.
MODS I BELIEVE FOR EXAMPLE THAT
IN A LOS ANGELES COUNTY WHERE
WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS WITH
RESPECT TO MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS
FOR SOME TIME.
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO HAVE
A FAIRLY I'M.
EASY PROCESS WE WILL BE ABLE TO
SELECT WHAT INFORMATION FROM OUR
MEDICAL RECORD CAN BE SHARED
DIGITALLY.
WITH LOCAL PROVIDER.
MY STAFF HAS NOT IT [inaudible]
ACOSTA [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
DRUG ABUSE [inaudible]
MENTAL HEALTH.
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
YES.
I DID AND I KNOW I'VE FORGOTTEN
THE DETAILS OF THIS BUT I
BELIEVE WE WE HAVE HAD TO DO
SOMETHING TO BECOME FULLY HIPPA
COMPLIANT SO WE CAN DO THAT HAND
OFF.
AND AND I MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT IS WHERE WE NOW ARE.
WE DID A WE DID SOME BILLS OF OF
ALLOWING THE COUNTY CORRECTIONAL
SYSTEMS.
TO GIVE HEALTHCARE INFORMATION
AND TO THEIR HEALTHCARE --
AND SOCIAL STATURE SERVICE
AGENCIES YES OF SO THE PICTURE
THE RECORDS THE THING ABOUT THE
PLAN.
NO DISBURSING THE
CONFIDENTIALITY ISSUE.
ON THE HEALTH CORRECT SO --
W. SOMETHING --
THE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S
YEAH.
JEFF WE INTERESTED NOT ISSUE --
YES -- ONE
OF ONE OF THINGS HAPPEN IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS.
AS YOU KNOW.
IS -- THE
FENCE ALL HAVE EPIDEMIC.
AND THE DEATH RATE --
THE CALIFORNIA IS GOING UP IN
THE UNITED STATES ACTUALLY IS
GOING UP IN A ASTRONOMICAL
FASHION.
BECAUSE OF OKAY --
LACED WITH FENNEL [inaudible]
AND THIS SPECIALLY --
PRESENTS VULNERABILITIES TO
PEOPLE LEAVING [inaudible]
PERSPIRATION [inaudible]
AND IN TERMS OF GOING BACK TO
ADDICTION YOU THINK THAT --
DOES THE MEDICATION PROGRAM.
ARE YOU LOOKING OUT HOW THE ON
THAT.
ISSUE.
OF WHEN THEY LEAVE AND THEN THEY
IMMEDIATELY.
TRY. TO GET THE DRUGS AND THE
DEATH WITH DEFICIT WE SEE WHEN
PEOPLE LEAVE PRISON.
PEOPLE DIE WITHIN THE PRISON AND
THEY TAKE THE DRUG HAPPENS THERE
OF WOULD BE JUST NO PH<c.cyan> N</c>
AND THE WINNER WITH THE OVERDOSE
BECAUSE TEY'RE NOT USED TO THE
THE OLD LOW.
YOU EXPRESS WHAT WILL CERTAINLY
THE THAT'S THE BIGGER WORRY
ABOUT THIS TO DEATH --
MORBIDITY ISSUES [inaudible]
FOUND.
SO THE COMMONEST DOWNING.
JUST FIFTY OF THE NUMBERS ARE
GOING UP THREE FOUR TIMES WITH
THE YEARS THE YOU KNOW JUST A
FEW YEARS AGO THREE FOUR YEARS
AGO.
ALMOST ARE WE WE ARE --
WE PERSONALLY EXPERIENCE THAT --
WITH OUR PATIENTS AND SEE SEE
OUR FRONTAL COMES IN WE SEEN
DEATHS RELATED TO A FATAL USE SO
THE OF THAT PARTICULARLY
DANGEROUS DRUG --
THE THE GOAL OF OUR GOAL AND
FOCUSING ON SINCE WHO ARE ABOUT
TO BE RELEASED.
IS TO SEE IF WE CAN GET THEM
SOBRE AT THE TIME OF RELEASE.
AND CONNECTED WITH LOCAL SUPPORT
SERVICES NOT JUST MEDICAL BUT
SOCIAL WORK SERVICES.
SEE IF WE CAN.
KEEP THEM FROM TAKING ANY OF THE
DRUGS IN THOSE FIRST TWO WEEKS.
THOUGH IT IS AN ISSUE THAT --
WE ARE FOCUSED ON TRYING TO
ADDRESS IN THIS LARGELY THROUGH.
GETTING THEM READY AT THE TIME
OF RELEASE IN THE IN CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH LOCAL SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT YOU NEED IN ORDER
TO BE SUCCESSFUL UPON RELEASE.
AND AND I'VE TO MAKE IT CLEAR
IT'S IT'S AS YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
JUST. EIGHTY MEDICATION PROBLEM.
IT'S A PROBLEM DEALING WITH THE
ENTIRE RANGE OF SERVICES THAT
SOMEONE NEEDS UPON LEAVING
PRISON.
A TO FEEL LIKE OR MAYBE ABOUT A
CHANCE OUT HERE.
SO WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR PARTNERS.
WHO WOULD BE PROVIDING THOSE
SERVICES?
ARE YOU INVOLVED --
OR TO WHAT EXTENT IS MAYBE THE
TALK ABOUT THIS THE PAROLE --
SYSTEM IS SUPPOSED TO BE
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR OF SOME OF THE ISSUE TALK
ABOUT [inaudible]
ARE -- TERMS
OF TRAINING EQUIPMENT EQUIPMENT
WITH ABILITY --
HOWEVER THE BE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR RETRAINING
NEEDS [inaudible]
TO MAYBE.
DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE --
FROM THE PRO DEPARTMENTS
PERSPECTIVE.
HOW HOW WHAT KIND OF THINGS THEY
HAVE TO DO THE?
FIT IN WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
I'M CENTER THAT QUESTION GOES TO
A LEVEL OF DETAIL THAT I'M GOING
TO SEE IF MY STAFF GOING TO
DRESS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT.
IMPORTANCE OF THE QUESTION.
ABOUT WELL WHICH ROLE PERHAPS --
WE COULD DO IS RATHER THAN
HEARING THE VERBAL REPORTS
SPECIALLY GIVEN THAT YOU MAY NOT
PREPARED FOR IT WE THIS IS.
PART OF OUR ON IN ADDITION TO
YOUR ROLE AS THE RECEIVER IT'S
PART OF OUR APPROPRIATE
UNNECESSARY ATTENTION TO MAKING
SURE THAT OUR I'M.
THE WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH IN
THE PRISON IS PREPARING FOR
SUCCESS FOR ENTRY AND THEN WHAT
WE ARE DOING.
WITH PAROLE WHICH IS THE
SUPERVISION OF PEOPLE.
ON THAT IT IS [inaudible]
BEING DESIGNED.
INTENTIONALLY AND ADEQUATELY. TO
HELP US ENSURE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THESE PROBLEMS OF EITHER.
AND ADDRESS SUBSTANCE DISORDER
WHICH THEN CAUSES EITHER A DEATH
OR RETURN TO PRISON.
I'M AND WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
HEARINGWHERE WE FOCUS VERY AG
IN MUCH MORE DETAIL AROUND.
THE REENTRY PORTIONS ON BOTH
FREE RELEASED RIGHT REENTRY
PREPARATION.
PAROLE.
AND THAT --
TO PROVISION OF PAROLE.
SO.
PERHAPS IN PREPARATION FOR THAT.
I'M A SOMETHING FROM YOUR
DIVISIONS PERSPECTIVE FOR YOUR
OFFICE'S PERSPECTIVE WOULD
ASSIST US.
HAPPY TO OBLIGE --
I HAVE SOME LEGISLATION RANCHER
ON ON THE ISTHMUS PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THE PROGRAM.
OPERATED BY THE POOL SYSTEM
WHICH IS NOT PROVEN TO BE --
ADEQUATE --
IN DEALING WITH THESE ISSUES AND
I THINK THAT.
THE HEARING BE VERY VALUABLE IN
TERMS OF LOOKING AT A BETTER
MODEL. TO HAVE THAT TRANSITION --
FOR IN A WAY WHERE WE CAN GET
THE BEST POSSIBLE SERVICES THE
BILL ONCE THE COMMUNITY.
SO I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
STICKING ON MEDIA.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS LINE
FOR A FEW MOMENTS --
YOU MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE.
YOUR ESTIMATE IS A 2600026% OF
OUR OF FOLKS CURRENTLY IN OUR
STATE PRISONS HAVE AN OPIOID USE
DISORDER.
NOW IF THAT.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IS
IF THERE ARE NOT BEING PROVIDED
THE MEDICAL ASSISTANCE UNLESS
THEY HAVE?
GONE THROUGH APPROPRIATE
TREATMENT IN OUR WHATEVER --
NO LONGER UTILIZING THE DRUG.
THEN THAT MEANS THEY ARE THAT WE
BUT WHATEVER NUMBER CLOSE.
TO TWENTY SIX THOUSAND WHO RE
REGULAR OTP YOUR USERS WITHIN
OUR FACILITY [inaudible]
AND THAT WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE.
PUT ON A GOOD DEAL OF NEW
INVESTMENT TO TRY TO DO DRUG
INTERDICTION --
WOULD APPEAR THAT.
WELL MAYBE IT'S HAD A LITTLE
IMPACTED WOULD CERTAINLY
INDICATE NOT MUCH.
AND CERTAINLY WITH --
BUT NO BECAUSE OF ITS MINUSCULE
QUANTITIES SO EASY TO GET IN. TO
A FACILITY.
I JUST WONDER.
WHETHER --
WHAT'S THOUGHT THERE WOULD BE.
WHETHER A BROADER USE OF
MEDICALLY ASSISTED TREATMENT
[inaudible]
MIGHT.
BE MORE EFFECTIVE THAN MOST OF
OUR DRUG INTERDICTION PROGRAMS.
AND I ASKED THAT ON A COUPLE
LEVELS [inaudible]
ONE PLEASE ME.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE I DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE
THE USE OF LIKE IF I'M AN OPIOID
ADDICT.
AND I AM UNDER MEDICAL ASSISTED
TREATMENT DOES THAT PRETTY MUCH
DO I STILL.
DOES THAT NEGATE MY DESIRE TO
THEN FIND THE ILLEGAL SUBSTANCE
OR DO I STILL HAVE THAT CRAVING.
SO IN OTHER WORDS AND THAT'S ONE
QUESTION AND THEN THE SECOND ONE
IS.
LET'S SAY I AM ON THE MEDICALLY
ASSISTED TREATMENT.
BUT SOMEHOW I HAVE ACCESS.
WHILE I'M STILL IN THE FACILITY.
TO THE ONLY I USE THAT WHILE I
AM ON THE MEDICALY ASSISTED.
DOES THAT ENHANCE MY OVERDOSE OF
POTENTIAL OR SO IF YOU COULD
JUST ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE.
MAINTENANCE IS LIKE A FROG SO.
GOING.
I WON'T ENDEAVOR TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THOSE --
SUDDENLY JUMPS UP PLEASE LET ME
KNOW -- WELL
IN TERMS OF THE THE OF YOUR
INITIAL QUESTION CAN THIS BE
MORE SUCCESSFUL THAN
INTERDICTION.
YES I THINK IT CAN BE A BECAUSE
INTERDICTION UP HAS NOT YET
WORKED.
ON THE THE INTENTION HERE IS
ULTIMATELY.
TO HAVE RESOURCES THAT WILL
ENABLE US TO PROVIDE TREATMENT
TO ANYONE WHO WANTS TREATMENT --
THANK YOU MY MEDICAL RESOURCES
HAVE A RIDE.
THE IT IT'S A COMPLEX QUESTION
FRANKLY WHETHER --
YOU KNOW AS A GENERAL MATTER THE
MEDICATION ASSISTED THERAPY --
ELIMINATE --
CONSISTENTLY THE CRAVING.
THE THE THE REASON IT'S A
COMPLEX --
QUESTION AND THE ANSWER THERE'S
NOT A SINGLE DRUG THAT YOU USE
THERE ARE VARIATIONS DEPENDING
UPON THE CHARACTERISTICS OF THE
PARTICULAR PATIENT.
A WHAT'S MEDICALLY APPROPRIATE
FOR THEM.
IN ADDITION OF THE MEDICATION OF
THESE PROGRAMS REALLY DON'T WORK
UNLESS YOU HAVE SUCCESSFUL
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL THERAPY. TO
CHANGE BEHAVIOR.
BECAUSE OF THE END OF THE DAY IF
SOMEBODY DECIDES.
I'M DON'T WANT TO CONTINUE THIS
PROGRAM I'D RATHER JUST TAKE THE
DRUGS.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IN IN THE PRISONS YOU HAVE AN
ENVIRONMENT I THINK RIGHT NOW
WHERE IT'S PROBABLY EVEN MORE
THAN JUST THE DRUGS ARE
AVAILABLE.
DRUGS ARE BEING PUSHED ON PEOPLE.
IN THERE'S SOME FEAR AND
INTIMIDATION TO GET PEOPLE.
TO BUY DRUGS.
BECAUSE THIS IS A YOU.
MONEY IS BEING MADE OFF OF THIS.
SO WE ANTICIPATE.
THAT EVEN ARE BEING AS EFFECTIVE
YOU CAN BE WITH THESE PROGRAMS
OF THIS IS TRUE AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL
[inaudible]
ALWAYS [inaudible] FOR RELAPSE.
AND THERE THERE DOES COME A
CYCLE WHERE SOMEBODY WILL
RELAPSE AND THEN YOU TRY TO GET
HIM BACK ON THE PROGRAM.
BUT IT IT'S NOT SOMETHING WHERE
YOU HAVE --
YOU CAN PREDICT.
A 100% SUCCESS.
BY WAY OF COMPARISON WELL AS YOU
ALL KNOW WE WE HAD ASKED THE
LEGISLATURE AND RECEIVE SUPPORT
FOR OUR HABSI A PROGRAM.
WELL THAT'S ONE WE'RE WE'RE
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL.
I HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS IN THE
STATE IN TERMS OF IF SOMEBODY'S
ON THAT PROGRAM THEY ARE NOT.
A RE CONTRACTING --
Là CONDITION [inaudible]
ARMED.
THAT'S ONE WHERE THERE IS YOU'RE
GIVEN THE PILLS YOU'VE GOT THE
TWELVE WEEK OR EIGHT WEEKS SEEK
ONCE YOUR GET A CURE.
THIS IS MUCH MORE LIKE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS.
WHERE IT REQUIRES THE?
IN GAUGE WANT.
OF THE PATIENT.
AND WE ALL KNOW WITH CHRONIC
CONDITIONS --
DIABETES.
AND AM I GONNA TAKE MY PILLS IN
MY GOING TO REDUCE Y DIET MY
GOING TO EXERCISE --
RELAPSE RATES ARE SIGNIFICANT.
SO -- PART
OF THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE IN THIS
IS I THINK SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED -- TO
IN OUR OWN PLANNING AND
CONVERSATION LEGISLATURE.
WE NEED TO ESTABLISH SOME.
I'M REALISTIC EXPECTATIONS OF
WHAT THIS CAN ACCOMPLISH.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT GONNA BE A 100%.
IT'S GOING TO BE LESS THAN.
AND THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'VE ASKED STAFF IN
CONSULTING WITH NATIONAL EXPERTS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT WE'RE GETTING FOR THIS SORT
OF AN INVESTMENT?
WILL PRESS FOR FOR THE DOCTOR
ANSWERS THE QUESTION THE OTHER
PORTION OF MY QUESTION.
IS OUR OF THIS TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
ARE THEY CONCENTRATED IN CERTAIN
THE FACILITIES COMPARED TO
OTHERS.
OR IS THIS PRETTY MUCH EQUALLY
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS ALL OF OUR
THIRTY SOME ODD [inaudible]
PRISON FACILITY.
I BELIEVE THAT I DON'T THINK
IT'S JUST EQUALLY.
I THINK THERE ARE CONCENTRATIONS.
BUT IT IS AT ALL THIRTY FIVE
OKAY SO IF IT'S ALL THIRTY FIVE
BUT YOU COULD GIVE US.
AND AGAIN YOU KNOW I HAVE TO DO
IT VERBALLY NOW THAT YOU COULD.
PROVIDE US.
I'M WHICH FACILITIES PERHAPS
WERE HAS A HIGHER CONCENTRATION.
SO THAT WE AT LEAST AN HOUR
APPROACHING HOW TO DEAL WITH
THIS WE HAVE SOME SENSE.
RIGHT MAYBE ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT
ALL.
YEAH WE WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH SOME DATA POINTS WILL
SUGGEST WHERE THERE ARE HIGHER
CONCENTRATIONS OF PROBLEM.
AFTER ONLY REASON AFTER WE MATCH
WOMEN TO HAPPEN IF YOU CAN GIVE
ME A NUMBER OF TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND AND YOU MEANS YOU'RE
TRACKING TO SOME DEGREE SO YOU
HAVE SOME SENSE OF WHERE THE
CAMERA AROUND I WILL ADMIT MUCH
OF MUCH OF THE INFORMATION WE
HAVE ON THE TWENTY SIX ON
UNIVERSITY.
OF CALIFORNIA BERKELEY IT'S AN
ESTIMATE OKAY BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
BEEN FROM A ON THE MEDICAL SIDE.
WE DON'T COUNT.
THROUGH SCREENING THOSE PEOPLE.
OF THAT WILL BE SOMETHING THAT
THE THROUGH THE AS WE BEGIN
IMPLEMENTATION.
WILL START TO GET MUCH BETTER
DATA ABOUT WHAT THE NUMBERS ARE
AND WHERE THEY ARE BUT WE HAVE
SOME ESTIMATES --
WE CAN LOOK AT WHERE THE
OVERDOSE A NUMBER OF OVERDOSE IS
ARE THERE SOME INFORMATION WE
HAVE AND WILL PROVIDE THAT TO
THE COMMITTEE.
AND THEN ON THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER --
IF I'M ON MEDICALLY ASSISTED
TREATMENT AND THEN I USE THE
WHETHER HEROIN OR FELT NO ALERT
IS MY LIKELIHOOD OF OVERDOSE
INCREASE.
AND AND JUST THOSE MEDICAL PART.
IT DEPENDS ON HOW WE'RE TREATING
THE THE PATIENT AND WHAT'S RIGHT
AND WHAT DRUGS ARE USED AYE I'M
DOCTOR THIRD I'M DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH CARE OPERATIONS FOR THE
RECEIVER --
LET'S TALK ABOUT BUPRENORPHINE
WHICH IS THE DRUG THATIS MOST
EFFECTIVE IN WILL BE THE MAIN
STATE DRUG WE WILL BE USING WILL
BE USING A RANGE OF DRUGS.
BUT BUPRENORPHINE IS IS A MAIN
WAS IS NOW NEW DRUGS BEEN AROUND
FOREVER.
IT HAS PROPERTIES THE IN IN THE
IN THE BODY THAT YET BOTH --
BEHAVES LIKE AN OPIOID IN OTHER
WORDS THAT KNELLER MORPHINE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT BUT ALSO
BEHAVES LIKE NOR CANON
ANTAGONISED TO THE EUPHORIA IT'S
WHAT WE CALL A MIXED.
A MIX DAGEN THIS ANTAGONISED
ACTIVE AT REMOVING YOUR CRAVING.
FOR NARCOTICS YOU WILL NOT GO
INTO WITHDRAWAL ON AN
APPROPRIATE DOSE DRUG.
BECAUSE IT HAS MIXED AFFECTS YOU
WILL ALSO NOT GET YOU FORK.
THE THE THE RIGHT SURE THE HIGH
OF FROM AN ILLICIT OBTAIN
SUBSTANCE.
THE DRUG BECAUSE IT HAS NEXT
ANTAGONISE PROPERTIES.
IT IS POSSIBLE TO GET A LETHAL
OVERDOSE OF FENTANYL I MEAN THE
FENNEL IS INCREDIBLY POTENT DRUG
AND WE'RE NOT ONLY DEALING WITH
THAT NOW WE'RE ACTUALLY DEALING
WITH FENNEL ANALOGUES WHICH ARE
EVEN MORE POTENT THAN MEN FENNEL
YOU CAN GET INTO SOME OF THESE
DRUGS.
THAT ARE TEN THOUSAND TIMES AS
POTENT AS REGULAR FENTANYL ABOVE
THE I'M OUT OVER MORPHINE SO IT
IS POSSIBLE FOR YOU --
TO TO HAVE A LETHAL OVERDOSE
WHILE YOU WERE ON BUPRENORPHINE
HOWEVER IT IS MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO DO.
BUT AS AS A RECEIVER POINTED OUT.
YOU ALSO HAVE TO CONSIDER THE
ENVIRONMENT WITH WHICH WE WILL
BE PRESCRIBING THIS MEDICATION.
AND SO THE MOTIVATION OF AN
INDIVIDUAL PATIENT TO TO OBTAIN
ILLICIT DRUGS IS GOING TO BE
DEPENDENT ON THE ENVIRONMENT
THEY ARE IN.
AND AS WAS POINTED OUT THERE IS
SOME QUARTERS IN FOR SEEN YEAH
THERE IS A LARGE TRADE.
IN THESE DRUGS WITH IN THE
PRISON SYSTEM --
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM IN SPITE
IN TERMS OF INTERDICTION BEING A
LESS EFFECTIVE --
STRATEGY AND THAT'S NO DIFFERENT
REALLY THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE
WORLD NEIL INTERDICTION
STRATEGIES HAVE BEEN EMPLOYED
WITH VARYING DEGREES OF SUCCESS.
SO THE QUESTION YOU'RE REALLY
ASKING IS HOW QUICKLY CAN WE GET
TO THIS MIDDLE GROUP OF PEOPLE.
WE'RE TAKING THE HIGHEST GROUP
YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE COMING AND
WE'RE CONTINUE THE MEDICATIONS
ARE ON WAS.
THE GROUP THIS LEAVING WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY KEY BECAUSE A SENATOR
BELL POINTED OUT IT'S NOT TWO
WEEKS IS TO DATE.
YOU KNOW THAT THE OVER THE OVER
DOSE RATE YOU KNOW IS ANYWHERE
BETWEEN DEATH THE IS WITHIN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS RELEASE.
SO WHAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT A
HAND IN GLOVE TRANSFER TO FIFTY
EIGHT DIFFERENT COUNTIES WITH
FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT WAYS OF
DOING THINGS AND FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF RESOURCE.
THOSE WILL BE OUR FOCUS AND THEN
AS WE MOVE INTO HIS MIDDLE
GROUP WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS ON
OUR HIGHEST RISK PATIENTS FIRST.
AND THAT LARGELY IS A GROUP THAT
IS ALREADY ATTEMPTED OVERDOSE
INNER HAS SURVIVED.
I IS THE HIGHEST GROUP.
THE GROUP THAT IS CURRENTLY
UNDERGOING HEPATITIS C.
TREATMENT BECAUSE THEY GENERALLY
GOT THEIR DISEASE FROM
INTRAVENOUS DRUG USE AND WE'RE
SPENDING LARGE SUMS OF MONEY ON
THEM WE ACTUALLY HAVE VERY SAD
CASES NOW WE'RE WE HAVE CURED
PEOPLE THEIR HEPATITIS C..
ONLY SEE AND DIVERT DRUG
OVERDOSE.
ARM SO THOSE WILL BE THE GROUP'S
WILL FOCUS ON AND WILL FOCUS
SAID A SET OF OF HUBS WILL SHOW
YOU ALL THE IMPLEMENTATION
THINGS WE'VE GOT BUT YOU KNOW AS
FAR AS WE KNOW NO ONE IS TEMPTED
THIS ON THIS SCALE.
SO WE'RE GONNA LEARN AS WE GO ON
WE'VE GOT OUR BEST IDEAS WE
ALLOW REAL SMART PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM THAT GIVEN THIS ADVICE BOTH
INTERNAL EXTERNAL CDC ARE.
BUT WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO BE INFORMED WITH OUR INITIAL
ROLE LOTS OF WHAT HAPPENS FROM
THERE.
THANK YOU I A MINUTES.
SOME.
ARE YOU LOOKING AT THAT IS
EXTENDED --
YOU KNOW LIKE INJECTABLE ONCE
THE ONE OF THE PLAN AND THE THE
IMPLANTS.
THE SO THEY BEFORE THEY LEAVE
PRISON THEY GET THAT.
IN MY LAST --
LITTLE TIME WELL WHAT THE
MANUFACTURER IS DOING SOMETHING
LIKE THAT YEAH WITH IT WITHOUT
GETTING INTO A MONTH OR SO.
WITH IT WITHOUT GETTING INTO
INTO YOU KNOW REALLY SUB WE'D
LEVEL ON WE'RE LOOKING VERY
CLOSELY AT THE AT THE AT THE WAY
WE ADMINISTER OF MEDICAID WHICH
FORMA MEDICATION WE'RE GOING TO
USE.
THERE'S WHERE THERE'S ACTUALLY
BEEN SEVERAL STUDY IT WHILE
SEVERAL THERE'S BEEN TWO STUDIES
NOW DONE OUTSIDE OF PRISON
ENVIRONMENT TRYING TO COMPARE.
THE RELATIVE RISK BENEFITING
COST EFFECTIVENESS OF THE LONG
ACTING VERSUS THE IMMEDIATE
ACTING VERSUS THE DEPOT ACTING.
ON AN ACTUALLY THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS IS FOR THE SHORT
ACTING MEDICATION IN THE IF IF
YOU'VE HAD PEOPLE APPROPRIATELY
MOTIVATED AND WE SEE THIS NOW
WITH THE PATIENTS THAT COME INTO
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT --
IN THE FREE WORLD WITH AN
OVERDOSE WHERE WE ACTUALLY
INITIATE THERAPY IN THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT BEFORE
THEY'VE EVER MADE CONTACT WITH
THAT GROUP.
IS GOING TO MAINTAIN THEM AND A
AND THAT'S BEEN A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS BEING DONE
YOUKNOW AND AND WERE IN VERY
CLOSE CONTACT WITH THAT GROUP
BECAUSE SOME OF OUR PATIENTS
UPON RELEASE.
WILL NOW INTERACT IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT AS WELL.
SO OUR INITIAL PLAN RIGHT NOW
ACTING ORAL MEDICATION.
ONCE YOU HAVE SOMEBODY STABILIZE
FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME THEN
THE THE LONG ACTING MEDICATION
WORKS WE ARE NOT IN THE HAMMERED
RIGHT NOW AT ALL WITH THE DEPOT
MEDICATION.
BECAUSE OF SOME VERY UNIQUE
THINGS IN OUR OUR SERVER IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT TOGETHER WITH THE
THE CURRENT COST --
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD BE LOOKING
AT THE DEPOT TYPE MEDICATION
EXCEEDING A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER INMATE PER YEAR.
WHICH YOU KNOW MAKES OUR MAKES
HER HEPATITIS C. TREATMENT
LICHTER CHEAP --
I APPRECIATE THE THE NATIONAL
INFORMATION --
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE IT ESTIMATE IT'S
CLEARLY SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
GIVE A GOOD ATTENTION TO BUT
WHAT I WOULD ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES IS IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE
ESPECIALLY AROUND.
OUR SUBSTANCE ABUSE --
DISORDERED ST MINTS ARE
MEDICALLY ASSISTED TREAT AND WE
CAN HAVE OUR STAFF --
MISTER FRANCIS CAN.
THEN PREPARE IT AND ASK THE
RECEIVER.
TO YES SOME OF THOSE ANSWERS SO
THAT WHEN WE REVISIT THIS WE
HAVE YOU KNOW THE INFORMATION
THAT WE ARE HOPING.
I WANT TO MOVE ON TO A DIFFERENT --
QUESTION EIGHT WITHIN THE
RECEIVERS.
VIEW THAT IS NOT AROUND THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS I JUST
WANT TO THE CENTER MARK ON OUR
ON MENTAL HEALTH.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE [inaudible]
COMMITTEE.
AND THE NO HELP MARCUS IS GOING
[inaudible]
TO ASK.
FOR PRESENTATION --
PROBABLY IN APRIL.
ON PROGRAM.
SO YOU CAN COME AND MAKE A
PRESENTATION WE HAVE USUALLY GET
A GOOD CROP ABOUT TWENTY
LEGISLATORS.
WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY CENTER.
RIGHT TO THE THE QUESTION THAT I
HAVE BEEN AND YOU CAN PREPARE IT
WE DO NOT NEED IT VERBALLY BUT
WE'VE HAD IN PAST YEARS HAD A
BREAK DOWN SO.
I EIGHT SEE FOR MORE MATERIALS
THAT WERE CURRENTLY WILL AND IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OUR COST.
PER INMATE. FOR MEDICAL CARE
ANNUALLY WAS IN THE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND RANGE I BELIEVE SO MY
IS PROBABLY A LITTLE HIGHER EVEN
THIS.
YEAR THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YEAR
WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE IS A
BREAKDOWN.
OF IT ITEMS MATCHING IT'S LIKE
OUR HEALTH INSURANCE OR MET YOU
KNOW WE SEE THOSE CHARTS AND
THEY SHOW US THAT --
THE AVERAGE COST FOR PROVISION
OF HEALTH CARE FOR THE WHOLE
POPULATION IS X. BUT IT'S
CONCENTRATED 480% IT'S ONLY THIS.
AND FOR IF YOU KNOW 5% IT'S THAT
NO OTHER FIVE IT'S THIS AND
ANOTHER.
SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS
THAT KIND OF BREAK DOWN AND THEN
WITHIN THAT PERHAPS AGE OR OTHER
CHARACTERISTICS.
SO THAT WE CAN THEN LOOK AT I'M.
NO OBVIOUSLY THE RECEIVERS DRIVE
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING.
THE ADEQUATE HEALTH CARE FOR
THOSE PEOPLE THAT WE ARE HOLDING
WITH THAT WE ARE INCARCERATED
WHAT WHAT.
WHAT I FEEL PART OF OUR JOB IS
BESIDES MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
DOING THINGS WITH QUALITY AND
ACCORDING TO THE LAW?
IS ALSO TO MONITOR OUR GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURES AND SO IF WE
HAVE.
A A RATHER SMALL POPULATION OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE ARE.
HOLDING.
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR A VERY
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF OUR
HEALTH YOUR BOSS.
WE MAY WANT TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
OTHER OPTIONS WE HAVE.
AGAIN.
I'M WHAT I'M CARTON IS ENOUGH IS
THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR ENTIRE
CDC OUR BUDGET ONE OF THE
LARGEST JUMPS IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS.
IN TERMS OF OUR EXPENDITURES HAS
BEEN.
THE HEALTH CARE PORTION SO IT
MAKES SENSE THAT WE WOULD HAVE
THAT JUMP BECAUSE OF THE WORK
ORDER.
ON THE OTHER HAND AS I HAVE SAID
IN OTHER --
IN EACH ITEM THAT WE TALK ABOUT.
EVERY BIT OF INCREASE IN GENERAL
FUND EXPENDITURE.
WITHIN THE CDC OUR BUDGET.%
IS LESS GENERAL FUND ANY OTHER
STATE.
SO WE CAN GET THAT BREAK DOWN
YES MA'AM SURE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THEM WE HAD DONE A SIMILAR
ANALYSIS ABOUT.
MAYBE FIVE OR SIX YEARS AGO --
IN THE CHART THAT WE DID WE WERE
LOOKING AS I RECALL HOSPITAL
COSTS IT WAS EXACTLY THE CHART
THAT YOU HAVE IN YOUR MIND.
A IS FOR THE LOW LOW LOW AND
THEN THE LAST COUPLE OF THOUSAND
PATIENTS.
END UP BEING 40% OF OUR OVERALL
COSTS IN TERMS OF HOSPITAL COSTS
SO.
THE STAFF WILL BURGER PREPARE
SUCH A REPORT WE'LL SEE WHAT WE
CAN SHARE WITH YOU IF YOU CAN
GET MORE GRANULAR.
WE WANT TO SEE HOSPITAL COSTS
BUT IF IT'S OVER ALL WELL
PHARMACEUTICALS WOULD BE THE
INCLUDED THERE WE WILL LOOK AT
HOW WE CAN GET GREATER DETAIL
FOR YOU.
ON THAT OUR TOPIC THAT ARE --
HAVE SERIES CHRONIC CONDITIONS
MAY NOT BE HOSPITALIZED GROUP
BUT MAY BE.
IN SUCH AN CAPACITY THAT.
WE MAY WANT TO LOOK AT WHAT
OTHER OPTIONS WE MIGHT HAVE.
YES CENTER RUN THIS PROJECT
ISSUE.
THE LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SOME INTERESTING
THINGS THAT'S EARL TO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT THEY DID IS THEY HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER TO
BUILD A?
NEW PRISON.
OUR NEW JAIL IN LA INSTEAD THEY
DECIDED.
TO NOT DO THAT.
AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS
THEY'RE DEVELOPING A PLAN --
FOR INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC.
HOSPITAL.
FACILITIES TO WORK --
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS SO
THEY'RE BUILT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GETTING.
THE SECOND HOSPITALS.
BILL NOW THEY HAVE. TO HAVE THE
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
THE STATE TO DO --
MEDI CAL WAIVER. TO ALLOW THE
INSTITUTE [inaudible]
FOR WHATEVER.
SEC RULE THAT YOU CAN'T HAVE A
HOSPITAL.
OVER TWELVE PATIENTS RIGHT
[inaudible]
RULE [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
NOW
.
THANK YOU ARE
THANK YOU ARE AWESOME
[inaudible]
I WOULD [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
WE HAVE MANY COMMENT FROM EITHER
LA YOUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THEN ON THIS ITEM
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO OUR LAST
NIGHT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
RIGHT AND WE'RE GOING.
TO ALSO UNDER THE RECEIVER.
WHICH IS OUR EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM STAFF.
YOU MORE WE ARE.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
WE HAVE BEFORE USE.
INTRODUCED HER TO ON YOUR WING
YEAH -- ON
OUR END OF BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE YOU ARE THE FIRST THAT WAS
LISTED.
NGUYEN READER DIRECTOR THE PLAN
IN ACTION.
WE'RE REQUESTING LIMóN FUNDING.
TO FULLY IMPLEMENT A EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
WHICH ARE THE PROGRAM N --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WITH INTERNAL
RESOURCES.
ON MEDICAL REST I MEAN IN IN
DOING.
BELIEVE.
IN IT DOES YOUR AND YOU ARE OUR
HELP --
CULTURE.
I REMEMBER AS A GRADUATE --
WOULD LIKE TO EXPAND THAT TO A
NURSE PRACTITIONER RESIDENT THE
TRAINING PROGRAM [inaudible]
CURRENTLY [inaudible]
DO NOT WE HAVE THE WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO DO IS [inaudible]
PROGRAM.
MEN.
AND UP TO A YEAR RESIDENTS
PROGRAM WITHIN OUR INSTITUTIONS
[inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
WOMEN [inaudible]
OUR DEPARTMENT.
WE'RE REQUESTING --
REPORT IS [inaudible]
A REPORT.
IN THE PROGRAM AS WELL AS TO THE
DATA COLLECTION.
AND ALL THE METRIC BEHIND THE
PROGRAM.
TO LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY
MOMENT THEN I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION WHERE THERE ANY COMMENTS
ABOUT EITHER.
OKAY IN ANY PUBLIC COMMENT JUST
LIKE TO TAKE THAT BEFORE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
WITH A ALL RIGHT GREAT.
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR US. TO
APPROVED.
THAT REQUEST ON THE EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS PROGRAM STAFFING --
ROLL CALL [inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER.
I MORLOCK [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL [inaudible]
RIGHT.
I BELIEVE THAT BRINGS US
LOOKBOOKS FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
APPRECIATE --
ALL OF YOUR PARTICIPATION AND
OUR PRESENTATION MARS YVR FROM
OUR STAFF FROM CDC OUR ILIO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
WE ARE NOW.
ADJOURNED